this video is brought to you by genin
impact over the last year I've
documented my experience reading for the
very first time in my life the
incredible story of Naruto the magnum
opus of the now legendary mashi
Kishimoto a man whose life was overnight
turned on its head due in no small part
two The Runaway success of this now
prolific and Incredibly popular series
to kick off this comically enormous
video essay for those of you that have
yet to read or watch this story but
still want to remain spoiler-free here
is my on Line spoiler-free review of the
series Naruto is an incredibly ambitious
Story full of emotional struggle themes
of generational responsibility and
climactic battles the scope of which
would rival the likes of any Shen battle
manga all the while being one of the
most personal and honest musings I've
seen an author offer his audience and
funnily enough over the last year of
reading it the story and character of
Naruto even helped me a little overcome
my my personal struggles as any Great
Character should this is a video
chronicling my very first time ever
watching or reading this story and my
hope is that if nothing else this video
might show you a different way to enjoy
this story a story that took Kishimoto
15 years to write a story that helped
him achieve his dreams and a story that
has over the last two decades reached
millions and millions of people around
the world and in this video you'll see
just one more Fan's journey through
through this wonderful world so what are
we waiting for let's kick things off
where it all begins chapter 1
[Music]
page I got to say right off the bat
picking that first volume up off the
shelf felt terrific while I knew very
little about this story outside of the
main character's name Naruto and that
it's for the most part about ninjas I
was without question acutely aware of
one inali fact that this was a beloved
franchise a story people massively
identified with and that it too has its
detractors sounded very much like Dragon
Ball to me so while picking that first
volume from my shelf I was filled with a
giddy enthusiasm I hadn't felt in years
finally after all this time I was
reading Naruto and
I liked these opening chapters but I
didn't love them in fact I found them to
be a little unfocused if that makes
sense at all but don't worry this video
has a happy ending so sit tight for me
first impressions are important because
you only get one chance to make them in
that same vein the first paragraph of
your novel or the first chapter of your
manga in this case needs to perform a
host of different tricks not only to
hold your attention but to also
introduce you to the main character and
The Wider world the story is set in and
of course there are different ways to go
about performing this narrative
somersault one piece took an approach
adequately representative of what what
would later be recognized as Odis style
a comprehensive and intensely powerful
character-driven story built on the back
of Luffy's ambition hajim is yama's
Attack on Titan 2 I think had a near
perfect first impression on the audience
it was trying to reach establishing its
nail-biting premise the motivations of
the main characters and giving us a
taste of The Wider world's politically
driven infrastructure I knew I was in
for an action-packed political drama the
likes of which I would never forget so
yeah first impressions are important
they're what dictates whether or not
many people will give a story their
attention in the future particularly
when it comes to manga they're released
one chapter at a time after all it's not
like a movie or a book where the rest is
right there for you to digest and
because of this fact many manga begin
their stories with a much longer than
average first chapter to establish what
they want and given that Naruto is still
one of the most successful mangas to
ever be released I was surprised by its
introduction the pacing felt fast almost
too fast I will say though that it did a
decent job at establishing the heartbeat
of Naruto's Journey with him effectively
being the outcast of his community armed
only with a burning desire to become the
next Hokage I enjoyed that aspect of it
seeing Naruto's struggle with his
lessons felt appropriate hearing about
his dream felt intimate and the success
he finds at the end felt adequately
cathartic for a first chapter helped
enormously by kishimoto's fantastic
artistic abilities I mean that two-page
spread of the onetime screw-up Naruto
performing a fantastic clone technique
was given pride of place and rightfully
so I can still picture that stunning
shot right now as I speak there's plenty
I've taken away from this first chapter
that I liked and it was certainly enough
to encourage more reading from me which
I mean is sort of the only job it has
right however along with these
impressive aspects to the opening of the
story so too did it come with some I
don't want to say negatives but it did
leave me scratching my head a little the
character of Uka is given a lot of focus
in this first chapter I can see what
Kishimoto might have been going for here
with him acting as a useful individual
close enough to share intimate moments
with Naruto but far enough away to vent
candid frustrations for us as an
audience to understand within this first
chapter he existed as a vehicle to
deliver information to us about Naruto
and yet when I finished it I didn't feel
particularly close to Naruto but instead
Iuka himself due to the amount of time
we spent with him which might not be a
bad thing but certainly wasn't what I
was expecting nor was it I think what
Kishimoto was aiming for furthermore
there's an enormous amount of exposition
revealed in the first chapter alone I
would argue far more than is even
necessary to make that hook at the end
of the first chapter work thankfully
however as the first few chapters drift
on by I started to feel the story catch
its stride through the introduction of
two crucial
characters before we move on I'd like to
take a moment to touch on a wonderful
little short animation for genin impact
it's only about two or so minutes long
but it's a stunning look at one of the
regions from the game and I think
regardless of how familiar you are with
the series itself it's a remarkably
touching piece it's always neat to see
International collaborations in
animation and that's the case here with
hoyo verse teaming up with French Studio
Sun creature to produce this it's packed
to the brim with the most stunning
backgrounds that the camera lingers over
while understated animation helps to
bring things to life in a very
naturalistic way there's a real emphasis
on the fine detail of the world and it's
all placed against a delicate piano
piece that gives the animation a real
Serene feeling it evokes that same sense
of wonder you might get from watching a
studio jibli movie more than anything
you just want to step inside the frame
and explore and I think that's pretty
genius as you do have the option to
Simply play the game if you want to take
a look yourself I've put a link in the
description for you I'm definitely
curious to see if they'll tackle more
regions in the future as I think this
type of material works great as not only
an advertisement but a legitimate piece
of
[Music]
art I immediately liked Sasuke not only
did I find him well conceived and
conveyed through these introductory
chapters but I also found him to be
exactly what this story needed a rival
character a rival character while having
his own goals that often conflict with
the main character exists primarily to
highlight the significant differences
between himself and the main character
in this case Naruto by being a prodigy
top of his class and sought after by
Sakura Sasuke represents everything that
Naruto isn't and what he yearns to be
and in being such also facilitates
terrific contrasts that highlight
Naruto's greatest attributes his
unflinching desire to never give up and
his roaring passion to achieve his goal
to become the greatest Hokage that ever
lived while a character like Sasuke is
nowadays for lack of a better term
cliche I am a firm believer that often
times creative choices become cliches
for a reason because they work he comes
across as dark serious and single-minded
in his one existing goal to kill a
specific individual that wronged his
family in the past which is great as it
not only gives him a want or desire
different from the others but it's also
perfectly emblematic of of his
no-nonsense personality and embellishes
his already strong contrast with
Naruto's much more light-hearted Persona
helping us to better appreciate Naruto's
strengths while highlighting his
weaknesses the latter of which
developing into an aspect of the story
that drives so much of who Naruto is as
a character in essence I see Sasuke as
the perfect foil for Naruto in this
story all of which can be observed after
our introduction to another character in
Sakura this one was interesting and well
yes in a fun way not always so going
into this given the time this story was
released I was relieved to see that
Sakura wasn't being used for fan service
if you like that sort of thing more
power to you but it's never been for me
in the same way I don't like Mindless
action I similarly don't care much for
Mindless over sexualized characters male
or female my favorite aspect of her
character is how effective she can be as
a comic relief often times she's shown
with massively ere exaggerated
expressions of anger and joy which I
thought added some variety to the mix
furthermore from a narrative mechanical
front if if we lift the hood on this
metaphorical narrative car we can see
that she's clearly and currently
depicted as less of a character and more
of a mechanism to both Naro and Sasuke's
respective roles and encounters which
from a utilitarian perspective is not
only fine but exactly what Kishimoto was
looking for she is a supporting
character to Naruto and Sasuke and
without her these two would have very
little reason to interact with each
other at all thus making her
instrumental not only in making Sasuke
effective in his role but also by
extension responsible for making the
main character Naruto shine she is for
all intents and purposes the Catalyst
that makes all the magic happen between
them in the beginning take for example
Naruto and Sasuke's first ever
interaction in the manga very early on
there's an unrequited love triangle
established between Naruto Sakura and
Sasuke Naruto is interested in Sakura
Sakura hates Naruto but loves Sasuke and
Sasuke loves vengance but my point is
that without Sakura acting as a
connective tissue so to speak between
Naruto and Sasuke Naruto would never
have grown a jealousy for the attention
Sasuke is receiving from Saku and
therefore this would never have happened
and what a shame that would be I don't
want to live in a world where this scene
doesn't exist this was the first moment
of the manga that made me burst out
laughing and to be honest mangas don't
do that often for me so she's a great
tool for comedic hings too which I
appreciate but to be clear her primary
directive at least in these early
chapters is to facilitate this narrative
slight of hand time and again throughout
this Arc and it works in both directions
however this doesn't excuse one glaring
flaw I've noticed and it's probably one
of my biggest pet peeves when it comes
to character writing she exists to serve
other characters and little else her
existing goals are selfish certainly but
the fact that I would have zero idea
what sort of person she'd be like if I
were to remove Naruto and Sasuke from
the equation really serves to highlight
my point at this stage of the story I
mean there's a scene where these three
kids get to introduce themselves to each
other a terrific mechanism for us as an
audience to get to know them better
Naruto's intro is quirking and fun with
a fiery ambition clearly present
Sasuke's is appropriately dark and
serious but sakuras is literally her
saying that she loves Sasuke and hates
Naruto that's it funny enough she's
about to start talking about her other
Hobbies when Kishimoto decides that
that's a good time to cut to Kakashi
making note that she seems to care more
about love than Ninjutsu which brings me
to my main contention with her as a
character her very presence sort of
devalues the entire social structure and
reputation of the school Naruto
struggled to gain acceptance too at this
point in the story she barely says
anything other than wondering where
Sasuke is or how annoying Naruto can be
Naruto does have a large interest in her
an interest that at points in this Arc
drives him to make certain decisions but
he's still able to have other interests
and driving forces in his life outside
of that his main motivation is to become
the next Hokage and that's awesome
absolutely something I can get behind
but if all he wanted to do was to chase
Sakura that would be much less
interesting in short I respect what she
offers the story in terms of of quality
but as a character I not only find her
quite vapid but I also found that at
times her inclusion tends to devalue
what it is they are trying to achieve
but perhaps it's still early days and I
haven't given her a chance to fully
Express who she is as a character and
what she really wants to be fair she is
standing alongside two very well
realized characters and speaking of
contrasts when I picked up volume 2 the
cover brought to my attention something
rather interesting from an artistic
point of view front and center on the
cover we see Sakura Sasuke and Nar a
fairly standard cover considering the
contents of this volume concern them
specifically however in my hunter hunter
review I eventually pointed out what
made gone and kilaa were thoughtfully
designed characters from an artistic
point of view they acted as a great
inversion of colors in the manga when
compared to each other but Kishimoto
takes that to the next level with these
three to compliment Naruto's upbeat and
fiery personality he's given him bright
vibrant orange and yellows everywhere
for Sasuke his dark and more stoic
personality lends better to darker tones
but what makes him particularly
wonderful is only seen in the full color
I mentioned that Sasuke is a wonderful
rival character because he effectively
contrasts and complement Naruto's
personality amplifying his effect well
if we look at a color wheel we can quite
clearly see what the opposite or color
compliment to Orange is it's blue Sasuke
Dons a wonderfully dark blue get up
communicating his darker sensibilities
and highlighting what he represents to
the main character Naruto a contrast but
my friend that's not where this ends I
mentioned before that Sakura is sort of
the connective tissue that brings these
two into contact in many ways she acts
as the midpoint between the two of them
naturally she's going to be colored red
to represent her main driving motivation
love and the word sakur directly
translated means cherry blossom so pink
is a natural inclusion here too but one
look at the color wheel again and you'll
notice that pink and red are exactly
halfway between orange and blue in other
words she is right in the in the middle
between Sasuke and Naruto I love stuff
like this well done
Kishimoto truth be told but the time I
reached chapter 8 I was a little tired
of the current format this first third
of the arc while it did have elements I
enjoyed like the schooling with Kakashi
and the various challenges he presents
them with I still felt like The
Narrative of Naruto and most importantly
what people liked and loved about it
wasn't translating clearly for me school
is usually a sure fire away to create
instances of hij Jinks and conflict but
truth be told there wasn't a of focus
given to it the best part was the bab
Box challenge seeing Sasuke work his
magic and show how much better he is
than the rest was exactly the
reassurance I needed to confidently
press onward into the second third and
fourth volumes and thank God I did I
believe chapter 9 and 10 were where I
went from being undecided about this
story to sincerely enjoying the
experience when reading and reviewing
manga became my job I felt grateful of
course but also concerned as now a hobby
my onetime retreat suddenly became my
job and often times in this line of work
I found psyching myself up to read a
particular volume of manga to be
difficult and with the first few
chapters of Naruto passing one after the
other I felt as though I might be facing
another wall of manga I simply have to
get through but nothing could be further
from the truth with
[Music]
this chapter 9 is a glorious chapter
that while Exposition heavy also carries
with it a palpable and natural Rising
tension I've often said in the past that
pressure more so than conflict gives the
audience a chance to see who the
characters they're following really are
and to this chapter's credit it delivers
just the right amount of exposition to
build up to two payoffs in both this
chapter and the next something that's
very important to me as a Reviewer is
that I connect with on some level what
the author is trying to say and nowhere
is this more crucial than with the main
character having come to know and love
the likes of Goku Luffy the JoJo's and
numerous other wonderful characters over
the span of my life I was deeply
concerned particularly after the rocky
start that I wouldn't connect with
Naruto
but I think I see more of myself in this
little character than any of the others
while I love the Simplicity and grit of
Goku and the kind but tenacious Edge to
Luffy there's something about Naruto
that defines his character that I find
infectious doubt he will work his hands
to the Bone walk the soles off his shoes
and work until he collapses to make up
for what he perceives to be defects or
flaws in his own approach he recognizes
that he's not the most intelligent or
the most talented and were shown as much
thanks to the character of Sasuke and so
being faced with that reality he only
knows how to put his shoulder down and
push himself he has aspirations and he
wants to prove to himself that he's more
than what everyone thought thought he
was and in chapter 9 I learned this
about him having been almost killed
freezing at the first sign of real
danger he's forced to contend with the
fact that Sasuke was ready and he wasn't
and that maybe just maybe those
naysayers from his village were right
and seeing that frustration bubbled
beneath the surface of his expression
was amazing to sit and read through
particularly because it readed us for
what was to come one final thing I
really enjoyed concerning Naruto as a
character in these chapters was how
Kishimoto decided to splice in the
exposition to influence how we might
feel about Naruto as a character after
stabbing his own hand in frustration and
determination not to become a burden to
slow people down Kakashi notices how
fast he's healing from the beginning the
nin tal of fox Spirit trapped inside
Naruto has been a source of all his
longing and suffering he's been made
practically a parias since that faithful
Day by everyone in his community and now
Kishimoto wants us to believe that the
only thing that makes Naruto special is
his n tailed fox Spirit if he does
anything bad then that's to be expected
he has the fox Spirit after all and if
he does anything good now then it too
can be chalked down to that very Spirit
he's infused with but in this chapter
when faced by the mounting pressures
around him instead of freezing like he
did last time he looks to his hand as a
reminder plants his feet and stands up
to someone that just took out his
teacher an impressive Elite level ninja
I don't know what the prevailing
narrative concerning Naruto is online
what people's feelings are towards him
but what impresses me about his
character isn't the ability he was able
to bring out just in time to save the
day but it's the bravery and
determination he showed in the face of a
situation we know he was scared to
tackle it wasn't the action that
preceded it it was the decision to take
that action in the first place and all
of this was helped enormously by the
artwork it should go without saying at
this point that these chapters are
filled with wonderful action of numerous
varieties within which I finally felt as
though I was starting to understand
understand kishimoto's Rhythm as a
layout artist and that Rhythm being when
he's at his best he catches you off
guard he sets something up only for it
to be observed by the elite ninjas and
for them to reverse it on us again and
again and again it's a wonderfully
quirky style of paneling that infuses
wonderfully with the very concept and
theme of the story being
told I've said this before but I love
these types of visually interesting and
conceptually simple training exercises
or challenges for characters stuff like
snake way moving a boulder climbing a
tower or in this case climbing a tree
climbing the tree using chakra is a
really fun and visually interesting idea
for the premise of a chapter but what I
really liked about it was how as soon as
Kakashi mentioned this element the
chakras as something that if one can
Master then nothing is beyond them in
terms of Jutsu a panel is dedicated
specifically to show us Naruto's
expression and it says everything I can
tell that to him to have that question
answered would mean a lot the exercise
in action is a nice bolstering of what I
mentioned earlier about Sakura where
Sasuke exerted twoo much force and
Naruto too little Sakura hit the sweet
spot right in the middle and climb the
tree without the use of her arms in
addition to this being a nice visual and
narrative reminder of what she
represents to the two characters in
question it's honestly nice to see her
exceed in her own unique way ahead of
the other two for a change that is until
one page later where Kakashi says that
the pools of untapped chakra conceal
within Naruto and Sasuke make sakuras
look like nothing that's disappointing
concerning Sakura there is one scene I
really enjoyed her participation in
however with Sakura having already
completed the challenge climbing their
respective trees became a head-to-head
challenge with Sasuke miles ahead of
Naruto through this obviously it's
wonderful to see him slowly catch up
again not necessarily because he's more
talented or a prodigy like SAS is but
because he was willing to ask for help
and take the advice of someone like
Sakura that was successful before him
something Sasuke never thought to do
it's a small moment but it once again
made use of the two supporting
characters in a clever way to amplify
the desired effect of the main character
Naruto in the beginning of this video I
was lukewarm on this story I felt as
though it was a little unfocused or
unconventional which made it difficult
to latch onto and fully enjoy for me
however slowly chapter by chapter scene
by scene as we Advanced further and
farther into this story I grew a
fondness for this world and its
characters unlike stories I've covered
before Naruto was different for one
reason right from the GetGo with Hunter
Hunter it was clear to me it was a dark
dramatic character-driven story first
and foremost the same can be said for
one piece with its strong focus on World
building perhaps more so than any other
story I've read Luffy's Adventure hinges
on its World feeling alive as well as
its numerous colorful characters Attack
on Titan on the other hand was driven by
its premise early on and Dragon Ball by
its comedy and action but when it came
to Naruto I was left under decided for
quite some time I couldn't figure out
what it was that made it so special to
so many people it had some terrific
action endearing comedy an interesting
world and as I've outlined already some
nicely realized characters in the likes
of Naruto Sasuke Kakashi and even Saka
to some extent however at no point did I
feel like it was balanced to favor any
one area of those over the other that
was until I reached the final Encounter
of this
Ark
let's
go when it came to the closing moments
of this Arc within the final chaotic
battle pitting the likes of Sasuke and
Haku against each other and Kakashi and
sabua too it felt as though I finally
began to understand what it was that
Naruto was especially focused on and I
have to say it feels rather unique to
Naruto something I've mentioned a number
of times in this video has been that of
who I think Naruto is and one of the
many reasons why this scene depicting
Naro lost in Anger strikes a chord with
me is that it once again draws a
distinction between who people think he
is and who he actually is it feels
ominous dark coupled that with Kakashi
making mention that he can't feel
Naruto's energy and you have for
yourself something that more closely
resembles a possession than a convenient
chosen one type PowerUp moment erupting
forth from Naruto not because he
summoned it but because he specifically
didn't losing control of who he is for a
split second allowing that demonic
Spirit coiled within him to spring forth
with Savage and Reckless intent and what
stops him in his
tracks the second that power vanishes is
the moment Naruto regains his sense of
self strangely what I thought this scene
shared some commonalities with was
Avatar The Last Airbender within the
first few episodes angs conf conf
fronted with the horror that took place
in his absence once he arrives back at
his air Temple faced with this shock and
disarray he loses himself to the Avatar
State thankfully brought back before he
could hurt anyone by The Loving Embrace
of qara in Naruto similar to Avatar it's
being made evident that the fox spirit
inside Naruto isn't him necessarily and
instead what makes Naruto who he is
similar to Ang was his ability to
control himself before he hurts someone
he cared about and this sentiment of
constantly wanting to try to never give
up and to control whatever you can makes
itself known at new numerous wonderful
instances during the story none perhaps
more powerful than through inari's
flashbacks Naruto not only feels an
obligation to help people but
particularly those that he sees himself
in perhaps because he's a good person
but also perhaps these lost toys more so
because he empathizes with their
situation specifically with Haku and
Inari acting as two sides of that Naruto
coin in a sense Inari thankfully had
someone in Naruto to instill a positive
outlook on his situation leading to his
eventual and fantastic save at the end
but on the other hand we have someone
like Haku a character with an Outlook so
disastrously unfortunate and tragic that
it's almost difficult to accept that he
has so much incommon with our main
character Naruto in the first place with
his untimely and frankly harrowing end
coming moments after this heart to heart
and through this horribly sad end to a
fantastic battle something inside my
head clicked I mentioned towards the
beginning of the story that I found the
start somewhat rough around the edges
unfocused and IL defined however now
having completed the first Arc and
having gotten a taste of what this story
really is all about this story Naruto
feels perfect as a story penned by
Masashi Kishimoto at the beginning of
the very first volume I picked up
Kishimoto wrote a short paragraph
Thanking us for our support of his dream
Overjoyed he wrote that this was the
happiest moment of his life unlike Akira
Toriyama someone he admired and looked
up to kishimoto's path to success wasn't
as straightforward nothing seemed to
come easy to him time and again he'd
face rejection after rejection at every
corner all in a desperate attempt to
achieve his dream of one day breaking
into the manga industry it's not
difficult to see the parallels he's
drawn between his personal experiences
and the beginning of Naruto's story The
Journey of a young unwanted orphan child
tenaciously and earnestly pursuing his
dreams despite his detractors and in no
more fitting or poetic a fashion
together both Kishimoto and Naruto help
each other to achieve their respective
dreams speaking as a creative myself one
of the biggest difficulties in my
professional life has been my family's
initial disapproval of my vocation but
at no point could I ever see myself
doing anything other than this I love my
job exhausting and stressful as it may
be at times I love this and I think
that's why I tend to fall in love with
characters that have a strong sense of
self Above All Else characters like
Luffy someone that no matter what it
takes will in an unflinching fashion
March onward towards his goal it's
inevitable he will be the pirate king or
Goku someone I found a lot of comfort in
as a kid growing up to him nothing ever
seemed insurmountable he was never
scared and to this day the effect this
moment has had on me can be felt Naruto
however isn't like either of these two
he's me you us he's that kid that has a
chip on his shoulder something to prove
someone that doesn't know for certain if
he will achieve his dreams but God damn
it he's going to push himself until he
cannot push himself any further it is
for that reason among so many others I
can't help but root for Naruto when he
fights for his dreams and it's why I've
developed a special fondness for
kishimoto's story it's still no Dragon
Ball Hunter Hunter Jojo and certainly
not a one piece but it doesn't have to
be it's Naruto it's mashi Kishimoto
pouring his heart out and it's created
something that at least to me feels
entirely different it's something that
was unbelievably special to one person
in the beginning and became special to
Millions around the world today and I
think finally I understand that feeling
and it's only the beginning little did I
know I was about about to read an arc
that would exceed any and every
expectation I've had for this series so
far Naruto seems to be full of
[Applause]
[Music]
surprises funny thrilling philosophical
and stunningly depicted the cheting
exams are a monument to what Kishimoto
can do and I can't wait to discuss what
I thought worked so damn well and one or
two areas where I was a little unsure
right from the get go of this Arc it
wastes no time at all establishing what
the goals of our main Trio will be and
what the goal of the Ark is where I felt
the first arc's prologue was weighed
down by its establishing of these
characters causing it to feel a little
rough around the edges this Arc by
comparison is a finely polished gem
utilizing all the pre-existing
relationships we're familiar with to
bolster the motivations of the
characters in this story being told Here
Naruto still wants to prove himself and
to become the next hakaj and now he has
the chance to achieve the level of
journeyman Ninja n the same level as
iruka his only Father Figure and one
that throughout this Arc makes it clear
that he believes that Naruto and Co are
not ready and confronts Kakashi about
this directly it's cute and it adds more
drama going into the exams for us and
makes us ask the question what would
these exams be like Sasuke's motivation
is in comparison a lot more simple or at
least it is early on he's sick of going
on meaningless nothing missions that
don't push his abilities from the very
beginning his character has had one
Express motivation to avenge his family
and this Arc explores that facet of his
character in much greater detail than
the first did as he expresses excitement
over finally getting a chance to test
his abilities against worthy adversaries
the results are some of the most
shocking moments in the series so far
however for me the best part about these
pre-exam buildups has to be the
indication we get of something
meaningful finally happening to the
character of Sakura one of the biggest
issues I personally found with her
character was that at least compared to
the other characters she didn't really
have much depth she felt less like a a
character and more like a useful
mechanism in the story to create either
tension between characters or to insert
comedy and while those attributes are
important in a story they don't make a
great character in my mind and so the
choice to give her plenty of
characterization in the leadup to the
exams was exactly what I thought she
needed this feeling of being less than
being left out and not having the belief
in herself to press onward to have the
courage to fail for me this injection of
doubt and conflict in her mind not only
made sense given her company and what
she has done or not done but also
because again gave her the chance to
Rally herself right before the
application process ended it helped me
build a relationship with her as a
character which was exactly where I
thought she was lacking and now as this
Trio marches confidently into an exam
many see as far above their current
level We Begin this story and the
characters we meet along the way are
what make this as magical and intense A
Tale As It ultimately becomes so I guess
it's time to start the TuneIn
preliminary exams within the story there
are three preliminary exams followed by
the finals dozens and dozens of cell
groups enter and only a handful of
participants will make it past these
prelims I've seen many tournament or
exam arcs in my day but none like this
there's an element to this that really
makes it stand out and I plan on
addressing it as I go so let's start
with the first test
[Music]
not the written exam as soon as I
gathered that the focus of this Arc
would be an exam where students and
future prospects would face each other
in what I assumed at the time would be
hand-to-hand combat the chances of
promotion I got extremely excited I've
made it clear in the past that some of
my favorite storytelling devices or
settings are these which follow a
predetermined and easily understood
format tournaments and exams all offer
wonderful moments for characterization
to lead the charge on top of offering
numerous wonderful chances to get to
know new characters and given that
Kishimoto was a massive fan of airat
toriyama's Dragon Ball I wasn't
surprised in the slightest that just
like his Idol kishimoto's second Arc to
featured a similar format focus on
progressing to later rounds however what
I wasn't anticipating was the creative
approach he took numerous stories and
series Rest In The Laurels of the
examine tournament format relying on it
to carry the majority of the creative
weight while they focus on
characterization there's nothing wrong
with this approach and many have used it
effectively Dragon Ball was one of the
earliest adopters of this format and in
being such was quite straightforward and
by the books in its approach however
when I saw that Kishimoto wrote the
first part of this exam to be a written
paper test I was completely taken off
guard in fact I think I laughed out loud
when faced with the concept initially
the idea that he would attempt to make
entertaining something as mundane and
Visually boring as writing felt not only
like narrative suicide but also grabbed
my attention the same way a train wreck
might different series have made writing
compelling in the past like death note
but I couldn't see something like that
working for a story like Naruto at paper
test just seemed like a bad idea but I
could not have been more wrong slowly I
started to understand Not only was this
going to work as an interesting section
of the story but it was I think a genius
and unique utilization of this story's
particular strengths I'm specifically
referring to its premise and themes and
once I caught onto the fact that they
were being encouraged to cheat in order
to pass coupled with Naruto's innate
inability to understand abstract
Concepts at the best of times made not
only for a compelling set of humorous
and dramatic scenes but present what I
thought was one of the most brilliant
challenges possible for a ninja themed
exam I would never have thought of it
and something like this can only really
work in a story like this about ninja
training it's so damn good this exam's
format follows in principle a very
similar path to that of the old ten
kichi pakai from early Dragon Ball
wherein the preliminary matches before
the main course set up the rivalries
established the villains and her other
main characters that will participate
later while at this stage in the early
2000s that particular format was
somewhat tired and done this Innovation
on those principles in this new setting
offered all the same benefits in a new
way I've never experienced in the last
video I never understood the love some
people had for the character of Sakura
but with the introduction of these
written exams my opinion on her
completely changed in addition to
helping establish new characters like G
Hinata and Lee it also made me do a 180
on the character of sakuro with her
intelligence on full display proving to
us that she's more intelligent than even
Sasuke carving out her own little niche
in the group ending on a thunderously
powerful philosophical note where the
examiner does the unthinkable he
presents the class with a dilemma either
take question 10 get it wrong and fail
or bail now and try again next year here
apart from this once again taking me off
guard with its immediate high stakes the
philosophy that came from it not only
once again felt appropriate for the
themes and setting of this world but
again highlighted all the strengths of
the Naruto character himself the
character that looked the worst during
this written portion ended it with the
most Promise by proving himself in a
different way and so taking a step back
to appreciate everything this section
achieved these prelims both right before
and after successfully highlighted the
main antagonists established the
strengths and weaknesses of the main
characters and got me so damn excited
for what was to come I've read every
dragon ball tournament the hunter exams
of Hunter Hunter and the opening arcs of
my hero Academia but none came even
remotely close to the level of
efficiency and creativity these chapters
impressed me with major kudos to
Kishimoto for this section it's no small
feet to TI all the boxes the way he's
done here comfortably it is my favorite
part of the story so
far the forest of death the concept
surrounding this section was interesting
to say the least while less focused in
the prior and slightly more conventional
the opportunities this Hunger Games type
format offered should be clear there's a
reason TV shows like Allison Borderlands
and Squid games have become so popular
in recent years placing contestants into
a battle royale type setting buying for
their lives has Limitless possibilities
for drama comedy and conflict all within
creative and seldom seen set pieces and
this challenge was no different however
funnily enough this was a challenge that
really helped me come to grips with some
of the more intense themes of the story
and at first I didn't completely
understand in the prior exam iiki the
lead examiner for the written test said
before that test that and I quote from
this point there will be no more
fighting without the express permission
of the examining officer and even if
that permission is granted anything that
endangers another applicant's life is
strictly forbidden it seemed
straightforward enough I thought no
killing each other and as the remaining
kids signed the document waving this
rule of no killing my mind's immediate
first thought was that this must be a
bluff on behalf of the examiners to
create a high-stake simulation for their
future young talents I thought okay they
each get one of two types of scroll and
must retrieve the second type within the
aot of time I immediately thought an
interesting concept would be that they
all had the same color scroll and that
those that managed to listen to the
prior rules outlined by AI would survive
While others would succumb to the
pressure and take more drastic and
drastic measures as time went on or
something like that there were countless
directions for it to go and it ended up
going in a direction I never saw
coming
in an effort to tryy and outthink the
story I overthought the story while it
ended up delivering one of the most
straightforward blows that shook me to
my very core I should put this on a
shirt at this point for how frequently I
say it but placing characters under
pressure is a great mechanism to help
build a relationship between your
characters and the audience reading or
watching everything that transpires in
moments of high stress and high stakes
feels authentic it can make a bad
character feel more evil and a good
character feel more righteous and in
these high press scenarios Modo reveals
that the person attacking the group of
Sakura Naruto and Sasuke is a murderer
it's a chilling Revelation that suddenly
changes the entire Vibe of the exam
someone by the name of Orochimaru has
stolen the face of an examin killing
them in the process identity theft is
not a joke Jim he's someone of
tremendous danger and one far above the
likes of Naruto and Sasuke in skill
Orochimaru is unlike any of the other
characters I've encountered in this
series in the same way Zoro felt when he
first Tangled with mihawk back on the
Bader I felt like this encounter was
equally as unexpected and demonstrated
an enormous Gap in ability between the
characters there's a tremendous amount
of emphasis placed on Sasuke as he's the
target of Orochimaru due to his lineage
but for me the highlight of this section
has to be Sakura once Orochimaru leaves
his mark on Sasuke reveals that he knows
more than he's letting on concerning his
past and places Sakura in a situation
that actually made me feel so much
sympathy for her I was left a little
stunted within a single chapter
Kishimoto flipped the script on this
entire exam Downing both Naruto and
Sasuke thus placing a tremendous amount
of pressure on Sakura with no one to
rely on exhausted from lack of sleep and
terrified of everything around her for
fear of what might happen to Sasuke and
Naruto she stays by their side as
Vigilant as she can be it's an
incredibly endearing set of scenes that
demonstrate her strengths brilliantly
when the cards were down and she needed
to protect her friends she without
hesitation was willing to place her life
on the line for them even when she knows
that she's going to
lose
what begins is a brilliant sequence of
scenes dedicated to the struggle and
tenacity of Sakura builds up into a
fight for survival incorporating a host
of different characters revealing their
backgrounds and motivations for better
or worse Lee remains to be one of the
best boys and most likable characters in
this series fighting with his heart on
his sleeve God bless him and I can't
help but admit that I see a little too
much of myself in him at times and while
Brave his participation is one that
stayed with me for the longest time
during the force of death sequence
drawing distinct and obvious parallels
to the character of Naruto in his
admiration for Sakura and his
determination to improve and save those
that need
him Sasuke in this sequence appears more
vulnerable than ever before there's a
terrifying collection of scenes where
something horrific is awoken with in
Sasuke feeding off his desire for
Revenge apart from looking very
impressive both in the anime and the
manga this section impressed upon me
something I hadn't considered before
another contrast Sasuke provides Naruto
specifically in this series where Naruto
has had a demon sealed away inside him
without his consent and chosen to fight
against it to make it his own Sasuke has
been given one specifically because of
his goals and actions Naruto's goals
fight to free him from his prison and
Sasuke serve to become his undoing
unlike Naruto who wants to be the best
he can be Sasuke specifically is more
more over the course of this story
becoming more and more consumed both
figuratively and literally by his desire
to kill his brother and so while this is
just speculation if he is to fulfill his
role in the story to contrast Naruto it
stands to reason that the closer Naruto
gets to realizing his goal Sasuke will
become more and more consumed by his
it's a remarkably interesting Dynamic
and I can't wait to see how it plays
[Music]
out
G's characterization is terrifying and
in this scene he single-handedly crushes
my prediction that killing would be off
limits what a messed up exam overall
taking into consideration the final
segment of these force of death hunger
scroll Tag Games the vibe I'm left with
is one of hope that leaves me with a
chill in my spine we met and came to
know so many wonderful characters in
these challenges saw each and every one
of the main Trio experience hardship
only to rise to the occasion and
overcome some more so than others and it
helped to establish in a rather
mysterious fashion the most intimidating
villain of the series continuing the
trend from the previous written exam
while this one was much longer it wasn't
in any way less creative or
action-packed in my opinion these TuneIn
exams thus far have been an absolute
treat and have given me everything I
love from the traditional Shonen format
action comedy heart and even tenderness
through Ira at the end as he welcomes
his adoptive kid brother into his own
leagues of journeyman ninjas there's a
palpable sense of love between these two
characters and a wonderful sense of
progression to boot I loved this section
and overall with this force of death
sequence was an adventure as a quick as
side something I want to keep my eye on
is the examiner anko that encountered
Orochimaru and got his sign on her neck
she seems to have gone through the same
metamorphosis as Sasuke's so let's see
how this progresses with her down the
line let's get ready to
this changes everything I felt about the
story of Naruto and took what was I
thought a more kid-friendly world and
plunged it into a much more dark screwed
up and politically driven Universe which
isn't a bad thing at all if anything
this creates a nice contrast with the
Plucky and upbeat Persona of Naruto
himself however it does bring to my
attention a few things worth mentioning
having children hunt and kill each other
is kind of screwed up even if for the
sake of argument I were to remove my
human ity from the equation and just
look at this scenario Through The Eyes
of a coldblooded utilitarian it's such a
tremendous waste of future potential
that could make something of themselves
and serve the respective Villages one
day I mean I made the joke earlier about
this force of death sequence being like
The Hunger Games but at least in that
book series people were selected for
that with only one person who
volunteered to be the standout of the
games themselves there's a tragic nature
to these events that paint shobi as
tools of Destruction conflict and
nothing more pawns for political gain in
my previous video I didn't touch on it
very much but the relationship between
Haku and Zabuza is very much in keeping
with this notion Haku viewed himself as
a weapon to be used for the betterment
of the only person who cared for him and
Zabuza too felt that way as a ninja
broadly speaking it's tragic it's
horrific and to hear the Hokage of all
people speak so frankly about what they
are fighting for while interesting is
really unsettling in a lot of ways
effectively speaking confidently and
candidly to the remaining successful and
talented contestants of but how
disposable they are in this world events
like the force of death where they weed
out the weaker ones is normal adding a
much more Sinister tone to the likes of
anko who stated that she wanted to cut
the numbers down by half at least at the
very beginning and as we have that
horrific taste in hers concerning the
lack of humanity it's time for the
tournament to further Whittle down their
numbers there are some significantly
important matches and thrilling
spectacles to be certain but the
majority of them weren't too interesting
from a narrative point of view so I'll
only be sharing my thoughts concerning
what caught my
attention Sasuke versus yoroi while
short I thought this fight between
Sasuke and Yuro did everything it needed
to with the little it was given but what
makes this section interesting isn't
necessarily the fight itself but the
conversation that follows between
Kakashi and Orochimaru and just like the
hak moments ago his words the arch
villain of the series so far Echo his
exact sentiments concerning Shinobi in a
sense that these people are expendable
and we're reminded of this towards the
end of Yo's fight with Sasuke as he
fights his curse and once again in Shino
versus zaku a scene so powerfully
punctuated by orochimaru's onetime lacky
getting his arms literally destroyed
from the inside out it's horrific and
made all the worse as were given a
fleeting glimpse into the world of this
young man's history with Orochimaru
seconds before this story has gone from
strength to strength when it comes to
its implementation of themes and pacing
and while melancholic this scene is no
different
[Music]
Sakura versus Eno I never spoke about
Eno earlier in this video despite her
being directly involved in a number of
scenarios but Eno is another character
that gets some decent shine in
Exposition here and a chance to show her
true colors from a foundational
perspective I enjoy her popular girl
demeanor and character design but just
like Sakura in the last AR she suffers
from issues stemming from Sasuke being a
massive driving force in her life
however and this is a big however she
does offer Sakura a means to further
distance her yourself from this mindset
again I want to reiterate that really
liking a boy or someone in a story isn't
a sin or even a Bad Thing necessarily
but what's made me like Sakura all the
more lately has been her ability to
fight against her demons and in the case
of her defense of Sasuke her
insecurities fighting tooth and nail to
protect those she cared for all the
while earning the respect of those
around her this was a brilliant moment
from The Forest of death and it's one of
the reasons why I found this fight
against Eno to be so incredibly
frustrating not because it's bad far fr
it's amazing there's a touching story
filled with impactful gestures symbolism
and touching character writing however
there's also
this now look I understand that in some
cases particularly for the purposes of
deception and Espionage leaning into
some more feminine qualities or
embracing said qualities is important
for young female ninja prospects to be
able to wield that makes sense as a
concept but Kishimoto I found whenever
he tries to write a female character
like a female character
he does so in a fashion that convinces
me he's never seen or spoken to a woman
ever in his life there are some
brilliant visual metaphors demonstrating
Sakura's flowering personality and her
independence like when she takes off her
headband emblematic of her taking off
the security blanket her onetime friend
Eno gave her and that's brilliant but
throughout this chapter instead of these
two having a meaningful rivalry over
something philosophically profound or
substantial like the other fights I'm
constantly reminded that this is a
rivalry over Sasuke's affection however
looking past that there's as I said so
much to like about this fight from its
strategic action set pieces all the way
to its terrific use of the way Kishimoto
has depicted Sakura since the beginning
with her inner Sakura overriding Eno's
control Power it's such a brilliant and
creative idea and really while female
character writing isn't his strong suit
creative implementation of these
techniques certainly is and I'm
delighted this fight got some of that
too I'm a little Bumm that it ended in a
tie but at the end of the day it's still
the best fight so far and I think what I
like about this section of the arc
really is how much emphasis it places on
the secondary and supporting characters
while Naruto does pick up the victory in
his bout later on there's not a
tremendous amount that happens apart
[Music]
from heata versus Nei to be perfectly
honest of all the fights in this section
and trust me there's a Balls to the-
Wall fight to end all fights in this
section in a second this fight first
between Hinata and her cousin Nei
totally took me off guard and turned out
to be incredible I had no idea the quiet
girl and this person I didn't know the
name of before would have one of the
best fights of the tournament there's a
palpable resentment with heaps of
political undertones broiling right
beneath the surface as Nei expresses her
resentment towards Hinata's family
Branch all the while Hinata tries to
overcome her shortcomings and in timid
nature to give nii a far more
competitive bout than anyone ever
expected from her she's been one of the
only classmates of Naruto to actually
show him some admiration and respect
when it's due and I like how this fight
has Echoes of what made Naruto special
because of that she's able to recognize
what makes him strong and all throughout
this Arc she's sort of being the only
characters to believe in or care for him
and during this fight The Dominoes fall
and I come to realize why she wants that
sort of self-belief for herself it's
easily one of the best fights and
kishima does a terrific job of
characterizing Hinata as someone of
interest funnily and ironically enough
in writing Hinata Kishimoto managed to
write a more compelling female character
than the likes of perhaps Sakura and
certainly Eno
[Music]
G versus Rock Lee there it is there it
is oh my God before going into this
fight without knowing the source of
these names I had heard through the grap
find that G versus Rock Le was something
special I wasn't even 100% sure of which
anime it came from but this be a good
one it was mentioned during the force of
death exam that G's sand abilities
happened without him needing to think
and this turns out to be the antithesis
of Rock Lee who had to work for every
single thing he ever achieved unlike G
he wasn't born with this innate ability
to perform sand manipulation as if he
were a master of ultra Instinct but the
initial back and forth between these two
fighters plays to the advantages this
setup provides to G is set up to be this
immovable object this unbeatable foe one
that has never even had an attack land
on him and so early on we not only see
what G versus Rockley is but also the
battling between two different
approaches to work Natural Born talent
and innate ability versus hard work for
earned power A Tale As Old As Time
certainly and it's performed to
tremendous effect here a genius versus a
genius of hard work there's short
glimpses we get to see into Lee's early
life that paint a very similar picture
to that of Naruto's upbringing
surrounded by naysayers yelling at him
to quit reprimanding him for his
failings and insulting him for his lack
of natural ability when his master guy
walked up to him and called him a genius
of hard work I actually teared up a
little bit it's such a moving sentiment
that really captures the essence of this
character and in this fight Rock Le just
goes full-blown kaio-ken this is
the coolest ever I haven't spoken
about this much as of yet but the
choreography and scope of this
particular fight is unlike anything I've
seen from this series to date there are
some absolutely breathtaking layouts and
the philosophical message brimming with
hope promise and determination is enough
to win my affections many many times
over and all of this is turned up to 11
in the anime's adaptation thankfully my
team gave me specific episodes they
deemed as must-watch episodes before I
recorded these reviews to get my full
experience and G versus Rockley is
remarkably well produced in the anime
particularly for the early 2000s with
its use of CG backgrounds if you happen
to have seen my Attack on Titan video AJ
wrote some cool sections about one of
the earliest usages of 3D backgrounds in
conjunction with 2D animation to pull
off some insane sequences that inspired
the iconic action seen in that show and
it was this particular episode that
kicked things off directed by Toshi Yuki
tsuru who I've been told is a legendary
name in this franchise this episode
switches things up by swapping to 3D
backgrounds which although haven't aged
well in places did allow for some
spectacularly ambitious sequences from
the likes of iconic animator noro
Matsumoto it's all so Dynamic and the
fact that this was possible on a TV
schedule back in the early 2000s is
astonishing turns out that it was matsum
Motu who also animated the amazing
sequences in the forest of death episode
I was told to watch and that was insane
I've been absolutely loving the
choreography in the manga so to see
these legendary staff members Elevate
even further the material was really
cool AES got me set up with all the
animation highlights for the future so
I'm definitely excited to see more here
for now back to the manga as wonderful
as gar is a dancing partner in this
instance to bring out the best of Lee
it's Lee's Mentor guy that ends up
carrying the bulk of this bout's emotion
weight along with his lovable precious
Protege you can see in his eyes that
what Lee represents and is fighting for
matters greatly to him that he not only
can look on and enjoy the show but is
very much inspired by this young kid too
it's an outstandingly brilliant fight
easily the best I've seen so far in the
series and Kishimoto managed to achieve
this level of personal emotional
involvement from me without using any of
his main characters utterly spectacular
stuff
for this section of the story is largely
set up with it primarily providing us
with the chance to catch up with the
plot lines concerning orochimaru's plan
to steal away Sasuke the history of the
fourth Hokage and the various finalists
preparing in their own ways for the
respective upcoming Final bouts in the
TuneIn exams this is all fun and
enjoyable but it's rather standard
however while reading through this
section I did find something worth
perhaps remarking upon a large portion
of this waiting phase is spent following
Naruto's preparation to fight in these
final matches in these he trains with a
flamboyant Mentor called Jah who can
summon a giant frog it's humorous at
times despite the fan service however
what's interesting about this is what it
made me notice I've mentioned this
before but air toyama's Dr slump and
Dragon Ball were massive influences on
Kishimoto and Naro by extension and
nowhere was this more obvious to me than
with this specific
scene years back I wrote a series of
videos wherein I attempted to break down
how I understood certain characters in
The Dragon Ball series worked what made
the likes of Vegeta Piccolo Frieza and
many others tick in a sense and in them
I pointed out that one of the most
simple and effective narrative mechanics
Toriyama implemented was through the
character of sun Gohan High highed
perfectly in this
[Applause]
[Music]
scene we're all familiar with Gohan's
hidden reserves of strength only brought
forth through danger and it looks as
though in his admiration of Dragon Ball
he created in Naruto a character with
the determination of Goku but with the
mechanics of Son Gohan couple that with
his color scheme toad hermit mentor and
it's not hard to see the similarities
with that of Akira toriyama's early
material but where this scene and Naruto
himself deviates as a character comes
moments after he's thrown in the case of
Gohan his inner power was IL defined and
left to occupy our minds as pure
speculation it never came from anywhere
other than him ironically he is more of
a claim to a chosen one type power than
Naruto does in this way in Naruto's case
Kishimoto decided to depict a scene
inside Naruto's mind where he confronts
his literal inner demon directly I
thought this was a really cool idea and
what I didn't think would happen it's
brief but even so it's full of character
Naruto doing what he does best when he's
caught off guard act tough resulting in
the intimidating Beast trapped within to
aqus and lend Naruto the necessary
chakra to save his own and by extension
the fox spirit's life it's definitely
one of the most interesting developments
for the Naruto character thus far and I
was extremely excited to see where this
one
went
I thought the purpose of this scene was
brilliant isolating what makes gar tick
as a person and just like I pointed out
with the likes of Haku in the first Arc
Naruto seems to have a great emotional
maturity for these particular kinds of
lost toy characters empathizing with
their situation even in the case of G
where he's saying some of the most
reprehensible stuff mirroring the main
character offering an example of him in
an alternate world through through the
likes of a more unfortunate character
that didn't have positive figures in his
life like Naruto did really serves to
highlight what makes him wonderful I
mentioned that Naruto is a character
that's designed to sort of look better
when he's punching up fighting on the
back foot like Gohan was effectively
whenever an opportunity present himself
to show courage and this is a character
that due to Naruto's intimate
understanding of what makes him tick
knows the lengths of how far he's
willing to go Naruto's being a character
that shows a Brash bravado in
practically every encounter he's
participated in even up against the
ninetail Fox Spirit the reason he feels
comfortable in doing so is for a myriad
of reasons but one particularly stands
out in this case more often than not he
knows he's willing to push himself
farther than anyone because he needs to
but now he's met someone that's just as
willing to do that and suddenly Naruto
starts to shake brilliant scene similar
to Sasuke in this sense this is a
villain that's tailor made to make
Naruto look amazing placing him on a
back foot we don't often see him perform
on and I can't wait to see this fight
now tunin finally exams I'm going to be
glancing over some of these fights in
the same way the manga did while there
were story reasons for one of them being
entirely skipped over narratively I
really did feel like all the emphasis
was on these two fights between Naruto
and nji and Sasuke and Garda both were
amazing for very different reasons and I
will be chatting about them in detail
but one fight I won't be covering that
much of will be shikamaru's he'll say it
himself it's not what anyone came to see
but with that said he had a decent
showing for a chapter or two with some
fun and creative action sequences I
really liked his shadow speciality and
its implementation in this fight
specifically it's super fun and he's
super smart you're so smart I'm going to
throw up hold
[Music]
on did dear
C Naruto versus Nei the climax of this
fight shows firsthand to Nei someone
that believes someone's fate is
determined at Birth that you can change
your fate all of Naruto's life he was
told that he would be nothing special
that even if he did have potential he
was a cursed child burdened with a fox
spirit and right now in this fight
Naruto uses this as a strength I loved
watching this fight and honestly it
might be the best Naruto fight thus far
that I've seen Kishimoto has done a
terrific job of providing this young kid
with a host of interesting adversaries
to fight and bring out the very best in
him I've mentioned already why G is a
powerful fo to Naruto as he shares a
similar background but went a different
direction in his life but Nei on the
other hand instead of having a similar
upbringing channels a philosophy that
runs counter to Naruto's obsessed with
and convinced that everyone's fate is
predetermined that they are all hamsters
running on Wheels against a tide that
none of them could possibly overcome or
overturn the exact opposite of Naruto's
mindset and showing this orphan child
Channel everything in his power to grab
the victory was powerfully cathartic
with him effectively using all of his
weak points and insecurities as
strengths against his opponent and by
the way when Naruto erupts from the
floor with that massive uppercut to take
out the pompous Nei I actually punched
my fist to the sky and shouted yes it's
a brilliant fight and for the first time
this one time Lon receives the agulation
of his peers once mocked for who he was
the determination he's shown in the face
of adversity has delivered him the stage
that he deserves a Victor's welcome the
message of this fight being believing in
possibilities can give you the power to
change your destiny what an empowering
and uplifting
philosophy Sasuke versus gar something
I've noticed in this manga particularly
this week after I had to read like nine
volumes of them is that there aren't
really that many full page spreads
kishimoto's paneling doesn't feel
cluttered but he doesn't often go all
out with a full page spread too often
and that can be a strength as seen in
this fight here he really goes out to
make this feel like the spectacle it
deserves to be ever since the 1- Monon
training began Sasuke has had a question
mark hanging over his head after what he
went through in the forest of death and
the qualifiers immediately thereafter
when he eventually shows up for this
final showdown with gar we learn that
he's been training with Kakashi and the
way the two of them are revealed on the
page has a terrific sense of occasion
thanks to kishimoto's framing the fight
in addition to that gets a tremendous
amount of shine too and for all intents
and purposes this is Sasuke's highlight
re with the very creepiest from gar
making itself known to us as he slowly
starts to lose his mind I don't think
it's an understatement to say that this
is an incredibly important fight and
just as Sasuke whips out what looks like
to be his big finishing move the ark
takes a turn for the
[Music]
worst this Arc has been utterly
spectacular and has shown me tons of
stuff both to analyze and keep in mind
moving forward there's a massive
political upswing in this upcoming
material I feel and a war most likely I
think I'm finally starting to understand
why Naruto became the cultural icon it
is
today a main feature of this story and
indeed its world since I began covering
it has been the Hokage their history
what they represent what they've done
and who will next be selected as the
fifth Hokage given that the fourth died
long before this series began in a
battle to save the Earth and that the
third is now very old and sort of in the
clutches of Orochimaru facing almost
certain death the selection of the fifth
Hokage is up in the air and of vital
importance to secure The Village's
future and thus are the circumstances
and Stakes heading into this video's
material and speaking of which I think
this might be the best opening an arc
has received since I started reading
effectively the world Naruto's grown up
in is suddenly plunged into chaos and
ruin while the first two ARS Land of
Waves and the tunin exams began in
absolute stability this one begins in
utter chaos the very best of the best
are being backed up against the wall all
the while Naruto Sakura and Shikamaru
are being ordered to chase after Sasuke
to stop him from overextending himself
with the expressed order that once they
achieve their assignment they need to
wait for further instructions I can only
imagine the anxiety that would flow
through me if I was assigned something
like that effectively being asked to run
from home on a rescue mission of sorts
not knowing if I'll ever return to see
my community in the same state ever
again there's such unbelievably high
stakes with the entire infrastructure of
this world hanging in the balance it's
such an unbelievably effective attention
grabbing opener that flows brilliantly
from the abrupt conclusion to the tunin
exams prior furthermore I can absolutely
appreciate why pursuing gar is immensely
important to the likes of Sasuke on a
narrative level and it all ties back to
his foundational motivations from the
first and second chapters Sasuke's
expressed interest before the tuning
exams even began was to fight worthy
adversaries to increase his strength and
proficiency as a ninja this is to of
course accomplish his one goal to kill
his brother knowing that his brother is
much stronger than him Sasuke needs to
be as sure as he can possibly be once he
does eventually track him down that he
has the strength to do what he wants and
so G is a new Focus why because gar is
the first training ninja in the history
of the exams to finish the forest of
death in that time frame and without
sustaining any damage in other words gar
at this point is stronger than Sasuke's
brother was when he underwent this
challenge of course assuming he
underwent this Challenge and so proving
to himself that he can defeat gar is a
great indicator of how strong Sasuke is
relative to his brother at this point in
his life and the eventual pursuit of
Sasuke by the likes of Naruto Shikamaru
and Sakura is really fun incorporating a
diverse number of characters not limited
to Gar himself eventually but of the
battles leading up to that effort
shikamaru's is the best I think working
in a very similar fashion to his prior
conflict during the tuning exams that
against another of the sand Village's
best and brightest he's really wiy over
with his relaxed laid-back and
calculated approach to everything
formulating a plan of action in seconds
against the pursuing bad guys all within
a frenzied Panic furthermore Shikamaru
during this sequence brought to my
attention an in Universe explanation
that excuses for me one of the most
irritating aspects of modern and classic
anime with this Shadow possessing power
there's now an in Universe reason for
people to stand around blustering and
talking their hearts out with no action
thanks to his special Shadow ability but
that's not the only fight that starts
taking place towards the beginning of
this section it's time
for Orochimaru versus the third Hokage
hiru Zen when I first started reading
this fight one of the things I didn't
expect to show its face were the levels
of sentimentality it ended up
brandishing there are some powerful
moments of reflection on behalf of hiru
Zen himself with his confrontations
against his resurrected Masters all the
while who's forced to contend with his
onetime star pupil Orochimaru and when
you lay out the material like that it's
easy to see the obvious opportunities
for emotional connection but the way
this fight Paces itself and dishes out
fascinating Exposition both about
Orochimaru as a child his relationships
with Huen and of course the history of
Huen himself as a youth you can't help
but feel that much more invested and
connected to these characters not to
mention the world they're involved with
the story in question is called Naruto
but this fight while having little to
nothing to do with that character stands
on its own two feet and breeds new life
into the story The Action itself
although feeling less like Ninjutsu now
and more like Elemental bending on the
scale of avatar The Last Airbender
provides more spectacle than pretty much
anything we've seen before this point
and it reminded me of how old Huen
really must be now like many different
stories both from the East and the West
the older Mentor character is a
stereotype that depicts someone as
decrepit one moment while in another
moment showing everyone else up in
Naruto while this is still somewhat true
with this character it doesn't
romanticize the toll aging has had on
the great third Hokage with time itself
and the passage of it being a major
focus of this conflict between these two
characters Orochimaru breaking
established rules and laws extending his
youth beyond what is natural and Huen
accepting his decline fighting better
than anyone we've ever seen in the
series forced to fight and defeat his
former Masters the first and second
hokages all the while taking out
Orochimaru as a threat albeit at the
cost of his own life it's clearly an
emotionally char aair given that at
first he's mostly on the defensive which
Orochimaru points out at the beginning
is really unlike him it's honestly a
remarkable show of force that helps to
put into perspective how absurdly
powerful he must have been in his prime
given that this is him now taking some
of orochimaru's absolute best and while
he does die losing the battle he secures
the safety of those around him for the
time being eliminating orochimaru's
ability to weave signs thus in essence
winning the war the most effective and I
think perhaps the most important aspect
look looking to the Future concerning
this fight however might be that of what
we learn about Orochimaru in these
flashes to the past how he was hoping to
be the fourth Hokage and failed in
meeting the requirements and now he
seeks to have all the knowledge of all
the different styles granting himself
Eternal youth in the process overall
from an Aesthetics perspective this
fight was visually beautiful in the
manga and in the anime the animation
only served to elevate that material I
particularly enjoyed the back and forth
huin had with his former Masters the
special effects animation on display for
mudslides Fire and Water there's so much
stunning movement coding that episode I
do however have one small criticism of
this fight while It's Perfectly Natural
for Orochimaru to remain something of an
unknown going into this encounter Huen
the third Hokage felt still unfamiliar
to me despite his presence in the
beginning of their story and due to this
The Narrative had to dedicate
substantial sections to exploring Huen
as well as Orochimaru that's not a deal
breaker at all however and what
narrative Exposition there is I still
relatively enjoyed I mean the entire
purpose of this fight at the end of the
day was to give us a history lesson and
build up the world further so it
succeeded in that effort crescendoing on
a powerful and intense moment as the
third Hokage sacrifices himself to rid
the world of a great evil one last time
protecting the people he cares for
deeply by removing orochimaru's
abilities which I am only now realizing
is another very similar narrative move
to avatar The Last Airbender I'm getting
a feeling they might have taken some
notes from Naruto in this respect and
while this fight did book end this
section of the story the real meat of
the conflict proving to have spectacle
to rival that of even the Hokage level
threat here was that of Naruto versus
gar Naruto versus gar the shown between
gar and the various characters that try
to stop him is brilliant beginning with
the closest in pursuit of the young man
Sasuke our favorite little Moody boy and
their Dynamic is interesting for me
mainly because it's between two people
with hateful motivations Sasuke attempts
his third and possible suicidal attack
willing to throw his life away at the
chance to proceed ever closer to his one
single-minded goal all the while gar a
once small reserved child now more
closely resembles a monster grotesque
his body face and being contorts to form
an accurate representation of the hatred
and suffering inside his mind I like
that in making this decision Sasuke
began to once again succumb to the curse
of Orochimaru and just as he's being
overcome by it and facing the finishing
Blow from this new monstrous Gara Naruto
makes the save with this save being
perhaps metaphorical or emblematic of
what's to come for Sasuke and Naruto
that Naruto will in the future save him
from himself and once Naruto arrives we
recognize that exact same conflict
clouded his mind and caused that very
same hesitancy only once before have we
seen Naruto freeze up and since then
it's been pretty smooth sailing the
source of his determination and bravery
has always been that regardless of the
opponent he knows that he's willing to
go first further to push himself more
than they are and to him at this point
in his life that's all he has he doesn't
believe in or rely on what comes
naturally to him like Sasuke does and he
doesn't believe in his intelligence the
same way Sakura or Shikamaru would and
really it's easy to see why he's never
been told to believe in those facets of
himself and as a result has only tested
himself in the Realms of his own
determination he wants to achieve his
goal so badly that he's willing to push
himself farther than anyone he knows
that's where his confidence comes from
and that specifically is what makes gar
an interesting and imposing character
for Naruto to face consumed by the demon
inside him Naruto is not only facing
someone who he knows is willing to die
fighting willing to struggle as hard as
he will but he's also face to face with
a manifestation of a reality that could
have been his own and in many ways still
could be like gar he has a demon inside
of him and this fear causes him to
hesitate further putting his friends in
danger the seeds for this encounter were
sewn in the prior Arc as we slowly began
to understand who gar was and what he
was all about and with this final
showdown between two sides of
effectively the same coin we got another
perspective having been depicted as a
monster and showing all of his
personality defects we receive a
flashback to G's past and in it the
first panel displays gar sitting on a
swing alone looking on as other kids'
age are having fun remind you of anyone
the flashback itself is short but it
certainly paints a lonely tragic and
harrowing picture of what it must have
been like as gar growing up in a world
that both feared and despised him coming
to a head with the only person in his
life choosing to make an attempt on his
own life marking the point where he
would become the person he is today the
reasons I love battle shown in as a
genre are numerous however as I was
watching this climactic final battle
between two giant Kaiju in a ninja
themed story about believing in yourself
I was reminded of one specific reason
the genre allows you to place incredible
philosophical symbolic or thematic
weight behind the various techniques
that are implemented in it to show you
what I mean I'll use Dragon Ball as an
example given that it's the story I'm
most familiar with towards the beginning
of Dragon Ball Z the events of the San
Saga get underway Goku dies his son's
kidnapped by as arch nemesis and aliens
invade and take over the world it's
pretty standard stuff and just like this
Arc in Naruto where we see a giant frog
slice a sand monster with a sword the
visuals and craziness of the San Saga
what with its giant monkey monsters
massive beam struggles and depiction of
the afterlife gave it more than enough
eye candy to put on a wild show but the
reason that this Arc was successful had
much more to do with the simple story
that was being told at its foundation
and how the actions of the main
characters reflected the philosophies
that they represented when Vegeta
arrives he doesn't show affection for
his allies or anyone really in fact he
kills his oldest comrade the second he's
no longer useful to him in this way
Vegeta acts as the opposite of what Goku
represents in the story having given up
his life at the beginning of the arc to
save literally everyone Goku travels to
other world and after exerting more
effort than any mortal in history across
snake way requests the help of someone
he has never met so that he can continue
to defend others and once he touches
down on the battlefield having been
brought back by his friends he finds
himself as the one thing standing
between everything he cares about and
certain Annihilation all with the
technique that he managed to acquire
thanks to the philosophy he believed in
in this way battle Shonen has
facilitated not only a beam struggle but
a struggle of ideology between ego and
humility the beam struggle wasn't a
Cornerstone moment in a battle that has
gone down in history as one of the
greatest of all time simply because it
looked visually interesting absolutely
not it's because of what it represents
and so across the series techniques like
the Spirit Bomb Kaioken and Kamehameha
didn't just look cool through their
acquisition or connection to the story
they each represented a part of Goku's
identity and in that same way during
this battle with gar Naruto's philosophy
and way of life is challenged directly
by his natural opposite in gar and to
combat this natural opposing threat
Naruto uses the techniques that
represent who he is and what makes him a
terrific character after overcoming the
initial shock that came from confronting
A demented and psychotic version of
himself early on in the conflict a tried
andrue means of building up tension to a
big reveal took place gar would knock
Naruto to the floor berating him and
poking what he saw as holes in his
idealistic and hopeful outlook on life
but time and time again Naruto would
stand back up and as I pointed out in
his flashback G's struggle has been
about his lack of belief in others
ability to love him he refuses to trust
in anyone and so lives only for himself
hurting others maybe before they have
the chance to hurt him there are
numerous stages where gar slips up and
Naruto manages to land a significant hit
before he eventually runs out of chakra
to help anymore and realizing this
Sasuke stands up for him and tries to
create an opening to allow both him and
Sakura to escape in response to this
Naruto throws out a beautiful
[Music]
quote when people are protecting someone
truly precious to them they truly can
become as strong as they must be all the
while assuming the same pose he did when
he was standing up for iruka in chapter
1 Naruto explodes with chakra resulting
in a very similar scene and Page spread
this is the technique that represents
the love his friends have for him and
the love he has for them it's the
manifestation of Naruto's desire to
protect those he loves the perfect
thematic counter to G's hateful and
lonely perspective that's haunted him
his entire life but that's not even the
best part as I said there's a giant frog
versus giant sand monster kiju battle
and even here this same Narrative
Approach is present with stunning
Effectiveness I would even argue to
Greater effect as gar makes decisions
that make this contrast even more
pronounced Naruto's summoning on of
gamabunta is a very important touch
Kishimoto added to make this picture as
effective as it ends up being if we want
to break this down gamabunta and
Naruto's ability to summon him in the
first place is directly tied to the fox
spirit's chakra which was only now
possible to access thanks to jiah
granting Naruto the agency to make his
own destiny by removing the seal that
blocked this chakra Naruto now summons
gamabunta because he has the control to
make the fox Spirit work for him which
happens to be the exact opposite of
gara's Ace in the Hole wherein he
effectively surrenders all the agency he
has to the sand Spirit by Falling
unconscious thus unlocking the full
power of this spirit and so when
described like that the scene while we
can acknowledge on a surface level how
much is visually happening on screen I
mean come on look that's a giant frog
wearing clothes and a sword while it has
a lot going on if you look at what this
story is about it becomes much more
simple and effective it's not just a
crazy monster battle with the fate of
the Known World on the line it's Naruto
using the good that he's received in his
life to try and reach gar someone that's
fallen so far from reality and boy does
Naruto reach
him this is The Natural end to the major
conflict of this Ark with G out for the
count destruction after coming to an end
in their Village and the hakaj after
losing his life during the battle with
Orochimaru the progression into the next
Arc feels seamless something I've
criticized Dragon Ball super in the past
for was how little the arcs themselves
flowed into each other everything felt
as though it had a clearly defined and
cut ending which can be okay for some
people but for me I much prefer when the
events of the prior story inform the
next it creates a believable cause and
effect and furthermore injects a great
sense of scale to the occasion and this
is true for Naruto in this instance for
everything that's transpired it's the
consequences of the prior Arc that
informed the events of this
one
jiah is such a lovely character quirky
and light from the beginning I saw a
very Naruto sort of energy within him
reinforced perfectly in this section by
the imagery of his training days and
it's this position the fifth hokagay
looking to be filled that this Arc most
concerns itself with this upcoming Arc
concerns itself with an answering
predominantly two questions what does it
mean to be Hokage and who will be the
fifth and on this journey we follow Jah
and Naruto as they set out to find
Tsunade one of the three great Shinobi
touted by Jah himself as being perfect
for the job the story feels well thought
out and the events within it are
thrilling so let's jump into it during
their travels to find Tsunade jeriah
gives Naruto specific training that is
quite Advanced it involves chakra
manipulation in three separate steps I
found this section very fun but within
it I began to realize something recently
in the story it's felt at least from an
optical point of view from other
characters that Naruto has undergone a
fairly significant change a sudden
realization has occurred that he is in
fact destined not for mediocrity but
instead something significant it flips
the script on the character in a sense
but I don't necessarily think in a bad
way the journey from his birth through
the land of waves all the way through to
the end of the tunin exams has been in
many ways completed he was an insecure
kid without a place in the world and
through great hardship overcame any
falsehood he may have believed either
about himself or others his goal to
become the next Hokage while still
unachieved it was a goal set by him to
show the world that not only is some
loser kid worth something but is capable
of achieving the highest rank in the
land in other words he was determined to
make something of himself despite what
others might have thought but with his
travels having yielded surprising
changes in his mindset and Outlook as
seen during the gar fight he now has no
reason to have such a chip on his
shoulder he's proven himself not only
strong to the people who care about him
but most importantly himself and so
strictly speaking in a sense this
emotional Journey for him as a character
is over he spent the entire story trying
to prove his worth and reliability to
various people in his life and now that
he has that Kishimoto then decided to
give him more promise and responsibility
than any other character in the
[Music]
series hello do you have a moment to
talk about our Lord and savior for the
entire series Naruto has wanted to be
this person and now we get to see how he
fares when the crippling pressure of
this responsibility becomes a reality
and he would have lost died or had been
taken away by Itachi had it not been for
the likes of Sasuke coming to save him
or eventually J
and thus one of the main takeaways from
this encounter ends up being Naruto once
again wasn't ready the poor kid was just
about figuring out how the world as he
knew it worked growing up and now
everything is suddenly changing however
thankfully the last few arcs have helped
him grow and unlike last time he found
himself unsure he has something and
someone to fight
for the training that Naruto under goes
has specific emphasis on this philosophy
to find self-reliant and master a
technique inste es with as little help
as possible Jah totally aware of this
forces Naruto to self sooth and teach
himself offering up a collection of
scenes that feel both intimate and
enlightening for us as an audience to
sit back and watch seeing his struggles
his injuries and flashes back into the
past to gain deeper insight into the
workings of what he's doing was
wonderful to experience seeing his doubt
his frustration and the pain he goes
through to achieve this frankly
incredible feat in such a short amount
of time stands in direct contrast with
the likes of Goku who seem to manage
incredible Feats of Strength with
comparative ease these training
sequences with jariah highlight
something integral to the progression of
this character and really this story I
think for me it highlights or rather
points out that despite the shift in
value people now see in Naruto with him
effectively being a great significance
he's still the same kid struggling and
trying his best to succeed against all
of this pressure and that's really what
this entire second half following the
death of the third Hokage is about
responsibility and how different
characters with different backgrounds
react to sudden or long existing
responsibility Orochimaru and in a
smaller way for now Itachi are the
forces of pressure being applied to this
world forcing as of explained the likes
of Naruto to improve and train but these
themes are also explored with the likes
of jayah and even Tsunade to meaningful
degrees with the position of fifth
Hokage requiring someone to fill it both
Jah and Tsunade are faced with that
responsibility Judah almost immediately
shifts the responsibility to Cady and in
doing that is for forced to accept the
responsibility of training Naruto and
locating Tsunade who he thinks is a
better fit speaking of which Tsunade on
the other hand is a much more
interesting character with this line of
thought while jiah made his decision
based on little more than his own
assessment of him not being right for
the job Tsunade is faced with the
Dilemma of which his options directly
conflict with each other Save The
Village by becoming the fifth Hokage or
assure The Village's destruction by
helping Orochimaru and to be honest
there's no more interesting character to
force this dilemma upon than her from
the moment we hear about her to the
moment we meet her we painted a picture
of a person who just runs away from
responsibility only living for herself
and what she wants and now she's faced
with what would effectively be something
she can never turn back from and in
exchange for denying the responsibility
that comes with being the fifth hok
Orochimaru offers an alternative to
reanimate her loved ones this obviously
represents the ultimate want in her life
and so when she's faced with the offer
of responsibility the fifth Hokage comes
with she immediately declines much to
Naruto's Aston punishment and anger
further emphasized by her dismissal of
the fourth Hokage sacrifice citing it as
a fool hearty thing to have
done this was such a satisfying scene a
clash of two literal opposing ideologies
one who is willing to do anything to
achieve the status of Hokage and one who
thinks it's pointless punctuated by a
short but philosophically Rich fight
outside one where tunan chose not to use
more than her fingernail and to great
effect she uses it but and this is the
best part the responsibility Naruto
represents in this conflict makes itself
known through the technique he's been
training the responsibilities that he's
adopted during this training session the
technique that represents this
responsibility shocked Tsunade and gives
her an idea let Naruto train one week
and if he can Master the renen she'll
say he's deserving of becoming Hokage in
addition to giving him her grandfather's
necklace and if he fails she takes makes
all his money what makes this timeline
specifically interesting is that it also
happens to coincide with the time
Orochimaru wants an answer to his offer
from Tsunade the means with which these
two stories Naruto's as well as
tsunade's intertwine and inform each
other is both natural and fascinating
there's a wonderful scene where
tsunade's friend shizune brings Naruto
and us up to speed concerning tsunade's
tragic past filled with loss and Terror
seeing this allows us to empathize much
more readily with her but for Naruto it
only invigorates him right before she
tells Naruto about her backstory he
complains that she's stopping him from
getting the rest he needs to train
tomorrow however after this conversation
he informs her that he's going off the
train
immediately this search for Tsunade
section of the story is the absolute
best Naruto has been for me as both a
reviewer and a fan of Shonen
storytelling over the first 115 chapters
while they did shine a light on the
themes of determination and
responsibility they were never the focus
quite like they are in this Arc because
Naruto is such a brilliantly fleshed out
and fully realized character instead of
having to dedicate time within the story
to serve his character to bolster these
traits his character can now be used to
service the story for this reason to
represent the themes of determination
and responsibility and in using him this
way Kishimoto managed to help me build a
powerful connection and relationship
with the character of sunade throughout
this Arc she's been quite honestly a
turbulent character one that's caused a
tremendous amount of conflict in the
story and in this final portion she
confronts Orochimaru and she decides to
take the more difficult option in the
face of everything Orochimaru is
offering she says no and that Journey
from feeling indifferent or ambivalent
to feeling true responsibility for not
just herself or her friends but for her
entire Village she feels a
responsibility to become what they need
her to be and right here you can feel as
though the story is building up to a
specific point to something special
Naruto certainly plays his role in this
battle by demonstrating the value of
self-belief determination and
responsibility in the face of certain
doom and in doing so like he has shown
hints of at numerous points in the
series despite performing incredible
Feats that pale in comparison to the
power Kabuto possesses he manages to
inspire belief in these ideas for those
around him and that's when we see that
all of the focus and effort that
Kishimoto has put into the story
converge into one point a point that he
has built up and it's
this this moment honestly gave me chills
to have an entire Arc of character has
undergone be so succinctly punctuated
and presented in one sentence all the
while demonstrating in such a visually
stunning way Kishimoto sir fantastic
work from this point on the rest is
action movie window dressing but even so
the battle with their summon Spirits
with all three of the Shinobi greats was
intense and
[Music]
satisfying I loved watching Orochimaru
getting beat in the end to by the way
but really it was the quieter moments
that have stayed with me in this story
more than anything else there's a minor
visual gag during this material that I
knew had a lot of potential for
emotional resonance tsunade's insistence
on appearing young using her chakra to
manipulate the way she looks changing
herself from a 50-some year old woman to
one that looks as though she's in her
20s I thought that this was an
interesting idea for two reasons firstly
I like that it immediately helped to
reveal what sort of temperament she had
and where her values lay but also
because I thought it reflected her
character's biggest flaw the story of
Tsunade is one of a troubled soul
trapped in the past filled with
resentment unable to move on from the
horrible losses she suffered during that
part of her life I thought it served as
a brilliant metaphor for her current
mindset and beliefs in the beginning of
this part of the story and when the
ending came that powerful realization
and life altering shifting mindset so
too did her barriers for throwing her
life away for a Cause worth the
sacrifice and symbolically after
exhausting herself completely in a
desperate and Powerful effort to save
everyone and rise up to become the fifth
hokago
her illusion fell revealing her actual
self free of Illusion it's a beautiful
touch that really sealed this as such a
phenomenal Arc for me it was simple had
a clear message and was powerful in its
execution in essence it was focused it
managed to harness everything I loved
about this story and in the process
created a fantastic character that
happened to be female I've been vocal
about my issues with the likes of Eno
and Sakura but I'm also willing to point
out a job well done when I see it
Tsunade is a great character that had a
brilliant Arc in the story and with the
fifth Hokage now after being selected
and accepted Orochimaru still on the run
and a massive world of possibilities
ahead I can confidently say that I am
thrilled I picked up this series and I
cannot wait to see what lies ahead of us
on this wild and inspirational adventure
and what an arc it
is
so
[Music]
remember when I said that I looked on
with concern at the eight full volumes
of manga I had to read and review this
week well what an idiot I was the
material in these volumes are easily
some of the most simple in terms of
story but also have I think the very
best paneling and layout work from
Kishimoto that I've seen yet making the
entire process of reading deceptively
quick and seamless I'm telling you I was
slamming volumes like pints at Christmas
often when it comes to the artists
Behind These famous mangas the
development or change of the respective
artistic approaches Styles occurs
unconsciously and gradually over time
JoJo Dragon Ball and W piece are clear
and striking examples of this phenomenon
comparing their work from the beginning
of their run to their most recent stuff
highlights my point natural changes
occur and while some of this can explain
part of what's happened to kishimoto's
world work here as a mangaa I think
there's also a very conscious effort
being exerted here in the beginning of
volume 20 Kishimoto vents his
frustrations with the manga format
drawing from top right to bottom left
calling it limiting and this frustration
can be felt in the volumes concerning
this section specifically sporting
gorgeous pages and panels that really
grab my attention the likes of which I
haven't seen much from Kishimoto at all
it's wonderful to see aanga 200 chapters
into his career still trying to push
himself to innovate but what's
interesting about this change compared
to the AFF forementioned mangaka is that
kishimoto's transition is directly
influenced by the very thing that's
trying to mimic him that's right
Kishimoto was directly influenced by
Naruto's anime's character designer
tetsuya nishio he saw some amazing
design were coming from nishio on the
anime and loved how it seemed like such
a great mix of San and Shonen Styles he
thought it was the ideal art style he'd
been looking for and ever since he'd
been mimicking nish's drawings in a lot
of these author note sections Kishimoto
brings up many famous animators such as
hiroyuki okiura who worked on super
famous scenes on things like Ghost in
the Shell and akura which makes me think
he's a bit of an animation nut I
mentioned one particular animator who
has largely defined what Naruto action
is and that's noro Matsumoto Sasuke
versus Orochi Maru Rock Le versus gar
Orochimaru versus the third Hokage and
now Naruto versus Sasuke all these
iconic scenes come from this man and as
I've watch those and continue to read
I've noticed kishimoto's work beginning
to resemble the energy and posing found
in matsumoto's work I can only theorize
about his influence here but given
kishimoto's love of Animation it seems
like a safe bet having already achieved
so much notoriety in the industry with
so many people at this point looking up
to him I think it's a great sign of a
manga and a person to be able to look
outward and inward for a means to try
and improve himself it really does seem
like the more I learn about Kishimoto as
a person the more I realize how close he
is to Naruto as a
[Music]
character
while the conclusions to the prior arcs
activity with the assault on the village
after being dealt with and the selection
of the latest okag after being finalized
I was fully expecting this Arc to feel
like a footnote after everything that's
happened I was wrong despite being one
of the longest arcs among the material
I've covered so far the story in
question is remarkably simple which
meant that a lot of space was given to
this arc's various components to breathe
build up and climax appropriately and
boy do they climax appropriately the
First Act of this Arc is the one that
carries most of the heavy lifting from
an expository and foundational sense
upon which the rest of the arc launches
from Comfortably that said the rest of
this Arc consists of a series of fights
and Chase scenes and that might not
sound interesting but Kishimoto makes it
work really well act one if I could
describe this Arc in one word it would
be cathartic and focused having come off
the back of a rip roaring couple of arcs
with more conflict than you could swing
a cat at going into this I was curious
to see the direction Kishimoto was going
to take sure we'd have to deal with the
aftermath of the attack on the village
and Lady Cady settling into her new
position but outside of that I didn't
see much else to deal with outside of
perhaps The Itachi and Sasuke conflict
in The Last Arc while I didn't speak
much about it Itachi very much cemented
himself as one of the most terrifying
major players in the story as soon as he
appeared on the other side of the door
facing I sincerely felt the tension and
pressure rise which is exactly the sort
of impression you want from a major
villain or antagonist and the action and
drama that took fuel from that encounter
as Sasuke entered the fry to make the
save on Naruto it felt like a Monumental
moment in every sense of the word that
was building to something however then
the rug is pulled from beneath us
despite the other arcs that make up the
rest of this first PA of Naruto being
somewhat more complex with a greater
number of moving Parts this Arc and its
AG volumes primarily concern themselves
with Sasuke's relationship with his
brother and the choices he makes in
seeking revenge in response to that and
I loved it my biggest complaint after I
finished the very first Arc of Naruto
was that it felt somewhat unfocused and
now in this Arc not only are things
incredibly simple but each facet of this
Arc now receives ample
attention SAS Sasuke versus Naruto round
one funnily enough despite being
mentioned once before that Sasuke
desired to test himself against Naruto
this matchup for one reason or another
faded into the back of my subconscious
as something I either didn't know I
wanted or one that I totally forgot
about and I have no idea why because on
paper these two squaring off makes
complete sense and are a terrific
matchup narratively speaking I mentioned
before in an earlier video that I felt
the closer Naruto came to achieving his
goal the farther away Sasuke would be
pushed by his with Orochimaru having
laid that metaphorical check off's gun
before us when he said Sasuke needs to
seek out more power by embracing the
darkness in his heart I knew a scene or
sequence of events would play out like
this and it's so much better than I
thought it would be made possible thanks
to some key pieces of symbolism laid out
across this series the initial fight
that kicks off this arc's activity is
short but punctuated powerfully by a
striking visual by really putting into
perspective the Gap that's appearing
between himself and Naruto however at
this point in the story I think it's
important to point out that their
relationship isn't necessarily
interesting to me because of their
Dynamic on its own and that largely has
to do with Kakashi and jiah pretty much
telling us explicitly what's happening
narratively between them we're not left
to understand this on our own by reading
the material and understanding it
ourselves and as a result this
Exposition feels clunky and did take
away from this short but opening fight
between them then again this is a manga
for young teens so I'm going to let it
slide I will however say what I did
really enjoy was the role mentors are
playing in this story whether that be
Kakashi and SAS which I will definitely
speak about more later jiah's
relationship with Naruto as I've
described in the past Sakura's new
budding relationship with lady Tsunade
and of course guy's relationship with
Rock Lee Rock Le's been an interesting
character in this story from the moment
I met him back during the tuning exams I
knew I liked this little guy with him
time and time again throughout the story
whether it be in the force of death the
fight with G or his Rehabilitation after
that fight he sort of in a way stood as
an example of what a hero with a similar
mentality to that of Naruto might appear
like if he didn't have an all powerful
Spirit trapped within him when Naruto in
the first half of the story contended
with inadequacy and a chip on his
shoulder eventually Kishimoto was forced
to transition his character from one
that struggled to make a difference to
one who had to deal with the high
expectations from those around him Lee
on the other hand because of the lack of
advantages he has compared to Naruto can
fully lean into an Embrace angles and
Outcast character like Naruto once was
afforded Naruto can self-heal thanks to
the the fox spirit inside him and so a
natural way to explore Lee's character
to further distinguish him from Naruto
is to have him absorb a tremendous
amount of damage and the consequences of
that action which brings me to his
mentor guy in many ways the mentor
characters in this story mirror key
attributes of their students
personalities guy is perhaps the most
pronounced variation on this concept
everything from his appearance to his
desire to prove himself against Kakashi
to his soul destroying training
exercises in every sense of the word the
connection between guy and Lee is as
powerful as it is because they feel like
Father and Son once again providing Lee
in the story horrific odds for anyone to
have to face let alone a young teenager
I spoke about guy before in a prior part
saying that I thought he saw a
tremendous amount of himself in Lee and
due to that sees him as something of an
inspiration to even him and while that
was true in this Arc their relationship
is tested as guy comes face to face with
the consequences of the path he laid
this young boy down and so he's faced
with a dilemma does he encourage him
like he always had to look the odds in
the eye unblinking and take the surgery
which has a 50% mortality rate or does
he choose to discourage him out of
sympathy for his situation it's a
tremendous amount of responsibility and
it's a fascinating character study
within this Arc that I think has the
most emotional
resonance act two the scene where Sasuke
chooses to leave to connect with the
dark side is actually a lot more
effective than I thought it would be
it's certainly not profound or anything
like that but it really does feel
authentic and honest to the characters
involved which is the most important
thing in this scene Sakura tries her
best to persuade Sasuke to stay with
them and in doing so pours her heart out
in a tender albeit awkward scene which I
honestly thought was appropriate and
well perfect they are just kids after
all struggling to navigate the mindfield
that is expressing how they feel about
each other while under extreme stress
with little practice in that area and it
absolutely came across that way I really
did feel sorry for Sakura during this
this part and while I don't Vibe too
much with her as a character I did think
this felt very authentic and appropriate
for her and following Sasuke leaving the
foundation is now set for the chase that
will follow that day with none other
than Shikamaru now at tunin being passed
with assembling a team interestingly
while Naruto was the obvious choice and
is chosen to be part of that team Nei
kba and choji were less expected by me
but absolutely welcomed in my mind the
chase that eventually gets underway I
thought was brilliant while there was a
little bit of a slow burn towards the
middle I definitely thought the
attention given to the fights really
helped the pacing as well as Elevate the
various characters that otherwise didn't
get the attention they deserved earlier
in this story Shikamaru while having
been given some Shin in Prior ARS now
leads the group of young ninja with an
impressive and strategic fashion that
absolutely highlighted not only his
upsid as a leader and strategist but
when things didn't go 100% to plan with
his group's numbers dwindling it also
led him to question himself wondering if
he was good enough which for such a
certain and calculated character really
helped to humanize him in a way I wasn't
expecting grounding him while also
exhibiting his greatest strengths and
techniques and really that's what this
middle section does exceptionally well
it helps to reestablish these lesser
known and seldom focused on characters
offers them the chance to show their
absolute best and shows their internal
struggles and doubts the way this Chase
is organized it acts as a sort of Conga
line for lack of a better term of
orochimaru's goons to get through and so
one after another part of shikamaru's
team has to drop off to fight each
member of this group as they continue to
carry Sasuke off in a basket for
Orochimaru to take the body off choji's
fight is first and honestly when I look
at neis and keas alongside this I
thought this one did it best the rest
follow a very similar format to this and
so on top of it benefiting from being
the first time we see this sort of
sequence in format I think there's a lot
more we can dig into with this material
seeing as nii for example already had an
emotionally charged fight with Naruto
during the tuning exams that dealt with
much of the same subject matter
discussed in this fight specifically
furthermore choji has this l so I guess
Kishimoto took a leaf out of f Pie's
Playbook and gave Choi Rumble balls and
man does he get massive during this
honestly I didn't know what to expect
with this but once again similar to what
made Shikamaru effective during this
section the conflict choji endures
serves as a great vehicle to demonstrate
his skills that make him unique but it
also highlights his insecurities and
shortcomings as a ninja and a human
being too I think out of all the fights
in this section chois was by far my
favorite and while I was reading through
this material too I was shocked by how
fast I was flying through it the fights
in this section felt both compelling and
brief with the likes of Choi and Nei
receiving plenty of wonderful two-page
spreads while also demonstrating these
sound ninja second forms acting as a
foreshadowing of things to come for
Sasuke I thought the second form designs
of sound ninj brandish were phenomenal I
wasn't so sure about them each getting a
new transformation at first though I
thought the effect would get lessened
each and every time with it being more
and more formulaic but in actuality
because the designs were so great I
actually ended up getting hyped for what
they would eventually look like when
they did change furthermore once Naruto
and shikamaru's respective fights get
underway then the tempo really starts to
ramp up particularly when it comes to
Naruto's fight with this strange new
character coming to take the basket
housing Sasuke away Naruto assumes that
feral mode he slips into when his
friends are in danger and the artwork
accompanying it is appropriately awesome
however things as they often do during
stories go to and when they did
hear something amazing
[Music]
happened leave AR to make the
same I'm not sure if my energy in this
recording will accurately show just how
excited I felt when he showed up but I
went bananas because honestly I love
this little character I spoke about how
the last few volumes and fights really
felt somewhat formulaic and that they
effectively achieve the same sort of
things narratively but that formula has
been thrown right out the window and
replaced with the pure chaos Lee has
injected into this fight however as
things want to go in this story we can't
have too much of a good thing for too
long but that doesn't mean what we
receive as a replacement isn't great
[Music]
also at the beginning of volume 24
Kishimoto reminisced about his
experience reading Dragon Ball volume 24
for the first time and how that was
where Goku fought against Ginyu he
described the affair as something he was
massively excited to read through and
hop that he could make Naruto more
exciting when I opened that volume after
reading nothing but what felt like quite
safe choices up until now this volume
exploded with interest near impossible
to predict matchups and last minute
saves like the fight with Lee and his
Drunken Monkey technique which was
hilarious and surprisingly effective
against the worsening odds right after
his surgery and then gar and the other
sand ninja show up I'm not even remotely
kidding here it's felt like more has
happened in the last five chapters than
there has been in the last four volumes
it's honestly brilliant stuff kimimaro
is a brilliant looking villain and his
fight against Lee and eventually gar is
brilliantly handled he is one of the
most unsettling and awesome looking
ninjas I've come across in this story
and when he whipped out his spine and
used it as a sword I was like okay look
I know I'm not a big fan of action only
moment but that was really freaking cool
this fight is honestly not one I would
ever have thought to create if left to
my own devices but the two powers on
display here sand manipulation and Bone
manipulation created perhaps the most
visually stunning battle sequence I've
seen from this manga to date defensively
offensively and the strategy employed by
both Warriors was enough to win my heart
a million times over and throwing Lee
into the mix only served to exacerbate
that feeling for me watching these two
onetime enemies work together and in a
sense save each other was a immensely
satisfying and we're not done yet there
are moments in pop culture where you
have to sit back and recognize that this
was a moment not only pivotal to the
story that it takes part in but one that
has influenced and impacted the lives of
millions around the world for me that
moment was Goku versus Vegeta it was the
very first piece of material I ever saw
of Dragon Ball and because of the impact
that had on my life I've gone on to make
it my career and this fight Sasuke
versus Naruto this really and truly felt
like the culmination of of the entire
series conveyed perfectly by Kishimoto
as the strengths Naruto has garnered
across his time spent with us are all
used here to full effect from his most
bombastic and ostentatious abilities
like the shadow clones and the Rasen all
the way to the more subtle touches like
when he learned to walk on water with
jeriah all of these skills are on
display here and used to full effect
serving to heighten the drama and make
this feel like we've reached a
significant end point what did catch me
off guard however was that a massive
port portion of this fight is spent in
flashback a brilliant flashback but it
surprised me nevertheless the flashback
for Sasuke while long added so much to
an occasion that felt as though it was
starved of Sasuke's perspective we got
to see the decaying of Sasuke's
relationship with his brother and the
origins of his entire purpose in life to
get revenge but one thing I will say
about this before I move on is that I
get the feeling that we're missing a
large part of this story namely Itachi's
perspective on everything now it might
very well just turn out to be the case
that he's a cold blooded murderer that
has no redeemable qualities but who
knows I'll see how that plays out in the
future concerning the fight itself the
action in the opening minutes felt
appropriately shocking and confusing due
to Naruto's perspective however once the
flashback revealing Sasuke's motivations
and full backstory concluded the fight
suddenly felt both appropriate for each
respective character and most
importantly perfectly focused the
paneling and layout work by Kishimoto as
I mentioned earlier with the gar and
Rock Lee encounter is some of the best
in the series with Kishimoto really
demonstrating how far he's come as an an
artist going from strength to strength
leading to Naruto charging up his renen
and Sasuke his Chidori with the paneling
accompanying this being stronger than
anywhere else I've seen in the manga
there's a point of view shot from
underwater as we look on as these two
Ninjas dance on the water's surface with
their weapons floating down to the dark
depths beneath and that might be my
favorite page out of the entire conflict
here however if I want to take a step
back for a second and think about things
more abstractly it is my belief that the
flashback we get after this concerning
Kakashi's Origins holds a lot more
meaning behind it than might be evident
at first glance in this flashback
Kakashi's team is composed of three
individuals himself a young boy called
Obito uchia and a girl called Ren and
from this reflection on his early
training days we can see why perhaps
he's taken a keen interest in SAS taking
him under his wings seeking to teach him
the Chidori technique of that original
group Obito was clearly the overly
emotional underachiever like Naruto was
in Sasuke's group while Ren could be a
very convincing standin for Sakura given
that Sakura herself would begin studying
the same Jutsu Rin was however while
reading this material I couldn't help
but cast my mind back to the first Arc
where Naruto Sasuke and Sakura sat
before Kakashi in that very scene Sasuke
explained in no uncertain terms what his
goals were demonstrating his
single-minded approach in becoming a
ninja and over the course of that story
this Focus has remained and with the
farther and further he pursued that line
of thinking Kakashi began getting more
and more interested and involved in
Sasuke's life and I think there's a
reason for it he saw himself in SAS
Kakashi's flashback wherein we first see
him use the Chidori technique he does so
not taking into account how his actions
will affect his teammates single-minded
also in his goal he ends up failing in
that effort for the most part and later
in that same flashback Ren gets
kidnapped Obito wants to rescue her but
Kakashi insists on completing the
mission instead thankfully the
comparatively weaker Obito convinces
Kakashi to save her to and from this
it's clear to see the similarities
Kakashi sees in Sasuke particularly
striking for Kakashi given that he lost
a close friend in the process of that
mission it's a touching flashback
highlighting the origins of his eye but
for me it highlighted instead the birth
of who Kakashi is today by the end of
that sequence the Chidori becomes a
technique not exclusively of Destruction
but one that instead represents
protection of his closest loved ones
which recontextualized every instance he
used that move in the series for me
however if we are to think about this
one layer deeper his teaching of this
technique to Sasuke with his explicit
explanation of when to use this techque
technique it effectively acts as Kakashi
handing Sasuke a representation of one's
desire to protect what's most important
to him hoping that it will become that
for him to help him see what's actually
important to focus on what you have
right now instead of what you lost and
so when this story climaxes in the
emphatic and Grand fashion it does
Naruto's renen explodes on contact with
Sasuke's Chidori to create a stunning
Inferno of a spectacle no doubt but it's
also a collision of two techniques that
offer snapshots of how far one has come
and how far stray the other has fallen
the act and display of these techniques
alone perfectly tell the story of these
two Fierce characters in a very real and
metaphorical sense with the technique
that was designed to protect those close
to you very literally being used in this
instance to tear down the one closest to
Sasuke this aric wears many different
masks It's a character-driven drama it's
a comedy it's action and it's a thriller
but in the end this has become a story
about two characters more than anything
else and in the end Naruto's first part
ends in tragedy or does it the choice
Sasuke made to not kill Naruto says more
about his character than this entire
fight ever could and it's rather fitting
that a technique like Chidori couldn't
be used to end the life of his friend
overall my impressions of this Arc and
really this first section of Naruto is a
wonderful one while it didn't start
strong like many other series do
Kishimoto and by extension this story
has a passion behind it that much like
its titular character grew and grew grew
more effective with each subsequent Arc
I've transformed from someone that
didn't know the first thing about Naruto
and now I consider myself a massive fan
of Kishimoto and the work he's produced
here with this section of the story The
Ark was a massive finale befitting of
the occasion that managed to also feel
intimate at the same
[Music]
time
the further I've delved into this series
The More I found that it likes to
utilize fights to tell its story while I
do like this approach and I think it
makes sense given the circumstances I do
think that overall it does feel a lot
more WOTE in its approach compared to
earlier arcs which had opportunities for
training and exams to filter the themes
and narrative context for different
characters however with that said I also
think that the conversations that occur
during these fights serve as a nice
Balan to that issue and lack of variety
in certain settings this Arc which
focuses on the reintroduction of all the
main and secondary characters primarily
concerns itself with the kidnapping of
gar and the bringing Full Circle of his
character Arc it's a powerful tale with
themes of responsibility regret and
loneliness in terms of the new post
times skip designs while many of the
secondary characters have remained much
the same I do enjoy the reimagined
designs of Naruto and Sakura there's an
obvious air of maturity to these
respective looks helped enormously by
the addition of darker colors on Naruto
removing some of the fiery orange with a
much more muted darker tone the same
goes for Sakura I love that she's
decided to keep her hair short which
speaks to her mindset greatly thanks to
the fight she had with Eno during the
tuning exams furthermore her outfit
similar to her more mature Persona
reflects a more practical action-based
approach stripping away her dress-like
garments replacing them with something
far more fitting I think I'm
particularly happy with this change in
Sakura which I will definitely touch
more on later in this video with her
outstanding ending fight but as far as
first impressions go I'm honestly
thrilled that Sakura has been training
under lady Tsunade managing in her own
way to find an identity in a critically
important vertical the likes of which
Naruto and Sasuke aren't good at it
plays to the Natural strength she
demonstrates as a character in the first
part and builds upon them naturally
giving me a sense that she is in fact
her own
[Music]
character as a concept I really love
time skips and stories they can't really
be used all too often and when used
correctly can offer a lot of
anticipation and fun for the audience
reading or watching a great example of
this is once again one piece where
before the time skip everyone had a
clear motivation a clear set goal to aim
for in the time they had to train and
once they return after the time skip we
anticipate the reveal of how each person
did during their time away Dragon Ball
on the other hand took a different
approach by effectively ending on a high
note at the end of the 23rd ten kaii
budai and when they pick back up in the
saan arc they communicated the passage
of time visually through either the
action between Goku and radit or through
Goku now having a young son called Gohan
to be clear I'm not saying either of
those approaches to the time skip are
unique and I'm certainly not suggesting
that Kishimoto looked to mirror his
approach after any one of these I mean
this Arc of Naruto was written 2006 well
before the time skip of One Piece I'm
just using these as examples of how one
might approach this narrative mechanic
and make it work for them interestingly
though the Naruto series seems to have
taken an approach similar two but not
exactly the same as either of them
similar to one piece in that Naruto's
final Arc before the time skip ends in a
tragic Manner and spurred on from the
results of that our heroes now have a
clear-cut goal to work towards and like
Dragon Ball we see the passage of time
with certain characters more accurately
through the revelation of their new
circumstances while we can see the
developments and improvements of Naruto
and Sakura with extreme Clarity during
the reintroduction training sessions
with Kakashi we also see the new
position gar finds himself in now that
the dust has settled and as it happens
this Arc concerns itself with his story
[Applause]
[Music]
greatly finally after all this time the
Akatsuki are making their presence felt
and in this Arc they are pretty damn
awesome Itachi specifically I found to
be massively entertaining in that regard
creepy as it was but I'll touch on that
a little later as it happens these
Akatsuki folks are after individuals
known as jinchuriki these are humans
like gar and Naruto that within them
possess the spirit of one of the
nine-tailed beast spirit things and
speaking of which one of this arc's
strongest reintroductions comes by way
of gar to the story we catch up with him
in the Sand Village he was raised in as
the new kazakage the differences don't
stop there however and we see just how
much he's changed when a character from
the Akatsuki arrives and starts to
slaughter the people of his village
there are flashbacks detailing in
explicit terms how G's mindset has
changed over the last number of years
dedicating himself to his people he
wants to build a connection with his
village gain the respect and to become
something precious to them he wants to
be a person people can look up to
someone who can lead and look after his
community it's a beautiful 180 he's
taken since we last saw him during the
tunin exams with my favorite
demonstrations of his character coming
in the form of his defense of his own
village using all of his chakra in a
massive effort shielding his people from
the oncoming attacks from darara and I
don't know what it is but every single
time gar Tangles with any one it's
always aacal something amazing to look
at visually while offering up some juicy
narrative growth in the process the
fight that takes place while not being
much to look at in the anime in the
manga the page spreads are truly
breathtaking the scale is evident and
only further serves to reinforce the
extreme effort gar is willing to push
himself towards in the name of
protecting others now despite the fight
ending in defeat for the young kazakage
it's clear that GAR is on the path to
winning the war in his mind helped
obviously by by the young Uzumaki
Naruto's actions and philosophy however
now kidnapped and in transit to the
stronghold of the Akatsuki for purposes
we have yet to fully understand the word
reaches Naruto and his allies something
needs to be done and this my friends is
where our story really kicks off but
before I jump into Naruto and the gang's
effort to catch up with and save gar I
have one small nitpick that I just have
to get out in the open there have been
very few things in Naruto the series
that have bothered me and honestly fewer
than is standard for a story I review on
a long-term basis however now I think is
the time to talk about a particularly
bad piece of writing that's all over
this manga it's minor but it would be
disingenuous for me not to mention it
amongst all the praise I've given the
series my pet peeve with this series is
when a character says and I quote that
Jutsu you know when in movies characters
that our best friends tell us that
they're best friends like hey man we've
been friends since we were kids etc etc
people don't really speak to each other
like that in the real world and it just
sucks me out of the experience when I
hear it or see it in writing and in a
sense that's what that Jutsu does for me
when a character says it to another you
can't be talking about that Jutsu it's I
mean like they may as well be winking at
the camera now with that said I totally
understand the utility of such a
sentence Kishimoto wants to tell us that
whomever's speaking has an ace up their
sleeve but he doesn't want to tell us
what that is I get it it's a builder of
anticipation in a sense but there has to
be a better way than this and to be
honest it wouldn't have bothered me if
it had only been once or twice in the
series but it happens countless times
all right so back to the story once word
reaches Naruto back at the Village lady
Tsunade sends himself Sakura and Kakashi
to check it out their mission is to sus
out the situation in the S Village and
report back immediately before there's
any trouble one thing I will say though
is that once they do arrive Sakura
demonstrates how impressive she is with
her abilities to heal the wounded and
cure poison there's now such a
pronounced contrast with her
particularly when you compare her with
the comparatively much less competent
child she was when the series began and
this isn't by any means all she's
improved since these days but we'll get
to that soon furthermore before we go
into the Final Act of the story I do
want to say that I really enjoyed the
wild cards that were injected into the
mix right before the second half of this
Arc out of nowhere guys team with
everyone's favorite little Splendid
ninja Rock Lee is roped into this
Mission Kakashi and his team decide to
try and retrieve gar from those that
stole him away and it's something Naruto
is very passionate about pursuing and in
that Pursuit trouble finds
them I think what I like most about this
section which doesn't just depict
Itachi's fight with Kakashi's group but
also gu's team with Itachi's Ally Kisame
isn't simply just how imposing the
enemies are presented but how capable
the leaders of each group are Kakashi
and Guy there's some great lines of
dialogue from Kakashi here that really
helped to relax me into the situation
revealing Itachi's strategy his
weaknesses with his eyesight and
threatening him by saying that he
Kakashi doesn't make the same mistakes
twice almost putting himself on the same
level as Itachi and reminding us all too
that he was a prodigy when he was
growing up and really I think despite
the two fights happening side by side
with different people guy and Kakashi
they share a ton in common with both
leaders groups suffering compromises to
their abilities leaving much of the
heavy lifting to guy and Kakashi
respectively guy ends up implementing a
technique very similar to that which Lee
used against gar and in the manga the
scenes feel truly massive the scope of
the battle feels enormous which
interestingly is the exact opposite of
Kakashi's fight with Itachi and this is
by design it felt painfully intimate
everything from Itachi's first
appearance to his constant state of
always feeling comfortable in every
situation I mean this is why Kakashi in
this instance added so much to the scene
with a Tachi popping up out of the
Shadows the reassurance Kakashi gave me
as a reader felt much needed but good
God did I not anticipate what he would
put Naruto through acting as some sort
of sadistic Spirit of Christmas Past
confronting him with manifestations of
his deepest insecurities regrets and
fears it's a masterful touch further
separating Itachi as a villain or Foe
unlike any we've seen before in this
story climaxing in a sequence where
Kakashi holds Itachi off long enough for
Sakura to bring Naruto back to reality
where he lands a devastatingly
impressive attack in his feral Spirit
State and it's the combination of this
in tandem with his shadow clone
technique that made this hype as all
hell and that's when Itachi and kasami
revealed that these were fakes the
entire time and that their real selves
aren't anywhere close by appearing
before them like this simply because
they wish to stall them frustrating as
it was for sure it was also a brilliant
scene and one that really freaked me out
while I was reading it all right so the
situation is big door has a lock gar is
on the other side being killed and
because of that door and the seal that's
on it they have to split up into a bunch
of different fights some are great and
others we straight up just do not see so
let's kick things off with one of the
battles that we do see the battle inside
the cave featuring granny Chio and
Sakura versus Sasori Sakura's fight with
Lady Chio against Sasori was actually
way way better than I was anticipating
Sakura while showing promise in a
multitude of areas always felt
significantly less interesting Jew in
part to her being used predominantly for
comedy and well to swoon over Sasuke
which again that's totally normal for a
young girl in a story to do but when all
of the other characters have deeply
philosophical and moral dilemmas at the
core of their respective characters that
they themselves deal with in every fight
it really felt like when different
battles took place Sakura was left out
to dry but in this Arc Kishimoto seems
to have given her something much more to
work with or at the very least build
something significant off of the strong
foundations laid During certain sections
of prior art s characters like Kakashi
Rock Le gar Hinata Nei Naruto and even
Sasuke all derive their issues from
their upbringings however compared to
these characters Sakura's upbringing was
comparatively painless and well normal I
mean in the first arc when she was
introducing and presenting herself in
the first Arc she defined herself by
what at the time was most important to
her Sasuke but fast forward to right now
after the time skip she can now derive
ambition and motivation not from her
childhood but from the events that took
place over the course of the series's
first half stuff that we the readers can
relate to she's now full of regret after
she failed to keep Sasuke from fleeing
the village in the first place
disappointed that she was too weak to
help bring him home and now years later
she's trained to become significantly
stronger studying under lady tsuna to
gain Jutsu to specifically protect and
heal her friends and in this scene she
fights tooth and nail against sesori
just so that she can live up to her own
ideals one moment long longer I've been
critical in the past tour but I also
give credit where it's due and that
right there that's a tremendous
Improvement on all fronts at numerous
points in this fight Sakura is told to
stand down to let the old lady handle
this fight and time and time again she
picks herself off the ground and shows
everyone including us the readers that
she isn't the same scared little girl
she once was and really while she
started the story as this girl I was
sort of only lukewarm on this fight
alongside granny Chio acts as at least
for me her coronation as a fully
realized character with a wonderful
resolve clearly on display struggling
with her own internal psychological
questions unique to her by the way and a
master that sees something inside her
student that no one else seems to see
where Sasuke has his Clan's genetics or
Heritage and Naruto has the fox spirit
it's easy to forget that Sakura doesn't
have these same advantages and for her
to become as exceptional as she is right
here is a feet worth standing back and
showing praise for couple this with the
fact that her opponent sesori and her
partner Chio and you have for yourself a
narrative cocktail primed for some
effective emotional imagery and a
challenge large enough to allow Sakura
to amaze us all with her new abilities
as Chio is faced with aggression against
her own lost grandson having totally
lost his way by the way stared with the
love that he cherished and so needed
uses his powers of puppetry to wield the
parents he lost as a child it's
unsettling and it's tragic particularly
when you take into account the fashion
with which Chio and Sakura see to his
demise using the puppets of his parents
assuming the same positions around him
as they symbolically welcome him to the
afterlife stabbing him collectively in
the same pose they were seen hugging him
once before this event also concerns
itself with Chio considerably I found
her character quite abrasive and well
unlikable when we were introduced to her
but she too has undergone a considerable
change one that is linked in many ways
to Gar and his standing in his community
and speaking speaking of gar time to
finally check in with the character
leading the charge for his rescue Naruto
the more this series explores Naruto as
a character the more interesting he
becomes to me since the beginning of
this series we haven't really had much
chance to see Kakashi show Naruto much
attention but that changes in this Arc
and with that change something came into
Focus for me a theme I don't often see
explored in as much depth and honest a
fashion is that of responsibility within
Shonen stories now I know what going to
say that's sort of the Crux of like 90%
of various characters and to that I say
I appreciate and understand that but
within those stories often times if the
outcome of a rash decision made by a
character results in confrontation or
aggression normally stories will lean
more in the camp of determination and
tenacity to save the day for that
character which sort of flies in the
face of the theme of responsibility I
think in a sense Naruto desperately
wants to save Sasuke he desperately
wants to save gar it's as clear as day
on his face his frustration and anger is
bubbling to the surface as he brandishes
his Fox spirit's Powers more and more he
promised Sakura he promised everyone and
he promised himself that he would bring
back gar home and yet at numerous points
in this Arc he loses his temper and
finds himself either compromising his
team's effort or their well-being
forcing us to contend with the notion
that if Naruto truly would do anything
to bring them back then he would also
deny himself this IND Ence into violence
and revenge that he so clearly
desperately is pushing for all in the
name of creating the best possible
chance to save gar in this instance
perhaps more times in this Arc than we
have seen in any Arc prior Naruto has
assumed his feral State eyes and Claws
poised for an animalistic attack to try
and force his way to Gar perhaps with
his failings and helping Sasuke echoing
in his mind also but the point is that
his intentions are good but he must know
that that's not the best way and yet he
indulges in it regardless this is why I
love Kakashi because in this Chase he
grounds the young ninja reaffirming to
him that they are indeed on the same
team and that if he wants gar back they
just need to be smart about how they
approach this altercation with darara
and you know what's interesting about
this particular mechanic with Naruto is
that as it happens the more he loses
himself to the spirit the more this
Behavior invokes its power and the more
of a risk he runs in not only never
achieving his goal but he might lose
himself completely also thanks to his
friendship with the likes of Judah and
Kakashi he's managed to avoid this but I
just find it interesting that this power
which he draws from if drawn from too
much will run counter to what his
ultimate goals are and nothing drive
that home more than
this
Nar there's a simple but fantastic
series of panels in this manga where gar
finds himself all alone fading away with
no one to help him and simply Naruto
someone who's found himself in that same
situation thinks of the times when he
was at his loneliness eventually he
slowly but surely built a community
around him that cared about him it's
been described in the story and
particularly in this Arc that Naruto's
power is to build connections with
everyone he speaks with and this is
reflected in these panels as time went
on he was able to build around him a
wonderful community of friends and loved
ones but gar didn't have those same
advantages and when Chio starts to make
murmurings along the lines of this is
how it is for kazakage Naruto snaps no
one understands gar like Naruto does and
even Naruto can't imagine what his
circumstances must have been like
interestingly there's something of a
contradiction at play here where much of
the drama seems to be stemming from in a
very natural and great way mind you in
how Naruto feels in relation to Gar
versus how the rest of the world seems
to treat ninjas and certainly gin
shariki they are disposable and yet in
this Outburst with the death of gar
despite wanting to be Hokage one of the
highest positions in this structure he
seems beside himself totally and utterly
distraught at the notion that no one
ever considered how he might have felt
how gar might have felt how his life
might have gone different had he not
been forced to connect with this spirit
in the first place in other words
Naruto's here to shake things up he
wants to become Hokage and maybe he'll
change this crazy world along the way
this show of emotion and frankly common
sense resonates with the Oldtimer and in
a last ditch effort to do what she
believes is the right thing to do she
sacrifices herself to bring gar back
from the brink and the depiction of
which is beautiful surrounded by those
he longed for connection with gar now
has a family who loves
him I'm
break tonight something I haven't
complimented Naruto as much for in this
series is its consistent sense of flow
in the past I've criticized shows like
Dragon Ball super for feeling broadly
speaking like a collection of short
story arcs with clear-cut beginnings and
endings with little to no connective
tissue between arcs themselves to help
create a sense that there's this Grand
Story or Adventure in the original
Dragon Ball so many of the arcs flowed
naturally into each other providing
setups and payoffs for themselves in
other words it successfully felt like a
single massive story and thankfully I
can say the same is true for Naruto
something happens in one Arc and so
therefore those actions or outcomes
necessarily impact the coming narrative
the tuning exams led to the Ambush which
led to the third hokage's death which
led to the search for Tsunade etc etc
everything in this universe feels
connected which in turn for me at least
helps me to feel that much more invested
in each and every narrative Choice
that's made because I know that each and
every narrative choice is likely to
directly impact the
future there were a few things that
stuck with me after the conclusion to
last week's material firstly it was the
amicable nature gar embraced Naruto with
highlighting that these two are the only
two people in their respective circles
that truly understand each other and due
to that fact the length Naruto went to
for gar really helped to highlight how
far he has come socially now surrounded
by the family he always wanted and has
now acquired despite the losses that
took place to make all of this possible
representing a dated way of thinking now
passing on there was Kakashi's ability
to use the variation on the mango
Sharingan which on its own is awesome
but speaks to a sadness for his past
where he lost a friend in Obito in a
nutshell my reaction to it was oh my God
this is so oh no it's really sad isn't
it and finally the introduction of a new
character called Sai my first impression
of Sai was that he was creepy and
underhanded and while all of my
assessment was technically correct what
he offers to this story is so much more
than that simple first impression from a
consistency perspective he slots into
the story rather seamlessly despite him
being a relative unknown before this
introduction with him coming from the
Black Ops Foundation he seems like a
natural addition to the team of Sakura
and Naruto seeing as they at this point
were missing Kakashi and Sasuke in their
cell however despite side joining the
team Naruto and Sakura still needed a
leader to help them follow through on
this lead provided by sesori in the
previous Arc the lead informed them of a
scheduled meeting he had organized with
a mold he had in the ranks of Orochimaru
which happens to to be exactly where
Naruto wants to be due to the importance
of this Mission lady Tsunade employs the
help of Yamato a level-headed and
grounded older ninja descended from the
First Hokage this guy didn't make a
massive impression on me but he does
offer a useful mechanism that does come
into play later and overall seems like a
swell and balanced fellow by and large
he doesn't offer a massive amount
emotionally to the story but in terms of
facilitating the plot no other character
helps in that respect
more once again broadly speaking I think
s is an interesting character for two
reasons I mentioned that within this
story it made sense for him to join
their ranks to help out however it's
what this fellow represents for the
series that I think offers his true
strengths within this narrative firstly
he seems to be the embodiment of what
Shinobi are in this world raised by the
Black Ops forces he doesn't possess any
emotion or even understanding of how
other people react or think he's an
extreme manifestation of the tool for
Destruction and Espionage that have been
espoused by the hups of this world even
by the Third KAG himself at one point
that's one reason why he's interesting
the second reason is how he compliments
and contrasts Naruto I've spoken about
the importance of creating a contrast
character for Naruto the main character
to amplify his own personality Sasuke
was that for Naruto first and at various
points in the narrative that role has
shifted to different individuals in this
instance Sai fulfills that role so many
of his values run counter to Naruto's
and just like clockwork he brings out
the best in articular ninja what's also
interesting with this character is the
effect he he has on both Naruto and
Sakura by bluntly and coldly addressing
the actions of Sasuke he puts pressure
on both of them to justify Sasuke's
Behavior leading to a variety of
refusals from Naruto to work with him in
the first place and many many outbursts
the best of which was
this this is what I mean when I say Sai
brings out the best in Naruto what was
once rage and childish retaliation has
been replaced with a cam unflinching
resolve when he starts to realize that
these words from sigh don't necessarily
come from a place of intentional
antagonism but instead from a genuine
and troubling bewilderment that's only
interested in looking at this situation
from a cold utilitarian
standpoint teni bridge this section had
me stressed the hell out and I truly
mean that apart from the plan as it
currently is being extrem extremely
shaky no matter what way you look at it
trying to impersonate sori we also have
the wild card inside and we learn that
the informant is Kabuto and on top of
that the fact that Kabuto is actually a
triple agent there to betray and kill
sesori and you have for yourself a page
Turner unlike any I've seen from the
series in a long while also there's this
instance in this Arc where lady tunate
is looking out and notices an animal
jumping out from the brush and once
again this happens here at the bridge I
thought this was interesting as it turns
out it's actually aochi Maru lying in
weight which made me think was he at the
Village too I mean I love stuff like
that because even if it wasn't it's
still a cool piece of paranoia
kishimoto's injected into my mind which
is great because now we're primed for a
spectacular fight and this fight is all
of that and a bag of chips something
this Arc does a phenomenal job with is
making the fight feel personal as soon
as Yamato sees Orochimaru and everything
on the bridge starts turning South he
signals for the others this was a
brilliant touch to add drama to this
story with a great piece piece of visual
storytelling through Naruto immediately
showing signs of losing himself to that
more aggressive and feral Fox Spirit
State he's been in before this is an
incredibly important and emotional
battle for Naruto and to see this
reinforced by his immediate elevation
into this state without warning was
brilliant however what made me fall in
love with this section wasn't
necessarily the cool visuals but the
meaning and narrative behind them and
the consequences thereafter there's a
heavy amount of emphasis placed on
jiah's Words as he explains to yam what
he went through through while training
Naruto over the last number of years
informing him not to allow too many
tales to reveal themselves as Naruto
needs more and more power with them
effectively acting as a mechanism to
display how far gone Naruto has lost
himself to the fox Spirit itself as I
said it all looks very impressive
however as Naruto Powers up to attack
Orochimaru and Kabuto this happens
there's an obvious lesson to learn here
for Naruto but remember what I said
about this being an emotional and
personal fight for more than one person
well while I saw and enjoyed what Naruto
offered in this situation I was
completely taken aback by how Sakura
reacted to being hurt in the process of
this PowerUp when she wakes she doesn't
feel hurt or emotionally shocked by
Naruto's attack instead her reaction is
perfectly in keeping with her own
existing motivations she sees this as a
direct result of not Naruto being
selfish or losing control unnecessarily
but instead her own prior weaknesses she
couldn't bring Sasuke back and as a
result Naruto made a promise to bring
Sasuke back no matter what and as it
happens no matter what in this instance
means this it's extreme to say the least
he's on the brink and he may even lose
his life this sort of clear-headedness
and honest accountability on behalf of
Sakura is not only refreshing to hear
but incredibly Brave and Noble too after
seeing this reaction from Sakura it
honestly felt like she had grown the
most during the time Skip it's a
remarkable difference on the Naruto
front the Finesse humanity and technique
of him is completely gone at this point
there are no familiar techniques on
display like the shadow clones which is
a great touch I think to make this form
feel like an embodiment of something
Naruto isn't and when you combine that
with the fact that he's up against
Orochimaru it's in every sense of the
word no longer a battle between ninja
but monsters at this point Sakura does
try to help and bring Naruto back from
the brink once again but she gets hurt
in the process all right so this was
visually awesome and super fun to read
through it felt immensely cathartic
watching oroi Maru on the back foot
during this encounter we haven't seen
him fight all out in a while and this
fox Spirit really seems to be pushing
him back at every turn again the layout
on page spreads are fitting for the
occasion but if I'm being honest the
best stuff comes after the Smoke Clears
and Yamato using his special abilities
is able to seal away that spirit and
bring Naruto back from that breaking
point this is where Yamoto proves
himself as a worthy leader and Noble
ninja in my opinion his confrontation
with Naruto concerning the
responsibility he has to do his best
without the help of the fox spirit is
exactly what I was getting at last last
week this Spirit provides a welcome
shortcut and might even feel empowering
Naruto very clearly wants something and
at this point this seems like the
easiest route to meet that goal however
there are clear and easily identifiable
drawbacks to this line of action and
this is a common angle in Coming of Age
stories take Sam Ry Spider-Man 3 for
example it's not everyone's favorite
film but it tries to tell this exact
Story the Venom symbiote while offering
some more power and freedom comes at the
cost of what makes Peter Parker himself
leading to him hurting those around him
the exact same thing happens to Naruto
in this instance capping off the
confrontation with a quote so perfect
from yam I'd put it up there as one of
my favorite quotes from this entire
series the source of your strength
Naruto isn't the fox tal spirit it's
your own if you want to help Sasuke do
it using your own power if you want to
protect Saka do it using your own
strength brilliant this portion of the
story is where yam's upsides really
Shine for me as a new addition to the
main squad on top of being a Noble
level-headed leader type he's also
skilled in a wide and rare variety of
Jutsu one that comes in massively handy
when Sai who had be missing during the
encounter with Orochimaru attempts to
join forces with him and leaves promptly
along with Kabuto and himself thankfully
however Yamoto has a tracker on him and
little does I know that he's about to
lead him to where Orochimaru is hiding
with Sasuke this is a fantastic chance
for them to save him and a chance for
Naruto to show that he can control his
desire to relinquish control to the
spirit inside of him
once they confront Sai in his cell the
true scope of what he represents in this
series is plain as day while yes he
represents broadly speaking what ninjas
mean in this world specific to him he
also has a Sketchbook which reveals a
lot more about him and the process he
was created within in the first place
Once Upon a Time having a brother
someone who cherished him who cared for
him and someone who held on to a
specific sketchbook for however when he
died Sai lost any and all memory of what
he was going to put into that book for
his brother this book itself represents
sai's lost Humanity in conversations he
refers to himself as no one nobody a
clean slate that can act as an extension
of danzo's will a product of the
foundation's cruel methods to expunge
him of all that made him who he was in
the first place or at least that seems
to be the case until recently for when
he realizes he's lost that Sketchbook he
shows visible concern proving to us the
readers and viewers that while his
Humanity might not be visible on the
surface deep down tied to what that book
represents are the remnants of who he
really is as a person there's a
confrontation between Naruto and Sai
where Naruto tries to explain to him his
reasoning as to why he's so determined
to save Sasuke from those circumstances
despite his desire to stay and have
nothing more to do with him and in it I
think there's a connection being made
between Naruto meaning nothing to Sasuke
and Sai referring to himself as no one
despite Sasuke actively seeing Naruto as
quote nothing just because someone says
something isn't so doesn't remove the
bond that exists between two people that
genuinely cared for each other this
speaks to sai's relationship with his
brother when faced with Sai further
questioning why Naruto insists on trying
to save someone in Sasuke instead of
getting angry Naruto compassionately and
calmly explains his relationship with
Sasuke and his determination in the face
of impossible odds to never stop
fighting for him and in a way it's as if
he's directly speaking to SAI himself
and while a very solemn scene I think
it's really effective and at this moment
Naruto feels like he's reached an
understanding with s perhaps for the
first time since he's met him leading to
him for the first time actually trusting
him to carry out an important job to
locate Sasuke in this Hideout and it's
here that Kishimoto decides to once
again Place some paranoia and doubt in
our minds as he reveals sai's original
plan wasn't to help their team or to
even be a conduit between danzo and
Orochimaru but instead to specifically
assassinate Sasuke whether or not the
experiences and epiphanies he's had
since meeting Naruto will be enough to
dissuade this mission is another
question but either way with good
intentions or not he's running to
Sasuke's location it's super exciting as
the decision Sai makes once he reaches
Sasuke will effectively Define his true
intentions and really his character I
love stuff like this it makes me rethink
the entire interaction he had with
Naruto asking questions like did he
Master emotional deception like what
Sakura did to him earlier in the story
and even if he hasn't the very fact that
Kishimoto got me thinking and asking
these questions is proof that he
absolutely nailed this tension building
sequence thankfully though as it happens
Sai turns out to be a good
[Music]
[Applause]
boy the reunion between Sasuke and the
others feels Monumental it very much
feels like the culmination of everything
that's been built up to so far and
Kishimoto goes all out in dedicating as
much real estate as possible within the
chapter this scene takes place in for
massive page spreads to fully capture
the emotion of that moment from the
first time seeing each other in years to
close-ups of their respective reactions
to seeing each other there are so many
full page spreads that at points it
almost looks like a coloring book and I
mean that in the best possible way they
look very impressive with the
Expressions positioning and staging of
characters offering plenty in the way of
tone setting furthermore this sequence
deals with some of my favorite subject
matter and comes packed with some
wonderful imagery to convey what's
happening to boot when battling with
Sasuke we get to see a host of new
abilities he's clearly been working on
working on still with the single-minded
purpose of finding and killing his
brother to him now he claims that
nothing else matters to him except his
brother's death even if it means merging
with Orochimaru this I don't think I
believe though it's almost as if he
wants to convince himself that and I say
that because of what happens later on my
favorite part of this encounter has to
be the struggle Naruto is undergoing and
not just with Sasuke but himself a
struggle to resist the Allure of tapping
into the fox spirit's power and to
increase his chances of forcibly taking
Sasuke back home it's a wonderful
example of Naruto putting others first
and showing belief in himself to do what
needs to be done with his own power and
strength however there is something that
makes this scene a little more freaky
while Naruto is trying to Center himself
in his mind and subdue the fox Spirit
Sasuke is there in his mind with himself
and the fox it's a first in the series
and in being such it really gives Sasuke
an air of superiority and control the
likes of which we've not seen so far
however once again while Sasuke says
that nothing else matters to him other
than his brother's killing he leaves
Naruto and everyone else alive despite
them posing a direct opposition to his
plans and their consistent insistence on
sticking their noses in when he has
actively stated that he doesn't want
that there's a contradiction at play
here if nothing else matters including
your own well-being then why not get rid
of them here and now well I guess
because while he doesn't want to admit
it there is something else important to
him his friends so while this fight and
Mission ends in spectacular failure
Naruto and his allies at the very least
left with their lives and a deeper
understanding of the current situation
they need to become stronger I really
enjoyed this Arc I felt like it started
strong introduced and established some
really interesting new characters while
reinforcing the themes of responsibility
and highlighted the indoctrination of
young Ninja at a new extreme through the
likes of Sai who ended up really liking
in the finish both of the big fight
sequences in this Arc centered around
pivotal narrative beats concerning the
likes of Naruto Sakura Sai yam and
Sasuke overall I thought this Arc was a
efficient focused and snappy the teni
bridge sequence had me at the edge of my
seat and it managed to maintain that
tension through the battle with Sasuke
and thankfully they not only managed to
continue this goodness into the next Arc
but expanded some love to characters
like Shikamaru who has since quickly
become one of if not my favorite
character to follow in this story so
let's dive into this Arc and see
why akatski suppression mission right
from the top this Arc was phenomenal and
marks the second time this story
affected me emotionally primarily it
focuses on two characters in Naruto and
Shikamaru with the latter carrying most
of the heavy lifting along with his cell
group after a tragedy befalls them it's
rich with Coming of Age lessons to learn
and through these two characters
primarily we see what that looks like as
we explore their mindsets after each of
their respective setbacks Naruto after
coming face to face with Sasuke and
failing in the PRI Arch and Shikamaru
who experienced his own unique losses
having completed my notes on this
section I also realized that I didn't
talk or write much about the two main
antagonists of this Arc two akatski
members called hedan and kakuzu given
the amount of focus the theme
surrounding other characters receive in
this Arc I was surprised with just how
much characterization this pair ended up
receiving which only helps I think in
the long run to elevate the struggle to
defeat these two ultimately instead of
appearing stereotypical brandishing all
the personality of a brooding piece of
wood these two genuinely felt like two
individuals distinct from each other
that on a consistent basis break each
other's ch chops cracking jokes and
insulting each other like two guys in
the office with an established Rapport
their powers particularly heeden
introduced some wonderful opportunities
for Shikamaru to play with at various
stages and kakuzu is just straight up a
massive wall the likes of which even
Kakashi struggles to overcome priming
him as the perfect Target for our hero
of focus in this Arc Naruto however with
that said I've heard justifiable
complaints aimed at this arc's
conclusion and I'll be exploring them as
well as offering my two cents so let's
start from the start Naruto's training
this is what Naruto does for effectively
the entire runtime of this Arc Until the
End struggle through training after
failing to help Sasuke as it stands I
love training sequences for characters I
find them compelling and often bolster
the trainee characterization and
motivations by showing their tenacity
and determination to achieve their
respective goals through hardship
however something makes this Arc Stand
Out amidst all the other training stin
in the story something that expanded my
understanding of Jutsu and placed what I
believe to be a massive near near
impossible task in front of Naruto a
near impossible task with a ridiculously
short time limit through this training
we come to learn from Kakashi that the
renen a move Naruto already struggled to
get this level of Competency with is
actually an incomplete Jutsu developed
by the fourth Hokage himself I thought
that was a really nice touch as it leads
Kakashi into a quieter more
inspirational sequence where he
confidently states that he believes in
Naruto and that he thinks that someday
he will surpass even the fourth Hokage
himself moments like this make me
reflect than when Kakashi first met
Naruto back in the beginning not knowing
just how far this little kid would go
but throughout saw glimpses of his
potential leading to this moment where
he reaffirms Naruto's desire and belief
in himself but there's still a lot of
work to do so let's break down exactly
what needs to be done Naruto needs to
number one learn to use his change of
nature type Jutsu number two then
combine it with the renen to complete a
Jutsu that even the fourth hok KAG
couldn't oh and number three to do this
all within a time frame so short that it
would be impossible ble to complete any
of these steps in isolation this story
is All About surpassing barriers
overcoming the odds and showing the
naysayers wrong but with these exact
parameters as a reader I sincerely felt
as though there was absolutely no way to
make this work other than making some
sort of plot contrivance and that's when
Kakashi had one of the most ingenious
ideas I've ever heard in the
story I love when stories can surprise
me and truthfully I never considered
this as an option partially because I
wasn't 100% on the mechanics of the
technique but it's honestly a perfect
strategy there isn't enough time for
Naruto to practice and perfect this
technique on his own but if he splits up
into hundreds of clones then he can cram
years worth of training into a
comparatively tiny amount of time and
the best part about this strategy is
that this is an approach only Naruto
himself can utilize due to the
circumstances of his birth and the
resulting bottomless pit of chakra he
has and what's more is despite the
stress of what has just happened with
Sasuke he remains focused willing to
shoulder all of this responsibility time
and time again pushing himself to the
absolute limit his Breaking Point with
this entire sequence in the story
representing Naruto's true strength and
tenacity independent of the fox spirit
and as a result of all of this this
technique when he perfects it it will be
a technique not only uniquely his own
but has been developed with the express
purpose of giving him the strength he
needs to save his friend with the best
part being it will free him from having
to rely on the fox spirit's power
building upon the Lessons Learned in the
prior Arc and so as a continuation of
Naruto's story I loved this training
[Music]
sequence shikamaru's team versus hedan
and kakuzu this is the plotline that
gives this Arc its name while out on a
suppression mission to stop the akatski
Personnel team Asuma with Shikamaru
present runs into two individuals I
touched on earlier hedan and kakuzu as I
think it should a large portion of this
fight hinges on the readers or Our
Hero's lack of understanding of the
enemy we have no idea at this point what
their powers are why they're so
confident and what on Earth hedan is
wearing naturally due to the mystery
surrounding their abilities the stakes
raised themselves considerably creating
an ideal circumstance for Shikamaru to
formulate a plan of action after
deciphering what Jutsu hedan is
utilizing leading to a brilliant and
absolutely brutal killing strike of
hedan by a by the squad leader but wait
psych that's the wrong number with that
and shikamaru's zaap of energy unable to
restrain him any longer he's forced to
watch on powerless as Asuma gets stabbed
to near death in front of him in a
fashion only hedan could possibly pull
off thanks to his gruesome and honestly
sadistic Jutsu moments before he dies
reinforcements arrive forcing the two
akatski members to turn tail and run for
it leaving Asuma to die in shikamaru's
arms imparting before he leaves some
final words to each of his students and
surprisingly this felt authentic it felt
tragic with an appropriate level of
gravity to it for sure but what I was
surprised by was how readily I got on
board with and connected to how
Shikamaru and his cell group must have
been
feeling asuma's death I'm not sure if
this will come as a surprise to anyone
but I didn't expect to care as much as I
did during this sequence it shocked me
with how touching I found this ceremony
and the lengthy amount of time given to
this character's passing and since then
I've wondered why that was assuma wasn't
by any means a character I had an issue
with but I also wouldn't say he was one
I was particularly close to either which
honestly in retrospect made me wish I
had formed more of a bond with this
character across the series instead of
just the last 10 or so chapters but it
did make me wonder why I was feeling as
strongly as I did during this scene and
I think the reason why Shikamaru you see
going into a long running series
completely blind like I am with the
expectation of writing a review each and
every week is kind of like being an
Archer without a Target being asked to
hit the bullseye I try to make guesses
as to what's important to remark upon
but I'll always miss something when I'm
going in blind it's just the nature of
the beast when I reviewed Dragon Ball
earlier in the year I found it to be a
very pleasant experience as I knew what
was or was not important and so could
focus on and plan Seas for future things
I wanted to talk about like Goku's
transformation into the oaro in the
first Arc and how it has a direct
Connection in explaining his last
moments with his grandpa who we will
then meet much later in the urai Baba
section I can't do stuff like that with
Naruto I can only speak about things
that impacted me on that given week of
reading and hope and pray that I got the
important stuff however Shikamaru has
been a character that has time and time
again impressed me to no end initially
he seemed like a disinterested
unmotivated and boring character to make
up numbers for the background cast but
in his tune and exam fight he proved me
wrong after that he seemed like an
interesting character but not one that
would have served a leading role and
that's when the chase for Sasuke
happened and I once again was Pro proven
wrong and now I find myself over 300
chapters into this story watching as
this character I never anticipated I
would spend so much time with or connect
to one that has earned his standing
through struggle talent and effort
across this series making myself feel
this loss I think across the entire
story no character has surprised or
impacted me more than Shikamaru and what
I really appreciate about this series is
how dedicated and comfortable Kishimoto
is in Basking in the more Quiet Moments
whether that be solemn emotional still
or any combination of these I've
recognized him as being an incredible
artist with a particular flare for
Action creating some wonderfully kinetic
layouts however his attention to the
quieter moments across this Series has
really heightened my experience clearly
on display during asuma's funeral
distant shots of Shikamaru informing his
family in a long hallway all the framing
here really helping to sell the
atmosphere kishimoto's going for with
everyone taking the time to commemorate
this Noble and much loved Shinobi with
an appropriate amount of focus on the
character of Shikamaru and while I
thought all of this was great once I
finished this Arc my team suggested I
take a closer look at one specific
episode from the anime one that while
technically filler in many instances
elevated this section of the story to
new heights the manga never reached on
its
own episode
82 episode 82 of shipuden is a beautiful
and I think near perfect addition to the
series filled with stunning
cinematograph Ry the series of scenes
that decorate this short but powerful
episode heighten what was in fact the
purpose of shikamaru's portion which is
in effect his Coming of Age story I
always find these types of tales to be
profoundly powerful for a number of
reasons obviously because of their
hopeful relatability but more so because
of the crossroads and lessons that a
young person must learn in order to
become an adult Shikamaru doesn't know
what to do with himself and fails to
attend the funeral of his master Asuma
he wanders the streets sits isolated on
his porch for hours denying his mother's
offer for food until eventually his
father asks him to play him in a game of
shogi all shot from one angle at first
to emphasize the still measured and
reserved nature of the interaction with
shikaku remarking upon his son's
different approach to playing today
citing it as quote forceful the shogi
game itself offers this Father and Son
the means with which to subtly reach
each other with shikaku using it as a
vehicle to highlight his son's strengths
his gratitude for his son being alive
and teaching him not to shy away from
feeling what he's feeling eventually
reaching a boiling point where the angle
suddenly shift as Shikamaru flips the
table in Anger when he's reminded that
Asuma is dead shikaku tells him to let
it all out that sadness fear and anger
the direction is spectacular with
interesting angles close-ups of his
gritted teeth and clenched fists up
until now Shikamaru had always been
someone to rely on in a pinch to think
things through with a measured
calculated approach his father saw this
anger remarking on his forceful
uncharacteristic play style in the shogi
game and that it's not good to attend a
son's funeral in this scene shikaku
shows Shikamaru how to deal with a
tragic reality to allow these natural
feelings to come flooding out allowing
himself to mourn and later that night
armed with a clear head he looks again
at the shogi board recognizing a
particular tile symbolic of his bond
with Asuma and just like the Shinobi
Asuma wanted him to be Shikamaru jumps
to action and begins outlining his
Counterattack on those that took his
master and friend from him masterfully
highlighting moments where his plans
fail however this time he centers
himself dispassionately formulating this
plan meticulous ously there are some
glimpses of moments clearly taken from
the manga in this episode however it's
the pieces of added connective tissue
between these moments that I think
elevated the material far above what it
was in the manga there's nothing
compromised there's no theme devalued
for the sake of extending the runtime of
an anime episode everything here feels
well thought out purposeful and
effective in its telling it's exactly
what every anime adaptation of a long
running show should strive to be it's a
10 out of 10 brilliant addition to this
tale capping itself off with its main
focus Having learned a difficult but
important
[Music]
lesson I'm not sure if this is a
controversial take or not but I'm going
to be honest I like lady tady far more
than I ever liked the third Hokage we
actually get to see her work react to
drama and create strategies as the KAG
of this Village and its Shinobi with
this scene acting as a prime example of
that tying wonderfully together with and
complimenting The Arc Shikamaru
underwent in the anime episode
reflecting on when she lost someone near
and dear to her not wanting that for
anyone else unlike the third Hokage were
able to watch lady tady apply lesson she
learned unto the younger generation
telling and then ordering shikamaru's
cell of three not to go on some avenging
mission in the name of Asuma it's a
sound strategic argument that both
speaks to her as a leader and as a
character Having learned the exact same
lesson in the arc we were first
introduced to her unlike many characters
which typically act in a binary of
active or reactionary in terms of
Engagement with the plot she seems to
tick both boxes when the time calls for
it enacting her will as an active
character onto the story with Shikamaru
cell in this instance encouraging
Kakashi to lead the cell and as a
reactionary in the scene immediately
following as she formulates a plan of
action and support utilizing the updates
given to her by Sakura she's honestly a
fascinating character and one that sits
high in my rankings within this
story shikamaru's C attack despite them
entering into this scenario with a
newfound Vigor and Kakashi in toe I
legit felt a greater sense of forb
boarding entering into this scenario
than I ever thought possible when I
first met these two villains which I
think is a testament to kishimoto's
approach in building them up as a
credible threat complete with emotional
way and ties to Shikamaru and his
friends Eno and choji and while this
action gets off to a great start with
shikamaru's plan following through as he
anticipated Kishimoto ends up utilizing
this as an opportunity to show us how
different types of Jitsu react to each
other during this sequence we routinely
cut away to Naruto's training and Yamato
explaining the Dynamics between
different states once we get the basics
of one concept concerning change of
nature Kishimoto Cuts back to the action
and shows that mechanic in action
through Kakashi's lightning slicing up
kakuzu's Earth style
Jutsu furthermore I love that upon
hearing this from Yamato Naruto doesn't
focus on what he has that can defeat
Sasuke but instead focuses on how he can
amplify and compliment his friend
showing us that saving Sasuke is still
his one and only focus there's no
resentment no desire to hurt only
concern and love for his lost companion
it's a quick moment but it once again
reinforces the fact that Kishimoto tries
to stay true to his character's
motivations at all
times when Kakashi's attack reveals
kakuzu's true power separating into four
other opponents the scope of what lies
before Shikamaru becomes obvious
assuming the leadership position and
formulating a plan of attack utilizing
him himself as the anchoring point of
two separate fronts he's adopted the
most work and responsibility in this
group which is a far cry from the person
he once was someone that hardly ever
wanted to exert effort leading to this
awesome sequence where we as an audience
come to fully understand the scope of
shikamaru's plan that he readied himself
for every contingency and even conceived
of a means with which to dispose of
hedan the strategy implemented by
Shikamaru to defeat kakuzu was amazing
and absolutely cathartic I mean what a
payoff utilizing the information Garner
by Asuma to take down his attackers by
pitting their strengths against each
other what an outstanding effort on
behalf of
[Music]
shik I think at this point I was
thinking in my head okay so everyone's
either exhausted or not strong enough to
take this dude out the fight itself has
been amazing and a struggle against
kakuzu specifically but at this point I
didn't see a way out of this which I
think made what happens next all the
more effective for
me
I think what's interesting about this
section or involvement from Naruto is
how different people's opinions are on
his appearance here I spoke to one
person about this scene and we
completely disagreed on how Naruto's
involvement affected it so in this
section I'm going to explain both and
you can let me know which one you agree
with more let's start with my friend's
read on things my friend hated this
decision to include Naruto he felt as
though the entire Arc had been about Eno
Shikamaru and choji their relationship
with Asuma and that this was their big
battle to avenge their fallen Master
going on to say sure Shikamaru might get
to have his moment but Naruto just
steals everyone's Thunder and removes
everyone else's agency he had no
connection to this Arc but he just rose
up because he has to pay off his
training Arc in short he thought it was
horribly disconnected and as a result
hated it and to be honest depending on
what way you look at this I think that's
a fair way of reading the situation but
it wasn't mine I suppose in the manga
the two stories of this Arc are of
Shikamaru learning a lesson and Naruto
honing a new technique two characters
working through a struggle to overcome a
loss I understood that were part of that
cell and lost their Mentor too however
upon reflection their part in the ark
felt very small and not at all the focus
in the end I saw it as Naruto and
Shikamaru ending an arc that's centered
around them specifically the only one in
the cell that I cared about getting a
conclusion to their story with Shikamaru
for reasons I already explained choji
and Eno did do ayss and I did enjoy
their contribution but they very much
felt to me at least tagged onto the arc
at the very end albeit in a natural and
understandable way keeping in mind
however that I've only read the Manga I
have no idea if the anime did more stuff
to help choji and enu feel more like a
bigger part in the end but with that
said I do want to also acknowledge that
while Naruto's training was interesting
it didn't necessarily need to combine
with shikamaru's storyline battling the
akatski though it didn't bother me as it
didn't take away from shikamaru's moment
and from an in Universe position it
makes sense for Naruto to be there as he
has plenty to do with the akatski so in
the end I guess the biggest difference
between my opinion and my friends is
that I didn't feel that choji and Eno
played a big enough role in The Arc to
secure that big moment he wanted for
them I mean as far as I'm concerned
Kakashi contributed more to that story
than they did but in terms of my
reaction to Naruto showing up I don't
think I've ever been more happy to see
him as a character experiencing this
honestly felt kind of fresh too Naruto
up until now has been the one that
follows the leader and gets saved or
comes in clutch at the end in a sloppy
but effective fashion this on the other
hand feels similar though not identical
to Goku showing up to help fight the
ginu force in the back of my mind I'm
just thinking to myself has he managed
to get strong enough will we see the
perfected Jutsu he's been working on and
in addition to that his arrival onto the
battlefield comes with it an air of
quiet sto confidence I could really feel
the progression of his character
emotionally compared to the first arcs
once a character that fought to prove
himself by rushing into dangerous
circumstances without any plan and now
he's fighting specifically for a friend
and implements his shadow clones to gain
precious Intel to determine a plan of
attack there's a subtle maturity to
Naruto in this fight and it feels
wonderful to see him implement the
lessons he learned in the prior training
section he enjoyed but he falls
short I think this scene is perfect it's
a gentle but superb reminder that while
Naruto has developed and changed over
the course of the story he's still
himself willing to constantly pick
himself up off the ground to try and try
again until he gets the result he's
looking for willing to push himself into
circumstances that are dangerous if they
mean that he can get closer to achieving
his goal of protecting Sasuke it's a
wonderful combination of everything I
love about the character and I love the
subtle piece of foreshadowing we get
from the technique through the last
scene we see of Naruto training as he's
standing in the middle of a large crater
the attack itself is stunning and one
that eclipses any other effort I've seen
from any other character thus far in the
series capping on off with a wonderful
but quiet acknowledgement from Kakashi
that Naruto has indeed surpassed even
him and I love stuff like that but in
all honesty nothing caps off this fight
and really this Arc like Shikamaru
acting as hean God as he is passing
judgment onto him before blowing him up
and buing him underneath meters and
meters of rock and Earth coupled that
with the beautiful imagy provided and
you have for yourself a cacophony of all
the things I love about Kishimoto as a
manga artist I'm not kidding when I say
this that between these two arcs
Kishimoto felt really up the ante and
forced me to care about things I never
thought I would and of course built upon
already sturdy foundations that brings
us to where I find myself today it's
certainly not the flashiest but I love
how this fight really reflects and plays
into the Strategic aspects of the
leading character Shikamaru while also
feeling uniquely clever and appropriate
for a ninja styled encounter this fight
Shikamaru had with heeden doesn't at all
feel like a fight that could take place
in any other world other than Naruto
with the elements it takes advantage of
and as a result it gets extra points
from that for me the character of
Shikamaru has come Leaps and Bounds
farther than I ever thought he could
with his final scene once again
highlighting his fact as the shogi game
between himself and his father conclude
highlighting his acknowledgement of the
responsibility himself and his friends
bear going into the future and his
acceptance to the wife of his former
Master to become their guardian and
master in the future I've never seen
Shikamaru so motivated and determined to
work hard for a better tomorrow and I
honestly couldn't be happier with the
way this Arc
ended
[Music]
oo now that's a good
Cliffhanger to watch this
m let it be enough to reach the
Andross this new divine
The Itachi Pursuit
[Music]
mission that was the first sentence of
this Arc and with it commences a
brilliantly twisting and turning set of
stories filled with Incredible battles
definitely the best in the series I
think all centered around two characters
and their faded conflicts sas's pursuit
of his brother Itachi there's a lot to
cover in this video I haven't covered
Naruto since before the holidays and I
think this was my most enjoyable
experience when reading the material so
far whether that has more to do with my
heart growing fonder from absence or
whether it's the contents of these three
incredible arcs telling of the story
I'll leave it up to you to judge in an
effort however to make sure this video
doesn't last a million years I'll be
dividing this video into three natural
sections the first The Itachi Pursuit
Mission the second tale of jiah the
gallant and of course finishing with the
FED battle between Brothers each of
these will have their own metaphorical
and thematic strings I hope I pick up
and each has their battles holy hell do
they have their battles but one thing I
hope won't be lost here is that while I
am dividing this video into three
sections I want to communicate that this
story does a seamless job of perfectly
and naturally connecting each and every
Arc together implementing the words and
teachings of previous arcs to bolster
and in many cases greatly enhance the
power of certain key moments and the
first sentence of this Arc is no
different so long as you have mercy you
can't best Itachi this is a poisonous
mentality that clearly speaks to the
corruption that dwells deep within sas's
wouldbe kidnapper Orochimaru however
this Arc takes a Twist very early on
that I did not see
coming
no this is an interesting fight to kick
things off with and honestly it's not
because it's competitive in fact it's
not competitive at all but what what it
does show us is that there's an air of I
don't know narcissism or perhaps ego
attached to Sasuke now Sasuke has
nothing left to gain from Orochimaru and
so he absorbs him which is I guess fair
and still self-preservation outwardly
however Sasuke in this carries with him
a quiet confidence with everyone around
and you can hear this in how he speaks
to Orochimaru and the people he recruits
afterwards into his fourman cell group
but one thing that led me to suspect
that there was still so much more to
Sasuke than he was letting on was his
dedication too at numerous points in
this story to spare various individuals
lives if he could help it which again
flies in the face of what Orochimaru
told him in this arc's opening line
citing that he needs to strip himself of
Mercy but anyway a large portion of this
first section is dedicated to setting up
these chess pieces in this metaphorical
chess game would that be taken from a
combat strategy sense with Sasuke
recruiting the likes of sugu kin and
Jugo Karin introducing her first seems
to be the least complicated right off
the bat she offers a useful set of
senses and skills for Sasuke's team but
for the most part her contribution
serves support and comedic purposes
mostly with her admiration of Sasuke and
his sweaty grubby clothes making for a
character that Teeters the line between
gross and funny Jugo on the other hand
is sort of the Hulk to Sasuke's Black
Widow he's got this intense desire to
kill that he's overcome by from time to
time however Sasuke seems to be able to
Grant this man the freedom from his mind
that he's yearned for for what seems
like a long long time and if
introductions were anything to go by I'd
say that he's even more simp than Karin
which brings us to my favorite of the
members recruited sugu outside of me
really enjoying his design there's such
a weird confident and almost chaotic
nature to how this person conducts
himself around both Sasuke and others
furthermore on this chess board Naruto
and the rest of the protag Shinobi ready
themselves for this Pursuit they
recognize that Sasuke is after Itachi
and so they pursue Itachi also in the
hopes of finding Sasuke first oh and in
classic Shonen fashion the hero is told
that their most powerful technique is
too risky to use which means he will
definitely use this move and it is going
to be awesome when he eventually uses it
and so now with Sasuke and Naruto's team
formed and their targets set it's time
to start this Chase and what better way
than with one of the most surprisingly
brilliant fights I've enjoyed in this
series deara versus Sasuke this fight
totally took me by surprise grabbed my
attention and never let go to tell you
the truth I enjoyed darara as a
character in the past but I never really
connected to them until this fight where
the full scope of sas's power can be
observed and where the unbridled
creativity of darara can change the tide
of a given Conflict at a moment's notice
and this is a quick aside this fight is
split between two volumes and the only
reason I mentioned this is because
volume 40 has the best cover art I've
seen from Kishimoto to date hands down
no contest there's such a wonderful
sense of kinetic energy to its line art
which is fitting because this fight is
the exact same though when reading the
manga variation of this fight what I
appreciated the most was the borderline
absurd level of near Miss's fake outs
and swerves with more twists and turns
than a curly fry as often is the case
with these substantial fights we receive
the backstory and some new information
concerning deara we learn a little bit
more about his motivations and oddly
enough it turns out that this fight has
a bit more weight to it now with these
two combatants yearning to surpass the
same person Itachi furthermore and I
feel this is worth saying at this time
when I sit down to digest these volumes
of manga I do so while taking notes for
my script notes where I expand upon an
impression I'm getting or perhaps jot
down a few useful talking points or
ideas for the video I try to be as
eloquent as I can in order to
effectively convey the emotion or
technique at play in the story for
myself later but when deara used his
best move on Sasuke this is what my
notes were data's disintegrated
Sasuke no seriously my script actually
says Ah and also this sentence
explaining but back to the fight it
appears that in order to survive that
attack Sasuke used the shingan to see
the attack coming and Dodge he
blindsides deara but wait deara is
playing 40 chess and boom literally
Sasuke does reverse the situation again
for the second time but they changed
this one up and tied it back to the
beginning of the fight while also adding
the types chart into the mix which was
explored and introduced in the previous
section of the story his Chidori was
favorable against dear's style of Jutsu
and he knew it from the start but deara
still had one last trick up his
sleeve this fight was honestly full of
ups and downs twists and turns
interesting reveals and call backs to
previously established techniques that
made perfect sense for the time and the
way this fight ends creates the best
outcome for both deara and Sasuke darara
puts some respect on his name in the
eyes of everyone including us the
audience not just by how creative he was
in his application of this incredible
power but also because of what Sasuke
did in response to this attack to
protect himself summoning orochimaru's
giant snake to sacrifice and ultimately
protect himself against the oncoming
nuke in other words Sasuke appeared
level-headed and Incredibly resourceful
all the while deara despite losing
Unleashed one of if not the most
powerful attack we've yet seen in this
series I adored this fight it's next
level
great
uh holy okay uh so cards on the
table I knew about this character before
I started reading or really I should say
I knew what he looked like but
apparently I knew less than I
anticipated because I honestly thought
that this was just some weird power up
for Naruto similar to Sasuke's one but
apparently he's just some new character
called pain I feel incredibly dumb right
now there's a wonderfully heartfelt
parting conversation between jeriah and
tady right here and while he never
explicitly says anything Toady about him
going on a mission with a low success
rate he knows that this is an important
thing for him to do not just as a high
ranking and skilled Shinobi but also as
a mentor to the Next Generation Upon
finishing this Arc this was a scene that
stood out to me as particularly
attention grabbing he wanted a chance to
have a drink with her and told her how
he respected her there was a specific
focus on his most wonderful qualities
with a sense of I don't know Melancholy
hanging in the air despite Tsunade
saying that he is to return regardless
once I reached the end of this Arc with
Sasuke standing face to face with Itachi
I felt a very uneasy feeling for the
future of jeriah as he arrived at the
location of pain tale of jeriah the
Gallant as the title of this Arc might
give away this is indeed the tale of
jeriah the gall you don't say as such
despite there being some developments
for the likes of Sasuke and Naruto
respectively while I will mention those
characters briefly I do want to focus my
attention on this incredible story
surrounding jah's attempt to gain Intel
on the akatski and the nature of an
individual called pain following some
light interrogation we catch up with the
likes of jeriah as he arrives on the
shores of this rain Village we learned
some backstory concerning pain he is
apparently the reason why the rain
Village is so successfully closed off
from everywhere pay defeated Hanzo the
man who named Jah as well as tunar and
Orochimaru the three great Shinobi of
Canoa he coined that term and in
addition to killing him pay also killed
his family and everyone who knew him and
all of this is coming from the mouths of
the people and to be honest he sounds
like more of a legend than an actual
person a god a force of Nature and more
on that in just a
sec the fight that ensues in this Arc is
different and I mean that in a good way
while there's action of a unique variety
particularly with regards to jiah and
what he brings to the table there's
something more Grand and prophetic about
this occasion it's less about the action
and more about the mystery as well as
the internal story of jodah as he fights
against increasingly insurmountable odds
with perhaps the first clue concerning
his thoughts on the future on the island
coming by way of this gesture lending
the key that unlocks Naruto's full
ninetail Fox Spirit to a messenger to
deliver to Naruto
himself nagato Konan and yahiko were all
children knew that were orphan by the
war of the time but Jah decided to
Mentor them however now that they seem
to be Associates of pain and what it's a
rather on the- noos metaphor the three
of them have effectively embraced and
focused on their pain rather than the
good that they can do for the world and
one to instead enact their Revenge to
make the world feel the same pain that
they were forced to feel and pain is a
word that is thrown around a ton in this
Arc and it's quite obvious that it's
trying to draw a connection between the
pain character and and the Very concept
of pain with what it represents to these
children nagato wants to give Every
Nation the power to destroy each other
so that they can all know pain but what
I love about this is what jiah offers as
advice and mentorship to these young
talented and brave children instead of
focusing on how the pain is manifesting
he points out to them that those that
have gone through pain can understand it
better than anyone that they have the
capacity to feel compassion on a greater
level than anyone without that
perspective or experience
and I just thought that that was such a
wonderful way of thinking about this
particular scenario the battle with
nagato or who Jah perceives as Nago
seems interesting but more so we see
Nago split up into three individuals
that represent pain the fight is
interesting told from jiah's point of
view which AIDS in the climax and
interspliced in this fight are a series
of flashbacks and one such flashback is
called back to once the three are taken
down and a surprise fourth person shows
up only two
what was once three has now turned into
six opponents one being the pain
character himself that I recognized
apparently ahiko was said to have died
but I guess that's a metaphorical death
considering he's here too question mark
and upon closer inspection nagato
doesn't look to be among them after all
though his eyes seem to be dawned by
everyone what is happening here back
with the likes of Sask and Co once they
arrive at the location to meet Itachi
Kisame is waiting for them apparently
only Sasuke is allowed to pass and speak
to his brother but not much else happens
here for me to give my full opinion on
just yet considering this Arc is
primarily centering around jiah and his
current struggle he discovers that the
folks he's fighting are all faces from
his past perhaps signifying his failure
standing right before him and now with
it being six on
one jah's reflection at the end of this
section is perhaps the most poetic and
beautiful section of this sprawling
sprawling story he spoke earlier in this
tale with Tsunade and I knew given the
nature of his musings it would bear some
relevance to this instance in that
section he says rejection makes me
stronger The Pursuit of Happiness isn't
for us in that scene he speaks with a
very tongue and cheek flare however it
really speaks to the tragedy he sees as
his life story as Shinobi's life is not
measured by how they lived but by what
they managed to accomplish before their
death and in reflecting on that very
principle he clearly holds dearly during
this short flashback jiah is haunted by
the failings that he thinks defined his
life until matato Cuts him off and
instead Praises his self-insert
character's work it's a book that he's
reading sort of like an autobiography of
his life with a renamed character it
makes one Wonder more about his decision
not to accept the position of hok since
he truly feels so ashamed of what he's
done throughout his life he probably
thought he would fail in that effort too
in becoming Hokage but the message
matato takes from this isn't that of his
failings but his tenacity so much so
it's inspired him to name his son after
the lead character of This Book of
[Music]
his this single turn of the page
revealing the origin of Naruto's name
sick had me fighting back tears and for
me this has been the most powerful and
emotional moment so far it's not even
close executed to near Perfection
discovering in his final moments that
his real selection all this time was
whether or not he would choose to fight
one last time to select Naruto to carry
on long after he's gone jiah was once
told as a child by the great Elder that
he would have a disciple that would
change the world potentially for good
and potentially for bad it depends on a
choice and in this instance Judah once
again rallies himself after falling in
order to try once again and in doing so
imparts a crucial message for Naruto as
to the identity of who pain really is
and as if like poetry as Naruto falls to
the ground in battle and jediah Fades
into the ocean declaring that his next
story should be called uzamaki Naruto
Naruto rises from the surface below
ready to carry on his master's will this
story was stunningly
depicted The Faded battle between
Brothers the vast majority of this
section or Arc of the story centers
around the Brewing or should I say
impending conflict between Sasuke and
the brother his wished was dead since
that faithful day in many ways this Arc
acts as a culmination of Sasuke's
Journey or at the very least a pivotal
or immeasurably important turning point
in the young character's life I found it
interesting how the fight between a Ai
and Sasuke begins with Close Quarters
combat using a variety of weapons and
Blades with all the sign weaving in the
fights leading up to now it not only
gives it a sense of identity but also a
much more grounded honest and personal
quality lending all the more weight and
frankly to my surprise
when yeah it's it's not him just like
all those times in the past atachi seems
to be one step ahead of Sasuke and
anyone else really this Close Quarters
intimate and earnest Affair seems to be
nothing more than an illusion of an
honest contest for
itach okay you got to stop doing that
all right I love this small exchange as
it works wonderfully from an audience's
perspective We Begin this chapter
expecting to deal with the contest
between these two but instead it acts as
the stage for a series of Illusions both
of which managed to work effectively on
me the conversation that takes place
past this point felt at least for me a
little more for exposition than it did
for character growth or Revelation
necessarily having come all this way
after seeing so many spectacular battles
it doesn't seem like the fight is in any
rush to meet its resolution and I like
that it's interesting for sure getting
to see Sasuke finally confront his older
brother but in retrospect the entire
Affair felt very detached from reality
both literally and figuratively some
information was divulged concerning the
character of uchia madada who too
possesses the mang Kio and in fact was
the first one to achieve such but I
think the most interesting part of this
conversation and indeed conflict comes
by way of a certain Revelation the mango
is a formidable weapon of ocular ability
that affords the wielder a number of
strengths otherwise not afforded to his
standard shingan user however when
madada first possessed it he noticed
that there was a major drawback to it
that the more he used it the more he
lost his ability to see which would be
for a ninja less than optimal in despair
Madara learned something vital it was
that if he took his brother's eyes not
only would he see the light return to
his vision but he would retain mangekyo
for forever more this for me at the time
explained the sudden shift in how Itachi
treated him growing up while he felt
like a good brother from time to time he
was simply working in his own
self-interest he wanted Sasuke to stay
alive as a host for his future eyes and
honestly this is an interesting angle to
take this plot line down it clears up a
ton with regards the mystery concerning
Itachi and while it takes away a lot of
his Mystique it replaces it with a whole
other brand of murderous power driven
Insanity which as Sasuke finds out is
terrifying on a whole other level but
this time it seems Sasuke is
significantly more skilled with the
sharing Gan than Itachi is with the
mango ice and so I guess it's round two
the fight itself turned out to be a lot
more competitive than I was anticipating
now naturally I wasn't aware of the
direction this fight would take and
where things would go from here but once
Itachi revealed his hand I figured some
sort of resolution would be met at this
point and the visuals are stunning in
the manga I particularly like the amate
rasu technique or I guess the black
Flames that engulf Sasuke as he
overpowers Itachi's fire efforts forcing
Itachi to dodge as the fire blast surges
into the sky above and once again like
most of the fights in this series
there's always an underlying strategy at
play and with the vision of Itachi
waning and the chakra of Sasuke at its
limit something comes to the attention
of Itachi it turns out all of the fire
Sasuke sent flying into the air wasn't
for nothing but in fact carefully
calculated creating for him an
electrical Cloud producing more energy
than anything he could conjure up on his
own and what a strike this one takes
traveling at 1 1,000th of a second with
enough punch to shake a continent and
it's at this point I think back to the
kid I first met towards the beginning of
the story and how far this festering
hatred and desire for Revenge has
brought him gifting him control over the
very heavens themselves it's a stunning
Display of Power greater than anything
I've seen once again however that's not
how this fight ends
revealing to all of us that he has had
this trump card still up his sleeve
cornered and feeling like he's out of
option Sasuke is confronted by the very
same sentence that this Arc and video
started with uttered by Orochimaru so
long as you have mercy you can't best
Itachi it can be seen throughout
Sasuke's action in the material covered
since those words were uttered that he
has indeed shown Mercy in almost every
confrontation along the path to his
brother even to those trying to kill him
and stunningly even Itachi to some
extent and in being faced with these
worsening circumstances Itachi unleashes
some monstrous attack Sasuke's chakra
Fades weaker and weaker until Orochimaru
erupts forth from the depths of his
person forced to relinquish the very
Humanity that made him who he was
despite him not necessarily being in
control of this move he did make the
choice to enview himself with
orochimaru's spirit in the first place
all with hatred driving him as a
motivator I don't think think it's a
coincidence that sandwich between this
pursuit of Itachi and this fated battle
between Brothers is a tale effectively
describing the life and virtue of a
mentor that consistently tried to do the
right thing in the face of constant
failure who found solace and
significance not in the goals he
achieved but the desire he consistently
and earnestly expressed in doing his
best who told children who had endured
so much pain in their lives to use it
not as a vehicle for more suffering but
to use it as a motivator to emphasize
and to prevent that suffering for others
throughout these arcs Sasuke having
known what it's like to lose those
important to him has carried with him a
dedication to not take a life if he can
help it because he more than perhaps
anyone else he knows understands what
sort of impact and sense of Sorrow that
can bring into their family and he
didn't want that for others however now
in this fight with Itachi he's willing
to throw all of that out the window he's
willing to let go of that sight of
himself if it means he gets what he
wants in other words he too was
embracing pain and when Itachi takes out
Orochimaru with relative ease he starts
to show very visible signs of serious
injury and fatigue coughing up blood
crying blood the battle rages on until
both are barely standing Sasuke throwing
everything he has at him until he too
has nothing left and staggering towards
him in a bloody stuper is Itachi
extending his trembling hand to take
what he considers his own sas's eyes
later on in this Arc we get formly
introduced to a character called madada
he takes Sasuke under his wing and in
doing so fills him in on some key
details concerning his now deceased
brother when Itachi was very young
through his exposure to pain and
suffering in war learned to be a gentle
and peaceloving person which again
speaks to the jiah teachings concerning
pain and empathy for that pain once
experienced and in this description
Itachi is kind of the opposite of mad in
this situation where mad killed his
brother for the benefit of his own Clan
Itachi sacrificed his own clan for the
betterment of the whiter Community with
it being the case in the end he cared
more for his brother than the broader
community of people even in his dying
moments Itachi wasn't trying to get his
eyes he was trying to give him his
ocular powers to protect him and shortly
following this Revelation for Sasuke
Naruto starts to show up in the story
once again having come to learn that his
fraternal brother Sasuke had in fact
achieved what he set out to do in his
last interaction with Itachi before he
teleported to Sasuke's battle Itachi
presents Naruto a dilemma to contend
with knowing what we do about Itachi's
backstory we can appreciate the Clear
Connection being drawn between what
choices he was left with and ultimately
made when he was young however Naruto
effectively responds by saying that when
faced with a tough decision wife with
compromise he'd make both outcomes
positive he wouldn't kill Sasuke to save
his village or vice versa he'd save his
village and he'd save Sasuke there is no
compromise with Naruto for him a life
where he has to compromise isn't a life
he thinks is worth living so he'd rather
die trying to get get that perfect
outcome rather than live with a
compromise hanging over him for the rest
of his life and I think in a sort of
childish idealistic sort of way there's
a purity and sweetness to that sentiment
that's just quite refreshing and I think
Itachi thought so too I think this is a
really important quote towards the end
of the story and someday when you have
the same eyes as I you will find me
again I think this line is my favorite
from all of the reflection panels we
receive from Sasuke because to be honest
in the moment I never took notice of
that phrase of the sentence but knowing
what I know now it's clear to me that he
meant if Sasuke can learn to understand
his decisions and empathize to see the
world as he saw us that he will be able
to see him as his brother once more a
lesson that while incredibly simple
offers Sasuke the means with which to
look at the world the very same
wayed now I seeing testing
me
away
last time I covered the Itachi story
line which came to a shocking and
Brilliant climax that story had focused
a tremendous amount in the dynamic
between Sasuke and his brother and with
good reason it needed the space to tell
that story and to be honest the
beginning of this next Arc suffers from
that decision slightly only slightly
however and I'll get into that in a
second firstly however I'd like to
unpack jah's death and why I love the
way it was handled and also to share
some thoughts I had concerning a
particular decision I found uh
first The Good the scene showcasing
tsuna and Naruto discovering jiah's fate
and their grieving respectively with the
news were appropriately tragic yet
beautiful when Kishimoto dedicates time
to quietly exploring a character's more
vulnerable sides I genuinely think he
really shines as a mangaka furthermore I
really like the idea of leaving behind a
riddle or Cipher for Naruto that
requires solving which in this
particular Arc acted as a very natural
means for Shikamaru to reach out to
Naruto personally for help in solving
this Cipher revealing a conversation
that speaks to the responsibilities of
growing up that they both need to face
Shonen as a genre is always dealing with
and concerning itself with children
coming of age but there isn't normally a
dedication to what one should do once
those years are over and where they need
to find fulfillment in that part of
their lives having turned 30 recently I
found myself resonating with that
message a lot that drive to Mentor the
Next Generation to be the ones who buy
the ramen rather than being the
snot-nosed little kids as he calls it in
other words it's time to grow up and to
stop sulking we need more stories to
glorify these more mature parts of our
Lives as I think there's somewhat of a
stigma for people that once you get over
a certain age that it's all downhill
from there when in actuality it's all
about perspective but hey what do I know
I'm just an old man anyways those were
all my favorite parts of the ending that
really spoke to me there was however one
aspect to it that while a technical
issue still didn't really feel
convincing to me as I mentioned I really
like the idea of having to figure out
how to decipher this Cipher it's a nice
mystery to keep us entertained while we
deal with the emotional outpouring on
behalf of jiah however when it came to
deciphering that code my first thought
when I thought was oh those numbers must
refer to page numbers in his make out
series of books right but then my second
thought was no that's dumb there's no
way an author would have a comprehensive
knowledge of the exact words that begin
each and every page in his novel off the
top of his head in the heat of battle if
he got one thing wrong then it wouldn't
have worked at all and okay look I know
this might sound unreasonable but look
let's take for example this script I'm
running right now or better yet the
attack on Titan script I wrote earlier
last year that monster was over 60 pages
and bear in mind still not as long as
his novels and I worked on it for months
despite however it being shorter and
therefore easier to remember than those
pages from his book series I couldn't
tell you what the first word on the
first page of that script is heck I
couldn't even tell you what the first
word of this script is and I wrote that
yesterday with that said however it it
is a cute idea and I like how Naruto
provides the Insight necessary for them
to solve the code wherein jiah explains
that the warning control is not among
the group in pain all right time for
Naruto sage
[Music]
training as I've said numerous times
before I'm a massive fan of training
arcs I think they add a lovely bit of
variety in a story to break up the
constant talking and fighting while
continuously feeding into the themes of
the greater narrative this part is no
different and what I did notice during
this one was once again despite Naruto
and Sasuke's paths having diverged in a
very significant way earlier in time
their core story beats are still in sync
together somewhat take for example the
last two arcs both Sasuke and Naruto
have lost people profoundly important to
them on a fundamental level in
diametrically opposed ways that both
have led the young pupils to receive
significant enhancements to their prior
abilities thanks to their loved ones
passing both of which they would in a
heartbeat return to life in exchange for
those newly acquired Powers we've
explored SAS predict already in the last
video so this Arc in turn shifts the
focus to Naruto once again as we follow
his tutelage under the toad hermit in
terms of mechanical differences once
again I'm a massive fan of what this new
ability means for Naruto moving forward
and I love how Naruto's pre-existing
abilities allow him to advance quickly
in this complex crash course in senjutsu
this idea of being able to derive power
from nature and the world around him is
so cool and the means with which Naruto
later learns to apply this technique in
ways never before seen by even his
Master speaks to both the past of this
series and indeed Naruto as a character
himself someone that's capable of
inventing an option C when someone gives
him two options he doesn't agree with
this is a sign of a naive mindset
working in a positive fashion I think
which again works in great contrast to
what Sasuke ends up doing towards the
beginning of this Arc I believe
following his acquisition of the aale
spirit and the use of the Newfound power
courtesy of his brother Sasuke explains
to his fellow uchia and akatski member
why he can be trusted in doing what's in
line with the akatski mission and to go
against his brother's wishes of
protecting kenoa and to be honest it
reads is pretty Juvenile and overly
simplistic considering everything he's
been through almost to an unbelievable
extent I understand his motivations and
his reasoning on a technical level but
at this point he should realize that
things are often more complicated than
they might appear to be that was the
entire point of his misunderstanding
with his brother and while he might
believe that he more than likely does
have a greater handle on the reality of
the current circumstances the fact that
he's moving forward with this line of
thinking without any hesitation just
proves that he still has so much more to
learn which will be entertaining once
Naruto and he inevitably Clash down the
line and look okay I know you're waiting
for me to talk about the big big fight
that's coming up but one small thing
first speaking more broadly for a second
about this arc's pacing there's a lot of
bouncing around to different points of
view early in this Arc we get Naruto's
Sage training which I like sas's
acquisition of the eight tale Spirit his
conversation with the akatski members
following that that dude's Community
trying to track down the tail spirit in
him those same folks making a plan to
Stage a summit tsunan trying to figure
out jah's message and we also have
Pain's attack on kenoa and while I can
appreciate that these are all necessary
points of view and do serve the story in
fact I just didn't find most of them
very interesting at all once here I
think when it comes to what this Arc
contains and what the Last Arc contains
that being two massive battles it's
natural to have all the exposition and
busy work taken care of between the more
hype moments to allow space for them to
breathe and the bigger the battles the
more Exposition that needs to be
squeezed in in between and unfortunately
this is that case which is reasonable it
just so happens that this section
unfortunately is sandwiched between the
two biggest battles in the story so far
and I think the pacing suffered quite a
lot during these early chapters as a
result was it boring kind of was it
worth what we got after this oh my God
[Music]
yes pain versus kenoa pay's invasion of
kenoa gakure is the opening act of what
ends up being one of the biggest and
best fights in this series so far and
maybe because I'm a big fan of Naruto as
a character but I sincerely enjoy this
more than Sasuke versus Itachi and I
loved that fight but perhaps it's not a
fair comparison because this one had so
many different people fighting to hold
the line waiting for Naruto to finish
his training and to save the day there
are tons of moving Parts in this one
kicking things off with different
battles held across the greater Village
area the use of strategy and the
implement ation and acquisition of new
information turns all of these fights on
their respective heads with each
individual understanding that each
encounter could be their last against
these monsters and that if they are
going to lose their lives here they may
as well do so while gaining precious
Intel to help enhance The Village's
chances of survival and this
unfortunately applies to everyone from
Konohamaru all the way to the great
Kakashi the quick exchange between pain
and Kakashi once again despite n Naruto
and Sasuke having steamrolled ahead in
terms of ability highlights the fact
that Kakashi is still managing to remain
a remarkably resourceful and focused
Warrior for konoha utilizing brilliant
strategy through very convincing clones
to drag out more Intel from the
situation regarding pain for the use of
others in this battle furthermore these
more Desperate Measures serve to act as
a tremendously effective means of
building tension I mean even Kakashi is
pulling out all the stops and he's
struggling but as I mentioned there are
a host of different battles taking place
all over the village with a real sense
of dread and hopelessness hanging in the
air particularly when chosa is thought
to be dead and Kakashi sacrifices his
own safety in order to allow choji to
relay that message that Intel they
gathered back to Tsunade and once he got
there Tsunade could sense Cho's energy
but no one else's it's at this point
Kishimoto once again leans on his
wonderful sensibilities with regards
these more emotional or sentimental
moments seldom as they are when they do
show up they really hit their Mark
having having grown up being treated as
though he was an outsider despite pain
demanding to know the location of Naruto
despite him threatening everyone's lives
the people of Canoa won't sell out
Naruto as we're reminded of all he's
achieved Through The Eyes of Cano's
citizens it's a brilliant lens for which
to view this part of the battle through
seeing what Naruto means to them and how
far this story has progressed as a
result speaking of progression
let all right I got to say that was
really sick and getting to see this kid
now having grown up some once again
speaks to the fostering of this new
generation Shikamaru touched on earlier
as well Naruto gave this kid some of his
time and guidance and now he's capable
of Performing Feats such as this the
renen is a crazy powerful move
to pull out as a surprise attack all
right but okay Switching gears for a
second and checking in with Naruto he's
after encountering a small teeny tiny
problem due to the fox Spirit unlike
like jiah the Toads can't rest on his
shoulders to facilitate this technique's
charge time which means now Naruto is
faced with a specific problem unique to
him without someone on his shoulder to
focus that energy on his behalf he now
needs to figure out a way of staying
still in combat in order to focus on
Gathering that energy without getting
killed by pain easier said than done
right and okay somewhat troublingly pain
eventually finds out where Naruto is
after which the unthinkable happens
Naruto versus Pain chaos rigning from
above the entire Village destroyed and
even suady in way over her head trying
to protect as many people as she can
from the onslaught as the dust clouds
fade there Naruto stands ready to lay
down his life for all of those that
afforded him the time to prepare with
theirs the there's a wonderfully tragic
but exciting moment that shows itself as
the ignition for this fight specifically
now that Naruto has mastered this
natural chakra business he can sense
everyone's energy but not Kakashi's he
calmly asks if he's on a mission
elsewhere and it's all to no response he
knows his fate a younger weaker and more
naive Naruto would have in this instance
exploded in Anger throwing caution to
the wind as well as his strategy
practically assuring his defeat and
securing everyone else's downfall but
it's different now he's grown up as we
saw through the eyes of the villagers
earlier Naruto is no longer a child and
it's time for him to prove that in the
grandest of ways and in doing so setting
an example for the Next Generation
choosing to carefully Channel his anger
into attacking the pain gang and boy
does he do just that the opening Gambit
of this conflict is honestly brilliant
and full of just the right amount of
determination motivation and strategy
everything I love in a good Naruto fight
we know what what Naruto is fighting for
we know how far he's come we are
currently learning all the strengths and
weaknesses of the Pain Group and
Naruto's strategy once again is
something only he can manage to pull off
thanks to his seemingly bottomless
supply of chakra leaving Shadow clones
behind him to charge away elsewhere as
batteries for the sage energy it's a
remarkably good strategy turning a
weakness into a strength a very Naruto
thing to do and the best part of this
entire opening to this fight is that the
guy who has been stealing all the Gin
shariki power from all the folks in the
Pain Group manages to get a hold of
Naruto himself this would normally be a
catastrophic failure on Naruto's part
and while it was a mistake like always
Naruto finds a way of turning something
negative into a positive because Naruto
needed to be still in order to gather
that Sage Jutsu that wasn't a viable
strategy for approaching this battle he
would have been open to attack however
in that hold with this guy he can do
just that stay still which then LED to
that pain guy absorbing too much Sage
Jutsu thus turning him into a frog
creature because he can't control it
that was such a creative and
cool moment with a decent depth of cause
and effect and while it's still fresh in
my mind at this moment in time it is my
favorite Switcheroo in the
[Music]
story finally it comes to light exactly
what is happening with regards the pain
puppet and who the Puppeteer is I
thought it was really cool to finally
get a chance to see Nago since we
haven't really seen since the flashbacks
with jiah though he looks like now
I like the Thematic significance of his
mission through pain nagato explains to
Naruto his vision for the world and in
the process really puts a bunch of
conflict into Naruto's Mind through pain
both literally and metaphorically nagato
is showing the world what his vision for
the future is and what Justice he wants
to
[Music]
bring and without Nar willing to make a
move Hinata jumps in confesses her
respect and love for
Naruto stop he's already dead and gets
taken
[Music]
out oh my God he's got bones on him this
looks kind of awkward but surprisingly
cool I didn't think it would look cool
but it actually does in execution with
the body of the fox building itself
around Naruto as the tal Sprout it's a
really cool visual indication of
progression towards a known endpoint
which I would imagine is the fully
realized Fox spirit in its physical form
but okay we finally gotten to the moment
that you've all been waiting
for the meme fight okay I'm going to
switch on my camera for this bit I'll be
talking a a lot about animation and I'm
not trusting Japan's copyright laws at
this moment in time let it be known that
in preparation for this section of the
video I have read the Manga and viewed
the corresponding episodes of the anime
that this controversial piece of
Animation has stemmed from I recognize
that I will be attempting to give my
personal opinion on a subjective but
widely discussed topic on the internet
but I guess I'm a Maverick like that
with that said I will try to ground my
reasoning in terms as uncontroversial as
I can and I will do so by trying to
answer the question is this a good
depiction of this fight there are of
course those of you out there that think
obviously no and obviously yes to that
answer so let's take a closer look for
me what makes a fight seem great is
multifaceted story animation artwork and
yes those are two separate things pacing
immersiveness and overall storyboarding
or direction of a scene and
interestingly the animation plays a role
in all of these aspects when it comes to
animation quality I think it's a
massively impressive Showcase of an
animator's skills in that department the
animator in question here that worked on
this scene was shinga Yamashita and odar
you've seen his work before in the past
and not just from this scene in fact
he's since gone on to direct and
composite for other anime I mean he has
been incredibly successful with the
openings of Jiu-Jitsu Kaizen but that's
Jiu-Jitsu Kaizen that's not Naruto and
this has become a beast into an of
itself I had seen this clip of animation
and I knew people didn't like it however
it is important to keep in mind when I
say animation that I am not referring to
the piece's likeness to the characters
animation is the illusion of movement
and to varing degrees different series
have iconic examples of this and
examples of tragically poor animation
also sometimes in the biggest of
properties in Japan one of my favorite
animators that worked on drag super back
in the day was a man by the name of Nai
Tate hello
there he too was a controversial artist
because some people loved him and others
hated him and once again it boiled down
entirely to what one as an audience
member was looking for if they were
looking for crazy Dynamic animation then
Tate was their guy if they were looking
for model sheet accuracy then he wasn't
and this fight here with pain seems to
tell the very same story both in an even
more exaggerated fashion the gestures
the smears the squash and stretch is all
there in aggressive effect and as a
result the scene is filled with a ton of
energy it's exciting it's Dynamic it's
energetic it feels alive and moreover
for the most part not too dissimilar to
other big action episodes with in this
series of Naruto however with that said
let's take a look at the other side of
this coin character likeness and its
importance I am a big fan of Saka or
high quality animation from Japan I'm
interested in the subject and I like
studying it a little more closely than
the average bear and taking that into
consideration if someone values
character a consistency more than
animation and movement then that's not
only perfectly reasonable it's probably
how most people feel too and with good
reason the purpose of Animation is to
enhance the story that's being told
through it and one important way of
achieving that desired effect is by
suspending the audience's disbelief for
them to get invested in the characters
and forget that they're watching
animation however I believe one could
very easily make the argument that if
any animation takes someone out of the
story and the story is what you're there
for then to those people that animation
would have failed in living up to its
purpose in other words if in this fight
with pain you found it distracting to
the point of it taking you out of the
story or fight that was taking place
then that animation despite it being
intentionally exaggerated and
technically impressive fails to serve
the primary purpose of animation for
that person which is to tell the story
in a dramatic fashion in keeping with
the tone of the manga but okay I've
explained why I think some people like
it and why some people hate it but what
do I think well it's complicated when it
came to this approach I think there's a
tremendous amount of Talent on display
when it comes to conveying movement and
a sense of energy the timing is really
nice and all that jazz and I'm also a
fan of simple shapes in order to
facilitate movement so from a
philosophical standpoint I appreciate
the approach taken however the moments
or moment that people seem to take issue
with even I have to admit feels like
they are pushing the envelope far too
far when it comes to some of the
exaggerations again this isn't evident
of poor animation quality certainly not
as I believe the animation to be quite
brilliant here it is however I think a
result either of not enough time
reserved for Corrections or perhaps not
the right direction for that scene at
least I think so while as I mentioned
that I appreciate the philosophies
behind the approach taken I think it
veered too far into Looney Tune
territory when it came to some of the
choices made which ultimately took me
completely out of the moment that these
scenes were trying to deliver for so in
short I think the artist that worked on
this was incredibly talented and I think
that the vast majority was perfectly
within the Realms of what the show had
produced before but I do however think
that the vision shinjo Yamashita had for
part of this final product was perhaps
too far outside of what many of us
including me consider to be within the
boundaries of reasonable artistic
license when I saw this I wasn't
thinking about how awesome the fight was
I wasn't thinking about the story I was
instead thinking about the animation and
how I felt that it didn't match the
show's overall approach which distracted
me from my primary reason for watching
anime the story but that's just my take
let me know what you think in the
comment section down below personally I
think there's a happy medium to be found
here that would please more people than
this ultimately did without alienating
the sakuga fans take Nate's best moments
from drag super these are perfect
examples of this sort of loose
minimalistic animation being corrected
to accommodate for both stylistic
consistency as well as a tremendous
energy in animation and so I think if
Yamashita had some of his Cuts corrected
for model correctness it wouldn't have
created as big of a storm as it did
otherwise online but that's just my two
cents also I think I'll probably keep up
the face cam for the rest of this video
cuz Lord knows I am recording this
review way too late and my editor is
tired I'll probably be doing more face
cam in the future too to help distance
myself from the material that has in the
past nuked my channel speaking broadly
about the fight for a second I thought
the action was bombastic and the
contrast between how the fox fights
versus how Naruto fights is
appropriately Stark it helps to
reinforce the dedication to strategy and
technique Naruto the person is and how
inconsiderate the fox is to the village
and world around him interested only in
destroying what stands in opposition to
him which as it happens helps to elevate
one of the most surprising scenes I've
yet come
across for the last two volumes this
story has built up to one gigantic
climax within this fight and
interestingly Kishimoto subverts this
expectation through this scene Naruto's
first meeting with his father the fourth
Hokage and as I'm sure many of you are
aware at this point I've never been a
massive fan of fight scenes unless they
have compelling ties to the narrative by
way of mystery or whatever but I am and
always have been a massive fan of quiet
introspective moments full of character
Rich dialogue and that's exactly what
this is during this encounter the fourth
oag is collected compassionate and wise
while Naruto is reasonably upset and
elated at what he's learned he
physically lashes out at his father
before basking momentarily in the fact
that he's the fourth hokage's son which
is again such a Naruto thing to do
particularly during a time where he's
made to feel confused and uncertain
thanks to pain he feels like a child
there's a neat conversation about the
philosophy surrounding what Naruto is
struggling with what pain has taught him
his motivations were and in response to
that the fourth okag explains that where
there's love there will be hate and the
duty of the Shinobi is to fight the
hatred before it turns into pain and
suffering the fourth tells Naruto that
he doesn't know the answer to his
problems but believes that Naruto will
find the answer himself before sealing
away the fox spirit and leaving Naruto
to return to the battle the words of
encouragement echoing in his ears from
Kakashi jeriah and now his father he
stands once more to the challenge that
pain presents him that nagato presents
him once again there are some great
visuals where the benefits of the sage
technique even when not in use become
apparent thanks to that chakra being
used in place of his own natural Supply
Naruto's clones explode onto the page in
a beautiful spread which again reminds
me of the stories beginning when he
first used that technique setting
himself up for the renen what a
brilliant move the climax to this
conflict is instead of action a
conversation a philosophical
conversation wherein Naruto expresses a
desire Nago explains his pain and Naruto
shows his maturity again something I
need to make clear is that my videos
aren't a substitute for the original
material so I won't be explaining
exactly what said but instead giving my
Impressions on it but I think right from
the beginning when Naruto expresses that
he did not see his defeat of pain as a
victory I thought again that this is
another wonderful step towards the theme
of maturity for Naruto but the story
also never shied away from the ugliness
of hatred he can't just ignore that
nagato killed jariah and Kakashi but his
memory of his master's parting lesson
can stop him from continuing this cycle
of violence reinforcing that it is a
choice that you can choose not to hurt
people to not cause more
[Music]
pain nagato's backstory was interesting
but a line that stood out to me was this
I will rule this world and make the
suffering stop this is a very naive and
overly simplistic view of how the world
should be under him Naruto's journey in
this Arc has been about him accepting
his role in becoming an adult needing to
learn patience and to think things
through and to prepare the world for the
next generation and in a way that's
exactly what nagato wants to do too
however with a lot more purposeful
suffering jeriah is quoted as saying a
person matures grows up when you
experience pain and as I'm sure you've
noticed this is a perfect continuation
to the themes of growing up and maturity
at play here too for Naruto the
situations regarding nagato and his
issues surrounding the illusion of Peace
for these larger Nations following times
of Bloodshed is a really interesting
perspective and a tragically honest
experience he and many others have
shared and Naruto doesn't necessarily
have any solution for it other then that
he won't give up and he will find a
solution to this problem admitting that
he still hates him but understands why
he is the way that he is and most
importantly decides not to hurt him
Naruto asks for Nago to believe that he
won't Harden with pain to believe that
he won't grow resentful or vengeful that
he will earnestly seek out peace in the
name of his master and for the good of
the world where nagato's pain pushed him
to embrace a negative path Naruto's
helped him to embrace a positive one
with this conversation speaking to
jiah's lesson too Nago Naruto has every
reason to hate and despise Nago for
everything that he's done however after
hearing his story Naruto can use his own
life experiences his own pain to
empathize and sympathize with Nago much
the same way he did with gar during the
tunin exams thus avoiding conflict
Naruto's pain was a source of peace in
this instant this manages to reach
nagato and while this ending might feel
much like nagato's thoughts on the
matter a little overly simplistic as a
set of lessons to live by I think
there's some great stuff here that's all
rooted in Naruto as he exists as a
character I'm not sure I'm a massive fan
of the resurrecting of Shinobi and
people who died during the battle as it
does remove a lot of the consequences
and Fallout from this Ark but is it
worth it for when Naruto arrives back a
kenoa to a hero's welcome I think
absolutely the Lonely Boy that once
sought after recognition and
acknowledgement is now the hero of his
village a beloved member of the society
who is now armed with A New Perspective
for which to better understand Sasuke
who he seems to be destined to collide
with very
soon
[Music]
but in the events of the pain assault
Canoa is uniquely weakened with the
likes of even lady tady the fifth Hokage
in a K State resulting in danzo the
prick who brainwashed Sai and has been
slithering around in the background for
a while now becoming the sixth okag in
her absence I can smell conflict Brewing
already in order to decide what to do
about the akatski members in the loose a
summon of all five KAG is held and prior
to leaving for this Gathering down O's
first rule is to effectively authorize
the killing of Sasuke overturning
tsunade's rule entirely this was a great
start to the story I found it sets up
the building blocks to be knocked down
so to speak following the pain assault
Arc while we still have this nebulous
overarching goal of regrouping with
Sasuke in order to convince him to come
back to the Village without a concrete
plan of how best to do that it remains a
less immediate concern in the Forefront
of what I would assume is a great many
readers despite it being the main
motivation for Naruto himself with that
said however the combination of this
over overing motivation and the addition
of a new Hokage in danzo creates a
unique pressure to be applied to this
desire from Naruto for SAS not to
mention conflict with the akatski and
five great Nations finally all of these
chest pieces are starting to come
together in a meaningful way and right
now I can really feel a progression
towards a big finish in this
Arc Naruto needs to watch what he does
in his presence he doesn't want to give
danzo a reason to lock him away as a
giki thankfully it's demonstrated that
not only will Naruto not be acting heily
or emotionally in response to all of
this but in fact quite the opposite when
faced with some Cloud ninjas looking for
information on Sasuke in an aggressive
manner Sakura is reduced to tears with
the news that they lay before her and
instead of pushing back against these
unwarranted words of antagonism that
speak ill not only of his friend Sasuke
but causes Sakura distress Naruto
doesn't act how he might have acted in
the past he uses the fact he's a ginu
Riki as a means of Bridging the Gap
between between their Village and his he
says that they shouldn't be focusing on
capturing Sasuke and seeking Revenge but
instead focusing on rescuing their
Sensei first it's another instance that
demonstrates how much Naruto has grown
as a person and also how his experiences
with those that seek revenge have
transformed him into someone that does
not seek that out knowing where it can
lead one down Naruto is like the
ultimate hero's journey in this respect
at every turn he tries to diffuse any
and all attention while avoiding
glorifying his own goals and
circumstances he willingly accepts a
beating from the cloud ninja to help
them stop the cycle of violence
Vengeance will ultimately bring them
down in seeking out Sasuke and when he
shares the important information about
his meeting with the forag in his mind
he chooses not to share that he was his
father and I think that's really telling
of where Naruto is right now mentally
when one gloats one does so because they
feel insecure about another person's
perception of them and wants to elevate
their standing artificially in their
peers eyes in the beginning Naruto was a
real blowhard and that was a reaction to
how others belittled and neglected him
however nowadays he's adored by the
people he has no need to gloat if
anything he's incredibly humble about
this meeting instead telling Kakashi
what he felt was the most important part
of it to him that his father believed in
him but let's get to some plot stuff
okay following this Naruto goes to the
KAG Summit escorted by Kakashi and
Yamato with the mission being that of
Peace belief in love in and of itself
seems to be a strong theme in the story
and primarily this Arc too Naruto values
what belief can do for someone and so
won't turn his back on his friend Sasuke
he will always believe that he can be
saved Kakashi believes in Naruto then as
a result and so follows him on what ends
up being a complete waste of time
mission to request peace at the summit
and even with Sai this is a character
that sits on the fence between danzo and
Naruto one who if left to his own
devices would most likely have chosen
Naruto due to his belief inside compare
that to Danza who trusts virtually no
one and even goes as far as to Cur seal
sized tongue from speaking against his
interests it's screwed up but this all
has a greater purpose the main thematic
takeaway I gleaned from this Arc was
that of two diametrically opposed
ideologies setting themselves up for an
inevitable Collision down the road and
we see all of this information as the
world Summit yields nothing but distrust
and lack of belief in the current
structure as danzo sought to manipulate
the little Goodwill that existed through
the land of Iron's suggestion that he be
the five Nation Army leader at the
beginning at least the parts of the arc
that deal with the political unrest
that's Brewing while being a little
wordy at times felt appropriate for the
setting and interesting throughout for
me not overstaying their respective
welcomes either mind you as tensions
climb in the summit meeting and
dishonesty is rooted out the physical
reason for their mistrust in the first
place makes itself known to everyone and
it doesn't stop there
either there's a story that's shared
with us of two sons that belonged to
this akatski Obito the older son
believed that peace could only be
achieved through Power while the younger
believed it could be achieved through
love a clear thematic parallel with the
characters of Sasuke and Naruto
respectively with even more again Sasuke
being the embodiment of this power
hungry ideology speaks to his prior
engagements and the same can be true for
Naruto Sasuke's older brother Itachi
subscribed closer to love than Sasuke
did who showed him little Mercy leading
to his death embracing hatred embracing
Revenge whereas Naruto particularly as
he gained better control over himself
which speaks this being the more
difficult path has found success in
treating people with mercy and love with
one of those very people Naruto helped
God even going as far as to try and
convince Sasuke to return to kenoa in
Naruto's dead in other words thanks to
Naruto gar can now see how lost Sasuke
is how obsessed with aggression hatred
and power he seems which brings him to
tears he's been there before it's a
great moment and these themes of Love
versus hatred trust versus aggression
belief versus distrust and
responsibility are what makes this Arc
as philosophically interesting as it
otherwise ends up being ignoring the
obvious being Naruto's position on the
side of trust that doesn't entirely mean
that that side is the obvious correct
choice either a significant portion of
the story deals with Naruto's friend
group primarily Sakura and the guilt
they and she feels for putting too much
of their trust and belief in Naruto
placing him under tremendous pressure
with the question becoming should they
deal with this themselves are they being
selfish by expecting Naruto to work a
miracle here and it's easy to see why
they come to this decision they do the
choices Kishimoto made to inject Nuance
into the story like this makes what
could have become an otherwise far too
simple and straightforward story into an
exciting one and that's EX L what you
need to do when writing an arc that
hinges so much on dialogue and
introspection like this there is a
decent amount of fighting in this Arc
once The Jig Is off and Sasuke's crew
decides to make their presence felt at
the summit watching a Sasuke contends
with each KAG that stood in his way was
a real page Turner forcing him to break
out moves some of which I expected and
others I didn't things most definitely
don't go 100% according to plan and in
these skirmishes Sasuke received some
big hits not to mention his chakra gets
depleted the main significant takeaway
from this I took was that of Sasuke's
reliance on his friends or the cell team
he assembled should I say with
practically every encounter he engages
with here had it not been for his team
having his back he would surely have
lost following this activity Mata shows
up and saves Sasuke from certain defeat
taking this as his opportunity to
announce the fourth Shinobi war with his
goal being that of the natural extreme
of mistrust and yearning for power he
wishes to control and to absorb the
power of the nine-tailed beasts in order
to control the world stripping the
populace of their autonomy th securing
World Peace as a result of that control
I guess now we have an endgame and while
the five nations agree to join forces
against this foe given the mistrust that
they have for one another I can't see
that working out so what happens
[Music]
next
Sakura this is a section of this Arc I
had absolutely no idea was as
controversial as it happens to be before
getting into this I want to be perfectly
clear here I am not part of any Naruto
communities online I do not speak about
Naruto with anyone and I was not
influenced by anything other than the
material I read to come to these
conclusions and feelings I have
regarding this series I have a number of
things to say about this not all
negative however one thing I have
noticed since reading and writing this
section has been that online some folks
are exceptionally passionate about this
particular argument which is why I have
tried to make my thoughts concerning
this narrative decision as thorough as I
possibly could even double-checking my
perspective by asking all of you guys on
Twitter so whether we end up agreeing or
disagreeing on this particular occasion
I thank you for your feedback and
Thoughts with that said let's get into
my immediate reaction and then my more
nuanced understanding of what Kishimoto
was going for and whether or not I
thought he was successful my immediate
reaction to this was a little
hyperbolic everyone I give you the panel
of no return for on this page resting
lovingly upon the top panel Kishimoto
speedr the character killing or
character defining moment for Sakura
depending on who you're talking to and
unfortunately I find myself leaning much
more negatively for a host of different
reasons I will spend the next while
explaining however I do have some
positives to speak of with regards to
the scene and I want to be clear that I
still stand by all my prior appraising
of her character from earlier in this
story I can't hold young Sakura
accountable for the sins of her present
self but I digress holy
this shocked me and the more I read the
more I found myself leaning back in my
chair hand placed firmly over my face
there's a moment earlier in this Arc
where SA confronts Sakura about the
promise she asked Naruto to keep and the
pressure that promise might put on him
on paper this idea for conflict within
the character of Sakura makes sense for
both her character and the story as it
could lead to some interesting conflict
however unfortunately it never fully
makes use of it at best and totally
botches its potential at worst from the
outset I want to make it clear that I am
not someone that believed Sakura was
being fickle and just wanted Naruto when
Sasuke became a non-starter she's not
that shallow I think anyone that thinks
that clearly hasn't read or watched the
material and if they have then they
clearly weren't paying attention if
that's their takeaway I have absolutely
no idea what's going on what I
personally dislike about this scene
isn't just one thing in isolation it's
that it's one Hasty naive albeit
well-intentioned for the most part
Choice made that has a rolling knock on
series of obviously negative outcomes
outcomes that should have been
abundantly obvious to anyone
particularly as Shinobi like Sakura my
first issue Sakura feels guilty for
potentially being a reason Naruto is
assuming so much responsibility and
pressure constantly putting himself in
danger potentially risking his own life
to bring Sasuke back because it was a
promise that he made to her this is
interesting and absolutely worth
exploring further it's true to her
character however in order to alleviate
that guilt and indeed because she cares
about Naruto she decides to lie to him
in an effort to protect him this is
regardless of her reasoning manipulation
and is because in doing so she is
lying to the face of someone she
supposedly cares about using something
that he has deeply wanted in the past a
potential relationship with her and she
knows that my second issue on top of
dangling that fake carrot in front of
him this lie is also attempting to Rob
Naruto of his autonomy as a character to
force him into making a specific choice
that she agrees with that she thinks is
the right thing to do she's trying to
make the decision for Naruto in this
effort of manipulation this to me is
worse than her trying in Earnest to get
with Naruto because she's done with
Sasuke it has layers of manipulation
beneath the surface that while coming
from a good place results in a massively
obvious immature and and somewhat
selfish decision being made out of
desperation my third issue the
motivation behind the scene is fine kind
of but the execution could not have been
worse furthermore what Sakura tries to
do assuming her goal is to take the
pressure off of Naruto and take agency
by going to confront the akatski herself
is one of the most
incomprehensibly dumb decisions anyone
could make in this series at this
particular point in time there's no
amount of mental gymnastics I can
perform to rationalize this Choice
particularly for someone that's known
for how clever she is now one might say
and rightfully so that people in
Desperate Times make irrational
decisions this is true however I have
two arguments against this one is
narratively driven and the other is
character driven we'll do the character
one first Sakura is a ninja a Shinobi a
warrior that has seen some awful things
that has come close to death numerous
times before her speciality requires her
to have a level head in intense
situations and the level with which she
fails to make even the faintest rational
decision here feels incredibly
convenient for the plot and inconvenient
for us sitting at home but I'll get to
that she's been trained as what's
essentially a military operative and if
she's been made aware of just how
powerful Sasuke has gotten even remotely
she has to be aware that Naruto is the
only one capable of stopping him at that
moment the pain incident proved that
Naruto is the strongest ninja in their
Village and by an incredibly wide margin
at that taking him off of this
proverbial chess board would be the
equivalent of not using your queen
because you're too scared of it being
taken out all the while you charge in
guns blazing with your good intentions
and a bunch of Pawns to your inevitable
demise so yeah Sakura makes some
incomprehensibly bad decisions in this
Arc which brings me to my narrative
point no one likes tension built upon a
lack of communication bad communication
at that if your scenes are driven simply
by two characters not being honest with
one another that can very very easily
feel incredibly frustrating for an
audience member if done incorrectly and
this just wasn't the time or place for
this for the longest time Sakura has
slowly been slipping into the background
of this series with even characters like
Konohamaru getting to do more than her
in recent memory and so for her
character to do something like this
feels annoying at best and idiotic and
dangerous at worst and considering she's
leading a with others in herstead I'm
leaning towards the latter
miscommunication now drives this
narrative and while Itachi did do
something similar with Sasuke not being
honest with him which created the
tension and conflict in the story around
that time Kishimoto approached that
narrative Choice completely differently
we never knew any of this was fabricated
on one side and thus the tension felt
natural during the conflict all the
while when it was revealed it did so
during the climax of that narrative
decision with all of the Thematic Rel
relance laid bare alongside the climax
for the world to see in other words we
were able to enjoy it however with this
situation I feel like I already know
where it's going what will happen and
what the lesson will eventually be
sucking all of the fun and drama out of
this supposedly dramatic situation and
finally my fourth issue all of this was
ignited by the advice of Sai a character
that is literally defined in the series
by how emotionally unintelligent he is a
person who wasn't no way equipped to
contribute a meaningfully Nuance take to
Sakura and when he did so she took a
completely to hard Hook Line and Sinker
naturally this is my smallest gripe
admittedly and you could even call it a
nitpick but that's why I left it here
for last and that's just the initial two
chapters as this story with Naruto
continues and he eventually catches wind
of what's going on with Sakura moving to
attack Sasuke this King suffers a panic
attack like my heart sinks for this
character he's trying so hard to do the
right thing to be honest and everyone
around him just seems to to be a
suicidal maniac and what's more is this
part didn't even really make sense to me
when I read it the first time in this
Sai says to Naruto quote that's why she
came here to tell you all of that now
when he says that he means her and her
desire to go off and fight Sasuke to
kill him which by the way she never said
all she did was pretend to profess her
love for him and then peace out without
further explanation to which Naruto
reasonably responds with why didn't she
just say that and to that they say it's
not that easy and that she was trying to
avoid hurting Naruto at no point did she
say what she was doing or why without
Sai and everyone else there to
effectively communicate her feelings for
him he would have had literally no
comprehension of what she or her friends
are doing right now despite her
supposedly having come to tell him just
that Sakura is someone that made this
choice in an effort to bring Naruto into
the least amount of danger she wants him
to succeed and to do well she is his
friend to me this just does not justify
what she did in trying to manipulate him
and only really makes sense if I assume
she's capable of making literally the
worst possible decisions placing herself
and her loved ones in life-threatening
danger all the while achieving the
opposite of what she set out to do
placing Naruto into an even more
dangerous and compromising position
because she herself is now in danger
okay time for some positives I think the
reason this frustrated me more than
anything else thus far was primarily
because it could have been really great
first of all let me say that I think
this scene does a lot of cool things
thematically for both characters
involved conversations like these where
two pivotal characters speak frankly
with one another about something
personal or important are usually
terrific and Rich with profound
introspection and catharsis Sakura and
Naruto have a long shared and turbulent
history together ripe for the picking
and in this scene there's plenty of
nuance present that I liked and I
touched on it earlier from Sakura's
point of view she sees Naruto as someone
that's trapped in his own fantasy a
person she deeply cares about has a love
for her which forces him to take
increasingly more Extreme Action putting
himself into life-threatening danger she
thinks that's her perspective and
believing that's the reality Sakura
feels a tremendous amount of guilt and
responsibility to alleviate that stress
and that's a really cool idea and what
makes it even better is Naruto's
response to
that
[Music]
this is one of the best decisions made
not only in this Arc but perhaps some of
the most important thematic and
character defining lines heading into
this big climax with MAA highlighting
for us as an audience how Naruto handles
and doesn't handle every piece of news
that comes his way earlier in this Arc M
expresses to the world leaders what his
ultimate goals were to seize control
over everyone's autonomy using infinite
suku yomi the infinite suku yomi is an
extremely powerful genjutsu that traps
the entire world in what is effectively
an illusion enslaving the human
population in a dream so that their
chakra may be drawn upon by the god tree
or at least that's what it says on
narutopedia it is in effect a technique
which traps the victim in a fantasy a
delusion and in the scenes where Naruto
is forced to contend with the fantasy
and delusion Sakura offers him that he
has always wanted he unflinchingly
chooses reality the difficult option to
not live in a lie because as he says he
hates those people the responsibility to
trudge forward no matter how hard
reality can be and as we can see it can
be extremely difficult particularly for
him and that's what this Arc is all
about in a sense with regards cell 7 or
team 7 each character is at their most
desperate made evident by the crazy
decision Sakura made the Lang Sasuke is
willing to go to and obviously with the
way Naruto's circumstances are causing
him to feel gone of the days of
childhood concerns and vapid spats we
are on the cusp of war and we feel that
with each subsequent page turn and so
putting a pin on this Sakura scene there
are clearly some interesting ideas and
profoundly interesting thematic choices
made that speak wonderfully to the
character of Naruto and in some ways
Sakura however all of this good I think
really came at the cost of any and all
respect I had for the Sakura character
as a competent and levelheaded ninja now
time for something completely different
Kisame versus Killer B is pretty damn
cool I honestly had no idea kazami could
transform like that I mean was it hinted
at before or was it a surprise for
people let me know down below I'm
actually not sure about that one in
addition to that I think what I like
most about this fight is what it meant
for this series moving forward this
second form and indeed even the taale
forms Killer B utilizes are nothing new
to the series however what's interesting
here is that Killer B seems to be in
complete control of this form and with
that it makes me wonder if Naruto will
have to learn how to do the same it
seems like the natural final training
Arc for him to under go on his way to
big final battle I mean it's literally
him mastering the demon inside of him
it's a cool concept but who knows maybe
this speculation is a complete waste of
time the fight itself is really cool
with Kisame breaking out a sword that
can suck chakra which comes in handy
later in the fight but moreover as it
looks like he's about to win against
Killer B ryag shows up and then the two
brothers just decapitate kame which I
wasn't expecting although now that we're
heading towards the end game it makes
sense to Nick some characters here and
there and speaking of mixing some
characters it's time for a fight I
wasn't anticipating to be nearly this
damn good danzo versus Sasuke Sasuke's
fight with danzo is the battle I never
knew I needed until I got it my God
almighty this fight works on so many
different levels and not just from the
clearly Exquisite visuals we see before
us but thematically danzo is a
fascinating individual for Sasuke to
square off against from his village both
of these characters represent two
diametrically opposed extreme
convictions
neither of which desirable one willing
to do literally everything in his power
to protect his village and the other
Desiring nothing more than to destroy
that Village neither are seen as just or
virtuous characters within the story and
in effect are both antagonists I'm
probably the only one who made this
Association but whenever I see a
character like danzo one that's driven
by Extreme Measures out of mistrust and
fear of the consequences I think of the
1999 film The Iron Giant if you haven't
seen this please do it's a brilliant
story and the book it's based on off of
is fantastic also set during the Cold
War of the 1950s one of the best
characters is Kent mansley while there
are some obvious and bjor differences
between himself and danzo what I find
fascinating about these types of
characters is how easy it is to
empathize with the respective points of
view not to justify their actions mind
you but understand them it ends up
making for some of the most interesting
interactions and colors the world with a
lot more nuance and when danzo removed
that brace from his arm revealing a
Litany of sharing eyes he'd harvested
from the Fallen UIA Clan I knew this
fight was going to be all sorts of
messed up and it didn't disappoint armed
with an arm of sharingans this battle
between these two fighters erupts into
an incredibly well animated game of
chess hinging the abilities of each
wielder specific strengths to be
utilized in tandem with either
misdirection or pure tenacity there's a
terrific visual marker established part
ways through the fight with danzo and
his remaining eyes acting as sort of a
lives system sacrificing an i to prolong
his struggle against Sasuke and that's
not to say danzo doesn't do work in this
either he does incredibly well way
better than I thought he would in terms
of choreography and setup for the fight
this one has a very good ending I think
all the while utilizing misdirection not
just on danzo but with us as an audience
too Sasuke had cast an illusion which
caused danzo to believe he had a spare
Sharingan or life so to speak when in
fact he didn't leading to his desperate
Gambit at the
end
this took me by surprise in a good way I
knew what the odds of this happening
were but I really didn't want it to
happen Karen had literally been offering
up her lifeblood to Sasuke in order to
rejuvenate him this whole thought
process was cut off though as donzo goes
full kamakazi mode there's a short but
wonderfully insightful flashback sharing
with us the past of both Huen and danzo
prior to either of them achieving higher
status in their Village each one acting
as a sort of counterbalance so to speak
to the other Huen would go on to operate
in the light as Hokage and danzo in the
shadows both acting in the interest of
the respective Village to The Bitter End
and quite unlike Kent mansley and Iron
Giant danzo at the very least is brave
enough to die for his convictions and
not become overwhelmed by the task or
Foe in front of him it's a really cool
moment that sort of recontextualizes a
lot of what he's done up until now sort
of Sakura and Sasuke there's a really
cool scene that takes place immediately
following the after math of this
encounter Karen is on the verge of death
on the floor waiting to be polished off
by the uncaring Sasuke and suddenly
Sakura shows up I'm not exactly sure how
I should feel about what she did to her
friends though on the way to meet with
Sasuke I mean I'm happy she did what she
could to spare their lives from what
ultimately amounted to a terrible
strategic move I didn't mention it
before but the idea that all of them
would take action like that with little
to no strategy genuinely surprised me
regarding Sakura however a large part of
the story deals with Sakura actively
making her presence felt in the story
and celebrating her autonomy as a
character but she does so by robbing
everyone else of theirs it's a really
strange decision narratively
particularly because of what happens at
the end of all of this her plans fail
twice achieving nothing and even admits
to some extent that she's just been in
the way so what's being achieved here
exactly to me it just feels like
Kishimoto Wanted only cell 7 to be
present for the final confrontation of
the Ark to reunite and didn't have a way
of getting Sakura there without her
making a host of extremely rash
decisions putting herself into Harm's
Way on two separate accounts the first
time when her plan if you can even call
it that leading to her trying to
convince Sasuke that she's going to be
on his side but he sees through
that surprises her she fails and then
Kakashi has to save her with that said
when she is in the room there's some
really nice imagery evocative of the
last moment she and Sasuke had oneon-one
before he initially left he flashes
behind her to thank her in that moment
she feels a connection with Sasuke it's
kind of nice however this time he
deceives her and once behind her she
felt nothing but an entirely different
person a coldness as Karen put it
there's a reallyy cool thematic visual
contrast that speaks to the progression
of these two characters and the
relationship I can see why Kishimoto
wanted her to be there in that moment I
just think the means with which he gets
her there is really strange and almost
unbelievable Naruto's journey to this
place however has been great trying to
deal with all of the responsibility all
of the stress a panic attack him
escaping in a creative way to deal with
Sasuke himself using the sage mode he
learned earlier in the prior Arch to
locate him and when he arrives he does
so in dramatic fashion following the
fight with Kakashi when he saves Sakura
the fight between Sasuke and Kakashi
isn't super long and apart from the
obviously cool Rogue student versus
regretful Master Dynamic of play one
particular Parts it out to me as really
nice Sasuke's dialogue or interactions
with Kakashi in these moments has him
saying things like only the uchia are
able to wield a shouting again however
through his Adept fighting with it s
acknowledges him well sort of this
happens only in the anime and I I can
see why it wasn't involved in the manga
this fight is actually quite short and
barely a fight at all really and while I
prefer that it isn't drawn out like in
the anime the anime does have a cool
line where Sasuke declares that he's
about to show what a real master of the
sharing gang can do only for him to
start losing his sight it's a really
nice visual touch that draws attention
to the path he's heading down with his
Spirit Kaiju fading away just like his
vision and in that moment Sakura takes
takes advantage of the situation yet
again now uh I bet a lot of people hate
on this but at the same time this is a
uniquely difficult situation to be in
and one she thought or at least wanted
to believe she was capable of following
through with and honestly I think I
understand both sides of this argument
not to say I'm sitting on the fence here
I think while the idea was interesting
the execution left a lot to be done
desired Sakura a character which has
played an increasingly smaller role as
of late in the series suddenly starts
taking not only an active role driving
her own Tale But makes choices that
actively make the life of the main
character that we're following so much
harder for reasons that honestly don't
make a lot of sense outside of her
feeling that she has to be part of or
shoulder some of this responsibility
ultimately achieving nothing I genuinely
think that partially due to her
inactivity it created a situation where
fans were far less likely to be
charitable towards her actions but
that's just my take and that brings us
to the end of the five kagay Summit I
had intended on covering more in this
video but when I discovered how heated
the conversation and dialogue online was
surrounding Sakura in this particular
Arc I knew that I had to dive in there
with a lot more detail plus this Arc had
a surprising amount happen too like
danzo becoming the temporary six of KAG
the five KAG summon itself the fourth
Shinobi War being declared Killer B
versus Kisame Sasuke versus danzo and of
course team sevens reuniting speaking of
which uh if you do disagree with
anything I said that's cool Everyone's
entitled to their own takes on a
fictional character and while I know
this might be autal effort much like
Sakura I'm going to try anyway please be
kind to each other in the comment
section I know without even looking it's
going to be a hellscape but please just
try to respect everyone you know we're
all human beings at the end of the
[Music]
day they will
off the back of my last video I'm
picking things up again right as Naruto
saves Sakura from her second near-death
experience courtesy of Sasuke which
leads to a surprisingly novel experience
in the series there is a standoff yes
but there's relatively speaking very
little action with only one blow being
exchanged between the two Warriors and
the interesting part of this scene
doesn't come from the action but instead
through the thoughts and words shared
Naruto sees Sasuke as a friend and
understands the Nuance of his situation
he's also so capable of empathizing with
his circumstances even going as far as
to imagine a scenario where he could
have turned out exactly the same as
Sasuke lost and vengeful there's a nice
call back to their last major conflict
with Naruto himself citing that they are
both high level Shinobi now meaning they
should be able to read each other's
thoughts apparently further emphasizing
this sense in Sasuke that Naruto does in
fact understand why he is the way that
he is and drags to the Forefront
Sasuke's mistakes for him only for
Sasuke to double down on his path
moments afterwards by requesting he
receive his brother's eyes because he is
now losing his vision and speaking of
which perhaps down the road this Choice
could act as a physical embodiment of
finally getting to see the world from
his brother's perspective slowly coming
around to his way of seeing things both
literally and metaphorically in other
words there might be a chance for some
nice albeit slightly on the nose
symbolism but I digress the scene itself
between Sasuke and Naruto exchanging
words has some really nice call backs to
their respective pasts as they launch
towards each other with their respective
signature techniques the chador and the
renen it's quite tense and despite it
being for the most part a little teaser
or Prelude to what will no doubt be a
massive conflict later on in the story I
thought the dialogue and themes
presented here were both entertaining
and effective in what they were trying
to achieve and before I move on I want
to touch on what might be a minor visual
cue but it might also be my favorite
visual indicator during the entire
confrontation that spoke to how serious
and all in really Naruto was during this
meeting with Sasuke prior to Stepping
forward to confront him both physically
and verbally Naruto had created two
other clones this could have created the
perfect situation for him to hedge his
bets and Bluff by keeping his true self
back while sending out a clone to carry
out that same message you know for
safety however and this speaks to what
he said to Sakura about authenticity and
being true to oneself he didn't do that
as made evident by those two clones
Vanishing the moment Sasuke leaves
revealing that the real Naruto was in
fact the one in front of him all along
before passing out in that moment he
really put everything on the line
extending a friendly smile and genuine
hand in order to potentially save his
friend earnestly trying to do so that's
a powerful statement and it's
communicated without words brilliantly
in a way only Naruto the character can
it's a brilliant part of this scene that
honestly was quite understated I thought
Switching gears now to something
completely different Killer B returns to
his village with his brother in tow the
rag since defeating kame he's been
keeping his sword as a quote spoil of
War but oh wait
kame is alive this legitimately caught
me off guard I genuinely thought he was
dead considering the Direction the Story
was going it made sense to me at the
time that the cast would start to
dwindle down some however my estimation
was entirely incorrect instead we're not
only not killing off kame but we're
reincorporating him back into the story
along with Kabuto with a brand new snake
likee design and speaking of Kabuto
hello I'm glad orochimaru's presence is
still being felt in the story since his
absorption somewhat so much time had
been spent on him and his desires as a
character furthermore he offered a
really interesting third position in the
eoty versus Shinobi War that's now
looming on the horizon and thankfully
Kabuto can act as the replacement for
that ideology in many respects with his
desires not necessarily interfering with
the yatsky the alliance between the two
was an interesting one for sure and
catching back up with the Canoa folks
the Sakura knocked out I think it's
interesting watching Karen remark on
what she feels when looking at Naruto
compared to when she looked at
remarking that he's the exact opposite
of him bright and warm but what I really
liked about this was what it was
foreshadowing for moments after she
remarks on his brightness and warmth she
comes right out and remarks on what
Darkness Lies Beneath the nine-tailed
fox spirit I like this in retrospect as
it really helps to set up and build up a
challenge Naruto eventually has to face
mastering this Darkness he possesses
deep down and speaking of that Darkness
right off the back of Sasuke's
successful ice surgery transplant or
whatever you want to call it we witness
an counter between Naruto and the toad
Spirits this largely deals with the
Elder toad examining Naruto's Destiny
for any signs of progression towards a
favorable goal in it he sees two
entities in Naruto's future the toad
Elder sees an octopus taking the form of
a mentor of which while reading I had a
few working theories as to what that
eight Lim entity might manifest as
Theory number one octopuses are famous
for their eight limbs limbs which look
like tals and so my first thought is
that this could easily point to Naruto
being mentored by killerby and his eight
tal spirit this makes sense as he would
be able to teach him to control the nin
Tales like he did with his eight as
established earlier in the story this
one happened to be correct Theory number
two was maybe the octopus and its eight
limbs are a misdirect and Naruto is
actually going to fight against or learn
from Kabuto and his many snakes which
could take the form of eight snakes who
knows this was a long shot and I knew it
and finally my third theory was maybe
the octopus is a metaphor for a beast
composed of eight individuals maybe this
will result to Naruto working with
killerby and seven others to complete
his training but this again was a long
shot in my eyes the second and final
prophecy interpreted by the toad spoke
of someone whose power lies in his eyes
which Naruto confidently alludes to
Sasuke matching that description and I
mean it does but now that Naruto and
effec ofely Kishimoto has pointed it out
it makes me question whether or not it
is going to be Sasuke either way I'm
excited by the prospects of this I love
that this training Naruto has to undergo
also forces him to focus on what makes
him different from Sasuke that his
training is only possible because he
represents the ideological opposite to
Sasuke's hatred one cannot Master what
Naruto is setting out to do by embracing
hate but in fact suppressing and
overcoming it it's perfect and the means
with which he does it is also great
right now Naruto has to overcome his
internal demons to even qualify for the
training under killer be and upon
stepping up to this preliminary
challenge Naruto realizes what's being
asked of him the actual manifestation of
his anger resentment and hatred stands
before him the chakra and world that
Naruto inhabits is great for these
obvious visual metaphors and often times
when shows have interesting worlds and
settings like this that lend a lot to
their stories they rest in The Laurels
of those advantages while not staying
true to the characters in this however
the manifestation of Naruto's hatred is
perfectly in keeping with his character
earlier in the arc as well as other
times in the series Naruto's been
apprehensive to indulge or fully embrace
the adulation he's been receiving since
becoming the hero of Canoa and when
faced with his inner hatred we learn
that this stems from a lack of trust in
them and himself a lack of trust because
he doesn't fully believe in himself
being worthy of this praise and there's
something beautiful about that once he
overcomes it not through action but
instead through self-acceptance and this
early training material is full of
moments very true to Naruto's character
he's light-hearted in the face of
uncertainty and when offered the chance
to use a clone to hedge his bets he
unflinchingly refuses to use it citing
that he's going to trust himself
speaking again to that very aspect
presid in the last encounter with Sasuke
that I loved so
[Music]
much the struggle between Naruto and the
ninetail fox spirit is for all intents
and purposes one of the best moments for
me in the entire series not just for its
thematic resonance with me or even how
well it's drawn there's tons to love and
appreciate about this sequence and
struggle for Naruto with his clear
Reliance in every signature move he's
learned across the series from the Clone
technique to the renen to even the sage
mode itself all of which are
manifestations and results derived from
those that have helped and loved him in
the past particularly with the sage mode
and when he uses that I actually got
chills all of this is fantastic however
for me the best part of this scene came
from how it ended up making me
feel
Nar at the beginning of every volume
Kishimoto writes a short paragraph
describing either the development of
this particular volume or whatever might
have been on his mind at the time of
writing it for volume 53 he wrote this
when the time came to put together the
plot for Naruto volume 53 I consulted my
wife and this is what resulted stories
about mother and if I'm being completely
honest I really felt that warm authentic
motherly influence all over these
chapters when Naruto contends with his
inner demons the fact that his mother
and father were both set up by prior
seals to appear at certain key moments
in his life I thought was a brilliant
touch there's a scene much later on
where iruka's father says to him it's
the parents duty to protect their
children and protect their child Kusha
and matato most definitely did and
continue to do culminating with the
events detail from chapter 500 onwards
entitled the birth of Naruto this is the
best part of the story I've read I don't
think I've ever been more captivated by
this series before the sense of occasion
spectacle and profound drama quotes each
and every page enticing me to read
further the precise and careful steps
taken by m to exact his revenge on Canoa
by unleashing the ninetail fox Spirit
the sheer scale of the occasion knowing
what we do now about what happens all
the while we watches Naruto's mom and
dad do everything in their power to hang
on long enough to save him and his
village it's a stunning series of
chapters that I actually found myself
going back over to read before writing
this very section of the video it's just
so well handled with the small cameos
from Kakashi and guy with Ira being
courageous even as early as then we get
to see the third Hokage as well as a
host of other villagers and Shinobi some
familiar and others formerly slain but
beyond anything else the real star of
this show is the sense of paternal
responsibility intense love for and
belief in their first and only child
Naruto I love how much n is so
levelheaded calm and talented always
looking to put the needs of his family
and others ahead of his own and I adore
how chaotic and courageous Kusha is when
trying to help her husband and child I
can see clear as day where all of
Naruto's best traits came from the drama
and Stakes rise higher and higher until
they both realize that there's only one
way of dealing with this monster and
when they come to that conclusion
Naruto's father exclaims let's believe
in this child he is our son after all
for for a series like Naruto I don't
think there could have been a more
fitting line than this right here a
child that has suffered from a feeling
of inadequacy because he felt no one
ever believed in him because no one ever
loved him ended up in that situation for
quite the opposite reason because those
that loved him more than anything else
in the world were willing to lay
everything they had on the line to save
him to believe in his future and what he
can bring to the world it's such a
brilliant line that speaks to the 500
chapters that came before it and then
there's the final moments of the volume
where Kusha and matato moments before
their respective deaths unpack
everything they wish they could tell
their son before they pass on and to say
that I wept in these fleeting moments
would be an understatement this utterly
destroyed me and I cannot express just
how much I adore this scene today and it
was all down to how authentic it felt
remaining true to the mission statement
at the beginning of this volume I can
absolutely tell that Kishimoto and his
wife collaborated on the dialogue and
direction of these scenes Kushina had so
much to say she was so loving and
maternal both in the traditional sense
and in a progressive one at times all
the while manato remains steadfast kind
and supportive all the way to The Bitter
End it's fantastically believable and
entrancing in the most tragic and
beautiful of ways easily the most
emotional this Series has made me hands
down no exceptions with the final
results being a newly unlocked form the
likes of which is more aesthetically
pleasing to me than any other design
I've yet seen produced from Naruto or
Kishimoto for the rest of this series it
looks powerful transcended and
appropriately Angelic given what Naruto
has gone through to achieve it it looks
perfectly suited to Naruto himself as
Karen would put it bright and
[Music]
warm Guy versus Kisame so this fight
scene boasts one of the few moments that
actually made me laugh out loud while
reading a manga having already
established what happened at the
waterfall of Truth through Naruto's
fight with himself to contrast that with
Kisame crashing through it leading to
guy believing that kisame's weird spiky
crazy form was his true self gave me a
good chule it on honesty and furthermore
I was elated that guy was now back in
the fold actively participating in the
story it's been way too long and I hope
we get to see more of rock Le and him
too those characters are way too good
not to be used more than they currently
are and in all seriousness this fight
vindicates that desire because holy
this was incredible
throughout this series Kisame has been a
cockroach not in the sense that he's an
irritating insect but more so that he
just won't die or go away and being
incredibly powerful as he is he's always
been a large issue whenever he's propped
up in the story armed with abilities
that absorb chakra I honestly couldn't
think of a better opponent to absolutely
body him like guy did right here the
years of tireless practice in perfecting
an area of fighting that's been somewhat
neglected in modern times Tai Jutsu
something that could have been seen as a
weakness in some other occasion is the
very reason he was able to overcome
Kisame In This Moment there's no chakra
use at all he's just so powerful his
fist change the pressure in the air
enough to create this monstrosity
watching Kisame try and fail to secure
any of his chakra in his usual way it's
mind-bendingly cool to watch and when
Kisame tries to move even an inch
afterwards gu pounces on him
effortlessly pinning him to the ground
yet again for individual who's more
flamboyant and light-hearted than most
it serves his character and indeed this
scene well for him to be so serious
during this encounter it's a great
contrast what a tussle so damn cool also
I'm not going to lie there are times
when I'm reading this story that I
wished it was more like guy and rock
Le's story they need their own spin-off
manga or something because I would read
that in a
heartbeat I just love their designs and
characters they're just so dorky while
also looking effortlessly badass when
drawn a certain way that's a really
tough balance to strike with the design
and they're barely used at all the
ending however of this encounter with
Kisame is actually kind of nice but in a
troubling sort of way of course trying
to get Intel from Kisame while he's down
Kisame elects to off himself instead of
relinquishing set information and I like
this really only because we get a short
glimpse into his past and his first
introduction to Itachi way back when I
will however say that I would have liked
his backstory to be established a little
earlier in the story than it was right
now us being filled in on the details of
his key life thematic moments mere
seconds before his death feels a tiny
bit rushed and I feel cheapens the
overall character he's a brilliant
character this sort of felt like
Kishimoto was a kid in class doing his
homework right before it started though
I suppose that's a bit severe we've
known Kisame for quite some time and I
still very much enjoyed this bit of
introspection it offered of for Itachi
and indeed how it influenced kisame's
judgment I especially like the line
Itachi utters about death quote no
matter who you are you do not know what
kind of human you are until the very end
which speaks wonderfully to to both
Itachi and indeed kisame's death at this
moment I really like this
[Music]
inclusion and right off the back of
Kisame we get this Mammoth of a battle
between Conan and uchia mad during which
his Mass stats to break off from her
incredible attack and will to defeat him
I didn't see this battle in the anime
but in the manga the scale and scope of
kishimoto's drawings really sold me on
the magnitude of this encounter Conan is
standing up for an ideal instilled in
her by Naruto earlier in the story
hopeful that the future Nago yearned for
would eventually become a reality it's
clear that Obito or MAA in this instance
is single-minded in his approach
referring to nagato initially not by
name but instead by his utility the
reinan and watching Conan shroud him in
her bombs leaving him with a destroyed
mask and a missing arm felt massively
satisfying and surprising it seems
having come from a group that believed
in yahiko or nagato being the bridge to
peace they now have only one hope left
Naruto and really I think that's a nice
buildup towards the climax there's a
really sweet little sign off too to
these characters using their time spent
with jiah but again I kind of wish this
lesson they shared wasn't established
for the purposes of this exit to the
story I still think it's massively
resonant but I think it could have been
made a lot more effective if it had been
a call back to an element of their
training we had already been exposed to
during their time with jiah but that's
honestly just a small gripe and hey look
M has a Swanky new
mask right at this moment Naruto thinks
he's on a mission to count the amount of
balls on these animals all the while not
deara and Kabuto tried to reach and
capture him while flying on a giant clay
bird which is in and of itself flying to
an island that is also not an island but
a massive turtle do I have that right
this story is so weird and I love it in
the best of ways at this point the story
is escal ating much faster than I
expected it to which is brilliant from a
pacing standpoint and I love the
atmosphere and characters that are being
brought to the Forefront of this Arc 2
funly enough Kishimoto wrote at the
beginning of volume 55 that he had to go
back and reference his older work
because this upcoming section involves
so many past characters apparently he
just forgot about their specs and don't
worry Kishimoto so did I probably the
most significant actions that occurred
during this encounter were that the old
KAG guy that looks a little like the
inspiration for granino from my hero
Academia fought against Adara and of
course the capture of yam by Kabuto I
think the most interesting part of this
for me was how calculated and measured
Kabuto's judgment seems to be in this
instance he's not going to overextend
himself at all and due to that he's
managed to make off with Yamato a
massively powerful Shinobi and Ally to
Naruto all in an effort to effectively
fuel M's Army and I guess that means
it's time for
[Applause]
[Music]
war G's speech one thing I will say
about this from the outside as it's as
good a time as any to say it G's rolling
the story ever since the time skip has
been diminished so significantly that it
almost feels like an injustice similar
to how I've expressed myself concerning
guyan Rock Lee gar is another one of
those characters I felt could have
offered so much more to the story having
been yet another albeit much more simple
analog to Sasuke given the journey he's
on right now I was prepared going into
the time skip for gar to fulfill a
specific role while not as prominent as
Naruto and SAS I figured given his
standing in the story at the time that
he would have been kept involved in the
rat race so to speak with that said
leading up to this point I haven't been
entirely upset with his utility in the
tale altogether he does provide an
interesting bit of commentary concerning
his view on the Old Guard versus the
Next Generation and I do like how he
empathizes from time to time on the
actions of different characters he
relates to on a deeper level furthermore
I think placing him into a Leader's role
is a really interesting idea and while I
am happy with what he offers the story I
think he's still being criminally
underutilized and I even go as far as to
say that I feel like there have been
some new characters introduced in this
second half of the story fulfilling
roles that he could have otherwise been
occupying at this moment but that's just
my opinion as we're introduced to both
the Shinobi and the akatski forces
there's a great contrast established
while we look at the folks fighting on
behalf of Shinobi against the akatski we
see numerous faces some familiar some
unfamiliar all with a strong sense of
character perspective and experience or
lack thereof every one of them voices
their concerns speculations and thoughts
to us as we s through each regiment
however with the akatski there's nothing
but darkness and silence like an army of
zombies totally void of Life are bracing
themselves for an imminent attack
awaiting the orders of their leader mad
it's quite tense and Atmospheric if I'm
being perfectly
[Music]
honest gar speech is the best thing his
character has done since Naruto saved
him so so long ago and while I have my
grievances with how this character has
been treated since this scene still
speaks to the aspects of the character
that I adored back in the beginning and
indeed still do right now the
differences that make up this fighting
unit this Army when compared to the
forces of the akatski is that of Life
they aren't resurrected beings they
aren't zombies they have one life and
they have free will these are the very
things that they are fighting against
the akasi for however they are also
something that at this moment are
standing in their respective ways for
many years the shared histories of these
Villages Mist Cloud Sandstone Leaf Etc
have been a source of pain and hatred
for one another but this is where gar
has a chance to utilize his unique
history to act as the great unifier in
many respects and in quite spectacular
fashion too might I add I was only
sitting here reading the speech in the
manga and it still gave me chills again
he totally empathizes with the
respective points of view and even
offers himself up to the chopping block
once this is all over but also outlines
that today they need to unify using
their shared experience with the akatski
to understand that this is much larger
than each of them and their individual
feelings right now and serves to to
highlight that following hatred is a
recipe for disaster a lesson Naruto
taught him and for Naruto their families
and their homes they must fight this day
it's a spectacular speech that again
speaks to the themes of this character
and indeed to handing over
responsibility to the Next Generation to
try and make amends for the mistakes of
the
past like I mentioned in the past with
regards to Naruto's motivation and
conviction as well as what's highlighted
When comparing these two armies a
driving force of many of these conflicts
is that of dealing with reality and
right here in this battle we see just
that we watch his s confronts a version
of his brother whom he loves we watch
his sesori learns to understand that the
so-called true self he now believes he
is is nothing more than a marionette
controlled and conjured by someone else
all of these are terrific instances that
speak to the ideology that makes for the
real Battleground that this all is
taking place on with a really nice touch
being that of their termination not by
offense but instead by convincing them
to join reality instead of a fantasy a
nice ruffle in the story from Kishimoto
I thought and if the impending battle
wasn't intense enough the training
Naruto is undergoing right now might
yield my new favorite technique in the
series so this beu chakra Fire Spirit
mode he's got right now is surprisingly
similar mechanically to that of the
kaio-ken well uh at least from what it
offers the story in some important
respects similar to the Kaioken if Goku
were to rely too heavily on it it would
cease being a tool and instead become an
instrument for his demise as seen during
The saian Saga however with Naruto
having successfully alfha the ninetail
spirit he now has access to the fox's
chakra reserves an important and
Brilliant addition to his repertoire
however without having tamed the Fox
Naruto now runs a very large risk if he
relies too heavily on the fox spirit's
chakra energy the fox too can steal
Naruto's chakra and if that Supply
reaches zero that being Naruto's chakra
energy then there's no more Naruto and
to add more weight to this issue if he
uses the Clone technique it expedites
that same process which not only means a
significantly important technique
fundamental to much of his Arsenal has
now been compromised but he also can't
lean as heavely on it to speed up his
training but in typical Naruto fashion
this isn't going to slow the young man
down but I honestly have no idea where
this will lead him my hope is somewhere
really cool okay so over the last half a
year I've been reading the Naruto manga
for the very first time and for a few
instances I've honestly been having a
really good experience the beginning was
a little slow but once we got to the
tuning exams things really stepped into
high gear as we were introduced to a
deep cast of characters all of which had
something to offer the story story from
Nei to Rock Lee from Hinata to Shikamaru
and as time marched onward and more and
more vicious adversaries appeared and
disappeared I found myself really
getting into this series even after the
time skip where a lot of people told me
I would start to lose interest I still
found myself very much invested in
almost all of the scenes I was engaging
with until this week this week
challenged me in a way that I haven't
been challenged by a series in quite
some time and it's not a good thing as a
reviewer I never wanted to find myself
in a scenario where I have to force my
my way through something in order to get
it consumed for the purposes of a review
that doesn't make for a good review and
it's unfair to the series I'm reading
too if I'm not in the right mindset for
a long story like this then even when
stuff I would otherwise enjoy prop up
I'm less likely to be charitable to it
and give it the attention it deserves
when I'm in the wrong frame of mind in
order to prevent this from happening I
take breaks during my day to walk my dog
spend some time with my family and do
some chores I'd otherwise have to do in
the evening time all in an effort to
make sure I'm receiving this material as
best I can and thankfully I've never had
to do this excessively this is all to
say that I am aware that there are
millions of fans of the section of the
story no doubt and while I still really
liked a lot of the ideas and scenes in
this section I found it to be one of the
most boring narratively to get through
and honestly it's for a number of
complicated reasons but it all boils
down to something under the umbrella of
this arc's use of flashbacks now I need
to make something perfectly clear here
before I explain because it's a lot more
complicated than just quote flashbacks
bad flashbacks are a terrific narrative
tool and just because the story uses a
ton of flashbacks in its chapters
creation doesn't by default make it an
ill-conceived narrative creation however
I will say the effectiveness of
flashbacks heavily depends on how they
are applied within a story so again for
the people in the back of the room
flashbacks aren't the problem in
isolation here my issues lie more with
how they are being used by Kishimoto in
this Arc within story like one piece
berserk and even Naruto itself on a
number of occasions flashbacks have been
the backbone to many iconic and terrific
scenes Itachi's impending conflict with
his brother Sasuke was a confrontation
built on the back of this particular
flashback mechanic without which the
result would be far less impressive or
impactful within that same Dynamic
Kishimoto also used The Limited
perspective of Sasuke to misdirect us
the audience through flashback to make
the climax all the more effective once
we did eventually see Itachi's
perspective and it worked brilliantly I
thought it is through understanding and
appreciating the flashback for the good
that it does within a story which
highlights I think the drawbacks to
using it flippantly or Worse again as a
narrative crutch I'm talking
specifically about the differences
between a flashback that's used to
enhance a scene versus one that is
needed for a scene to work at all and
fittingly there are examples of both in
these first three volumes of the Ark so
to better illustrate my point and to
prove that I'm not just hating here here
are some instances from this section
where I really like the application of
flashbacks before we get into the
problems I have with it Naruto's
training while Naruto is all but absent
from volumes 55 and 56 he does appear
quite a lot in volumes 54 and 57 within
which we get to see his training under
KB to help control his beu powers more
specifically to learn the Buu bomb which
as it happens is performed near
identical fashion to the renen the very
technique his father had and that Jah
helped to teach him there are call backs
to the Past in this SE sequence which
help to tie something new the beu bomb
to something emotionally resonant from
the past which had already been
previously established it helps to
heighten the sense of emotional weight
in the story while also serving to
remind us of something we could have
conceivably known prior in other words
the flashback enhanced the moment it did
not Define the moment later in the story
Naruto is cut off from investigating the
chakra he sents outside by IRA and
others Ika is trying to carry out what
his superiors have tasked him to do to
keep Naruto on the island but in that
moment Naruto senses the outside world
and all the suffering taking place
seemingly outside of his control it's
then Kishimoto uses flashbacks in a way
that I really liked flashing back to
something that we have seen before
Naruto's final confrontation with nagato
wherein he laments and uses over the
futility of war and how it perpetuates
the cycle of pain violence and suffering
in the world and in response to iku's
request to stay put with the promises
Naruto made to Naruto echoing in his
ears Naruto says I can stop this the
presence of this flashback enhances the
scene's punchline but it doesn't depend
on it and because of that it not only
helps the story feel Grand and complex
but it also serves to focus or
recontextualize the point of view Naruto
already has for us in this moment
further enhanced by yet more brief dips
into the past showing iku's thought
process with the note he leaves Naruto
after he powers out of their grasp
speaking to their relationship this is
brilliant and heartfelt storytelling it
is exactly why I love Naruto Zabuza and
Haku Zabuza and haku's return to the
pages of this manga off the back of
their Resurrection courtesy of Kabuto is
exactly what practically all of these
fights should have been in my eyes it
feels like there are dozens of fights
that take place in this Arc very few of
which I actually cared about but this
was one I very much found not only
enjoyable but powerful with them begging
to be put out of their misery to Kakashi
they slowly lose themselves as pawns yet
again to the elites that control them
zombies to the violent World they've
been forced in many ways to participate
in continuing the cycle of violence and
suffering that Nago spoke of and that
Naruto is currently trying to stop
despite being very early established
characters with little screen time they
end up painting a clear picture of
precisely the world or heroes in this
story are trying to change regarding
flashbacks however there's only minor
pieces of exposition of which there are
some minor pieces to remind us who these
people are in case we've forgotten it
doesn't distract from or bloat their
presence at all Asuma versus Enos
Shikamaru and choji this is another
fight I enjoyed part of but then started
to see a pattern emerge an obvious
pattern that slowly devolved into a
tedious nightmare for me okay I'm being
a little hyperbolic but it's all just
for good fun and it's a comic after all
come on Enos Shikamaru and Shoji's
efforts against assuma are some of the
most emotional out of all the conflicts
that take place here for me the
struggles that each member deals with
are the clear highlights that further
speak to the themes of generational
inheritance shikaru spoke of a while
back in the story The Next Generation is
taking over and accepting their new
position as Legends in their own right
by taking down the current Legends or
Legends of the past Flash facts are
heavy-handed in this scene too one in
particular that works well I thought is
the flashback to asuma's parting advice
to his students it's touching and serves
to put the scene on a pedestal in my
eyes a powerful strong moment choji
struggles to apply himself honestly
Shikamaru has an incredible amount of
resolve and conviction in this moment
having the clarity of mind to remind
choji that they are fighting to protect
asuma's child from his now zombified
father that they can't afford to be
cowardly In This Moment which sort of
bounces off of a line concerning
conviction from another fight that I'll
touch on slightly more negatively later
on but you know the quotes from that
section are still really good this is
all to say that Kishimoto had some
really cool ideas here and executed upon
some of them perfectly fine and well in
my mind but my god did I think that this
section was a structural nightmarish
Quagmire that I had to stop reading on
countless occasions because I was just
so sick of hearing Exposition from
characters I knew were going to go away
in mere chapters and that's not to even
make mention of a particular use of
flashbacks he employs here too before I
begin I think it's important to state
that I don't think Kishimoto is
necessarily using flashbacks as a crutch
per se but they're definitely doing a
lot of the heavy lifting during these
scenes and chapters over and over again
and I think that's the most important
part making up for a potential lack of
personal investment between his audience
and the characters a potential
unfamiliarity between his audience and
these characters seeing as they show up
very little in the story in meaningful
ways and perhaps a lack of planning or
proper structuring for these encounters
ahead of time on behalf of Kishimoto for
the better part of two volumes I spend
so much time with characters I either
didn't know didn't care about or with
one group did care about but didn't love
the execution of King Kaku and gaku for
instance I have never heard of before so
in order to create a scenario with a
satisfying climax to this section
kushimoto uses a flashback to establish
something in the past for these
characters to call back to in the end of
the fight before they're defeated to
give its ending an air of I don't know
finality otherwise it would have just
felt weird and using this technique here
and there you know it's honestly fine
but but here's the thing he uses this
exact same technique back to back to
back in this Arc it feels like this drab
dude durai I think his name is d r AI
has a flashback informing me or
reminding me of him and sets up the
conclusion to his fight mun versus Hanzo
have some nice themes at play with some
great quotes that I mentioned before but
ultimately I do not care about these
characters and again kimono uses yet
more flashbacks to create quote
satisfying conclusions here for these
people and even enjoying the Asuma fight
which focused on kji this is by far the
least offensive by the way but it still
had yet another flashback to something
we could have already seen before but
never did and the fact is that it's
there to set up a climax for me that
cheapens what was already emotionally
resonant without it and heck maybe they
did talk about the earrings before but
if they did I honestly couldn't recall
which just makes me wish that these
characters had more of a central role in
the story because they are compelling
now the use of a flashback here I think
in isolation is Purp perfectly fine but
within this Twisted Meandering
NeverEnding conga line of now boring
flashbacks this particular attempt to
reach me emotionally absolutely fell
flatter than it should which is as I
said such a shame because I actually
really like joji and look I really
wanted to fill this video with more
positivity than there ultimately will be
here and there will be positivity for
sure in places but when I was going
through my notes for this let me just
say that there were a lot of heated
words used one of the worst things the
story can be for me personally is boring
if something is comically bad at least I
can laugh at it and have a good time
engagement and interest is the most
important aspect of this process and I
just didn't get a whole lot of that in
this section unfortunately with that
said let's press onto something I did
like a lot more at the beginning of
volume 57 the story starts to refocus
itself on the main characters yet again
thankfully and Kishimoto says as much in
an almost exasperated blurb at the start
of the volume 2 as I've said in the past
a OA is fantastic a timeing together
seemingly disconnected prior encounters
to heighten the stakes or emotional
weight of a present scene and while I
don't think Kishimoto is comparably
strong in that department he is
extremely good at communicating his
experiences and feelings through his
analog in this story Naruto there's this
dope one-on-one scene where Naruto gets
to meet and Converse with the
nine-tailed fox spirit yet again the fox
brings up his past with Sasuke saying
that he couldn't even protect him from
his own hatred and yet he thinks he can
save everyone from it in the throws of
War and again this internal conflict
with Naruto has been a fun and
compelling device to demonstrate the
growth of the character throughout this
journey in the beginning he didn't even
want to face him or look at him he was
terrified of it he tried to Fain
confidence and eventually he gave into
it before his parents lifted him out on
two separate occasions however this time
Naruto reaffirms that he hasn't failed
with Sasuke because the only way to fail
in this instance would be to quit and he
will never quit on his friends which is
a terrific answer brimming with charm
and courage for Naruto to say all the
while he looks at his evil self's
reflection in the eye of the fox
speaking to his overcoming of his inner
demons indirectly answering the question
the fox asked in the first place of his
sudden confidence boost it's a terrific
scene All Things Considered furthermore
on the positive side of things we get my
favorite scene I've covered in this
video so far and while I'm sure many of
you will find it quite unremarkable the
very fact it was different from all the
other scenes I've seen up until now was
enough to sway me in a positive
direction let that sink in it was
different and therefore I liked it a lot
Switching gears from the constant
fighting and flashbacks we get this
rather intense scene where an imposter
posing as Nei appears in the medic tent
area alongside the likes of Sakura it's
honestly an interesting rule to the
story to help add some variety while
also giving Sakura more to do which is
awesome it's a rather simple angle with
a lot of consequence that really changes
up the formula from a more combat
Centric approach to a more Thriller
based strategic one honestly I thought
this was one of the coolest ideas in in
the arc so far and very creative trying
to weed out the spice in their midst
really helped to make this battle feel
much less shallow than it otherwise had
felt up until now it's a plot line
that's completely different and
demonstrates front and center the
variance and application of the
different forms of Jutsu Among Us the
rag versus Naruto scene was a really
cool initial Skirmish to show some of
Naruto's abilities in his I don't know
Spirit State I don't know the name of
that I need to look it
up the ninetail chakra form and
furthermore this a great job of
reaffirming his convictions and points
of view to us as readers claiming that
his father made absolutely no mistakes
when he believed in what he Naruto was
able to do and just when things are
getting good we get another flashback
this time for Killer B I do like that it
demonstrated the relationship between
Killer B and the neag and I really liked
his interaction with Naruto's dad and
how that informs his decision at the
very end forcing Naruto to prove himself
to him by making him Dodge his fastest
attack it really speaks to the phrase
real gold doesn't fear trial by fire
therefore if Naruto is the savior he
espouses to be then nothing not even the
fastest in the land could stand in his
way and it
doesn't look I'm willing to concede
right off the bat that this probably has
an explanation that someone much more
informed about the series can answer but
when this dude inoi called upon Naruto
for a quick hello I honestly got
confused was this something that they
were always able to do naturally a level
of suspension of disbelief is required
and I have applied that to the legions
of people they had been in communication
with on the battlefield in my mind it
was conceivable that they had arranged
some sort of frequency or item to be
held or something to differentiate them
from everyone else otherwise they'd just
be able to talk all the time to anyone
they wanted which would be by extension
make all the times people go missing in
the series make a lot less sense but
then he calls up Naruto to fill him in
on the plot Exposition he needs and
pieces out quickly afterwards while
Naruto is conceivably a great distance
away moving at incredibly high speeds
and wasn't part of the military's plan
at all Beyond staying put in a hole in
the ground hiding why wasn't this used
to try and communicate with Sasuke right
after he left why wasn't it used
whenever Naruto went missing or when
Sakura went missing is it like Dragon
Ball when people hide their Chi or in
this case chakra it's like blocking
their number from being called and if
that's the case did Sasuke just not use
any chakra for the 3 years he was
training again I'm not sure if this is
actually an issue or if I'm just missing
something if I am missing something let
me know in the comments down below
respectively I'm I really don't know
there must be something I'm missing here
that's quite substantial and I hope
someone can clear this up for me because
right now it seems really
weird earlier in the story we were
presented once again with gar on the
front lines awaiting the arrival of four
resurrected Shinobi and we were told one
of them is G's father I was excited for
gar to play a large role in the story
given his position and the Mystery
surrounding his origin still largely
unknown to us outside of a flashback
here and there but once we eventually
did catch back up with him we got made
maybe two or three chapters exploring
his origin with yet more flashbacks and
to be honest the flashback was
inoffensive and worked well enough but
the entire thing felt like it was
massively rushed to me and due to the
absurd amount this AR relies on
flashbacks to conclude story beats when
I saw the black Pages emerge yet again
for this section's flashback I started
to roll my eyes unfortunately again not
because flashbacks are bad but because
the way that they are using this Arc now
is very tedious I can predict where
things are going to go narratively it
now takes all the suspense out of the
occasion and feels like it's kishimoto's
way of Expediting the process of telling
these minor stories and it's frustrating
because again like choji I really like
gar as a character and a lot of these
ideas here seem like they could have
been much more effective if presented
with a little more pre-planning like
rock Le Choi and so many others I wish I
got to see more of gar in this series
but we really haven't gotten a chance to
see him that much up until now and so to
make up for that kishima uses these
flashbacks to create this sense of a
more detailed and comprehensive
backstory to all of these interactions
however in doing so this often it just
feels like he's making stuff up on the
spot in a halfhazard fashion and I'm
sure he isn't also and this is just a
minor nitpick but I just thought it was
funny chapter 548 is entitled Naruto
versus Itachi again I was excited
because that's a pretty impressive title
but 98% of the chapter is about the
resolution to G's conflict only in the
last last two pages of the chapter do
Naruto and Itachi even appear and in
those two final Pages they don't even
speak to each other why call it Naruto
versus Itachi there's nothing about it
that remotely shows these two in
Conflict okay okay rant over got to
chill the story surrounding this
character does continue somewhat as he
contributes greatly in aiding Naruto and
the takedown of one of the resurrected
KAG and while I still love G and thought
his contributions throughout this Arc
had some great ideas behind them I just
found that the manner with which they
were presented to be a little
unpredictable formulaic and boring sight
of things regretfully Itachi on the
other hand was the first sign I got that
things were turning themselves around in
this story and boy did they his meeting
with Naruto is less about them fighting
each other but more of them coming to
understand one another and Itachi
feeling comfortable enough to entrust
Naruto with his brother the scene is
filled with a lot of cool stuff I
particularly enjoyed the notion that
Itachi left a Raven as a contingency
within Naruto based on what he suspected
Sasuke to do after he died I mean that's
a 4D level chess move If Ever I did see
one and totally something I'd expect
from someone like Itachi to do and to
that end I really like the psychological
angle he took when Naruto insisted on
shouldering all of this responsibility
however between this Itachi stuff and
the next hype moment I will say that I
wasn't all too enthused or entertained
with the numerous cutaways to various
different former KAG now resurrected for
the purposes of conflict titles on their
own don't really mean anything to me and
if I don't understand who someone is on
any level prior to my meeting them
convincing me to care in the middle of
the very battle they were participating
in is like trying to convince your date
to go out with you while you're in the
middle of said date it's kind of putting
the cart before the horse there that
said I did enjoy the short scene Naruto
shares with the third R K's almost
impenetrable defenses cleverly utilizing
his own durability and power against
himself it's such a Naruto strategy
blunt but effective and well paneled to
my ad by ishimoto with all of that said
as we Flash from one area of conflict to
the next the pace starts to Quicken when
the main point of Interest
arrives Yia Mata arrives on the scene in
a resurrected body and decides that it's
time to start making things really fun
again I'm serious from this point on I
pretty much loved everything it's like
the story went from a 4 out of 10 to an
eight in a matter of a couple of
chapters with some of them even reaching
as high as 99.5's later in my estimation
and I absolutely will be talking more
about that later on I really like that
this fight along with many of the others
required Naruto to find a balance in
sharing the burden of this battle at
hand particularly within himself as I've
mentioned before the internal struggle
for Naruto contending with the fox
Spirit has been looming in the
background of most every dangerous
encounter he's engaged with either as a
risk he's needed to contend with or the
very cause for that very conflict that's
occurring in that moment the fight with
uchia Madara has a powerful air to it
the likes of which I haven't felt since
Itachi for some reason I wasn't really
expecting him to prop up in the story
like this but in hindsight it makes a
lot of sense considering what we've seen
thus far from this story with all the
resurrected Warriors but what makes this
fight scene all the more intimidating is
the fox spirit's willingness to
earnestly help Naruto in battle just
because he's sort of intimidated by mad
potentially even fearful it's absolutely
a turning point in the story and one
that elevates the antagonist here in
ways that we have never seen before from
this scene there are a lot of cool
moments obviously the meteor is a big
one that comes to mind but one that
stands out to me is the unification of
all five kagay in the effort against MAA
and furthermore I really like how they
all sort of had their own roles with the
obvious being cady's healing abilities
acting as support and raag acting as I
don't know the muscle once this whole
thing kicks off and a couple of them
fire attacks towards MAA only for him to
be unimpressed and say things like it's
not even worth absorbing for him then to
get absolutely decked hard by the reag
it was massively entertaining and
cathartic it's no longer a battle to
protect Naruto but instead want to
protect each other Villages that were
once at each other's throats thanks to a
common enemy have gained a sense of
solidarity and Community something they
wish to now fight for it's
brilliant and I honestly flipped out
with what this led to the best part of
the Ark this is in my opinion without
question the best part of this Arc by a
country mile so much so that it almost
completely makes up for the more boring
Parts I've experienced in this story
with a truly powerful moment coming by
way of Naruto communicating his values
and intentions effectively to the
spirits he's trying to reach most
specifically to the one that has been a
source of Torment for him his entire
life at numerous times during the
section I lost my Collective and
could not stop reading and on top of all
of that from a visual perspective this
is the best the manga has looked in God
knows how long while the Moa stuff was
fantastic and very enjoyable it's in
that exact moment from when Naruto's
perspective shifts from the five kagay
that I ended up getting one of the
biggest shocks the series has ever given
me
he headbutts him straight away
and by the way this is my new favorite
panel from the manga it's awesome and
super surprising with just the right
amount of silly with these two
characters having always been separated
in some shape or form to see them Clash
together so suddenly and
unconventionally it actually got me to
recoil in my chair and Shout out and
draw upon me the watchful judging eyes
of my wife it's okay I explained the
situation in the story and she patted me
on the head before leaving for her Ms
and N but look at Naruto expression on
this manga page it's just so kinetic I I
love it MOA reveals that he's someone by
the name of Toby in this scene great
great great and also nobody reaffirming
his conviction in achieving his goal of
effectively brainwashing the entire
world to peace and with this group of
seemingly zombify Ginger Riki carrying
out M's Mission be and Naruto the only
remaining Ginger Riki left have their
backs up against a
wall see what I mean about this section
just being awesome and the artwork r
reading this moment of the manga is
amazing too again more terrific artwork
from Kishimoto and even more surprises
that I never saw coming and naturally
when these two show up to fight against
mad I lost it again we've suddenly left
all of these fights I never really had
any investment in and now we're finally
focusing on some of the most hype
moments I've come across in a long long
while within this series and something I
need to make clear here too while there
are some truly breathtaking moments
depicted in this section with regards to
its action this still isn't my favorite
part of the material contained in this
section and furthermore the material
that I think is the best has little to
do at all with
action the Journey of Naruto across this
entire story has been about how he
himself has been impacted by the
circumstances of his own birth he's been
shunned ostracized and bullied for
effectively being a vessel for something
he never accepted in the first place to
Naruto he was in a horribly unfortunate
in a situation because there was
something wrong with him and when he did
eventually find out I could well imagine
there being a level of resentment
attached to that too a profound feeling
of why me or there's this monster inside
of me and now I have to pay for it and
to a varying degrees some more extreme
than others this has unfortunately been
the case and on this long and sprawling
quest to achieve his dreams he's also
had to search for who he is made evident
through interactions with gar nagato and
others Naruto has expressed that had
things developed differently in his life
he could have been consumed by hatred
much like these guys could have been too
the fox Spirit itself has shown up in
the story a great number of times at
first as a monster shocking and scaring
the young Naruto and over the course of
his life through misdirection and in
some ways taking advantage of the young
man's greatest insecurities this Spirit
has tried to free himself from the
prison by leveraging the hate inside
Naruto's psyche however thanks to some
support from his friends mentors and
indeed even his parents Naruto has not
only managed to become a well-rounded
individual but one that has managed to
overcome his met orical inner demon with
only one thing left in his way his
literal inner demon this Arc made a
curious choice of adding considerably
more opportunities for Kurama the fox
spirit inside Naruto to characterize
himself Beyond simply being an
antagonistic monster and truthfully at
first I thought this was a little too
fast or premature however the necessary
precedent for this section had already
been laid thanks to killerby and his
Buu's relationship and as the story
progresses we come to learn that much
like Naruto Kurama has much like all the
other other beu severe trust issues when
it comes to dealing with humans and with
good reason there are some cute
references to Dragon Ball and Journey to
the West with The Monkey King too but
why this works so effectively is that
what convinces Kurama isn't anything
Naruto says much like everything in his
life it's never been his words that have
carried him to where he is today it's
the actions he takes and In This Moment
Naruto proves himself to the fox by
freeing his fellow beu in a selfless
effort however now in desperate need of
chakra Kurama finally makes the decision
that he seemingly never has
[Music]
[Applause]
before this looked awesome holy wow okay
so the visual here I love it having
spent a considerable amount of time
reminiscing over Naruto's life there's
such a wonderful contrast between this
the fox Spirit state that he's in
currently and say this this weird demon
mode that he was in pror once a child
with something deep inside him
scratching and clawing their way out
fighting over his body and now a freed
Spirit fighting alongside Naruto in
harmony I'm going to leave this here for
now but my overall thoughts on this
particular choice is that of awe and
curiosity now that the fox has been
freed does that mean that the end game
here is to eventually release all the
beu back into the wild to live freely
again or is the end game going to be
something along the lines of what Killer
B has with his Buu as a standard moving
forward it's strange and that's not even
to make mention of this MAA or Toby
[Music]
situation as I mentioned when we last
left off Naruto had effectively achieved
Super Saiyan became the Avatar and
formed the perfect bond with his Digimon
right in the nick of time the visuals in
the manga looked stunning and we finally
scratched and clawed ourselves out of
that rot I agonized my way through in
the last video and I'm happy to report
that I enjoy this portion of the arc so
so much more than its middle in my last
video I had a growing issue with the
sheer volume of scenes and how
uninterested I was in them however with
this climax Sasuke re-enters the fry all
the while we focus on three specific
conflicts all with three different
flavors thankfully conflict number one
Naruto versus Toby this was the battle
that made this Arc a joy to read once
again for me last week there's such a
strong sense of stakes culmination and
profound occasion Within this battle
alone that I'd honestly be happy if this
was all we got as many of you know I'm
always a big fan of techniques that
impose their own unique tensions in a
fight and this is no different when it's
announced that Naruto only has 5 minutes
with the newly acquired fox form I could
feel my attention focus in on the battle
even more and this is great because in
the early stages of this fight Kishimoto
ensures that Naruto's character remains
consistent by having him not give up on
or take out the remaining beeu thanks to
his interaction with son I can't believe
that's his name Goku he knows that he
can save all of these entities he wants
to free them Naruto will not compromise
on his ethics or morals and it's
decisions like this narratively that
make for much more dramatic
circumstances it feels true to the
characters and so as a result it feels
less like an author dragging his
fictional puppets around an artificial
stage and more so a believable decision
that aligns with a specific character's
mindset and philosophy which makes
things all the more exciting and real
capping all of that off with some
outrageously brilliant manga
illustration and paneling to depict the
B bomb from Naruto it feels fittingly
huge and I'll admit I was just sort of
sitting there admiring them for a few
minutes too this is all to say that the
beginning of this fight I loved there's
a tremendous sense of unity and fate
associated with the particular flashback
to the bews when they were young and
Naruto seems to be that connective
tissue and while all of this was great
it's made all the better thanks to the
inclusion of other characters and their
respective
conflicts conflict number two the five
KAG versus the reincarnated uchia mad I
think much of what I like about this
fight comes by way of Lady tsunade's
contribution particularly when the first
hokage's image Hashi Rama is used for
intimidation purposes by MAA pitting the
image of her grandfather against her
perceived own lack of accomplishments he
belittles Tad's abilities and efforts
and CES that there was only ever one who
was worthy of fighting him the First
Hokage her grandfather it's a tried
andrue cliche in Shonen and storytelling
in general but effective nevertheless
when the target of this ridicule Rises
to the occasion proving that the words
lobbied against her wrong there's some
really nice tunat shine here too with
the focus remaining on teamwork Above
All Else and finally conflict number
three Sasuke and Itachi versus Kabuto
it's difficult to assert which of these
three fights is my favorite as it
constantly changed from moment to moment
each one offering more narrative
goodness digest than the last but one I
found myself much more invested in than
I was otherwise anticipating was
Kabuto's altercation with Itachi and
Sasuke Kabuto's sort of just been there
from the beginning he's always been a
means to an end for the main bad guy Oro
chimaru I found him interesting from a
utilitarian standpoint but when it came
to him specifically I never found myself
asking the question who he was or where
did he come from and I think that's part
of what makes Kabuto's progression to
this point so appealing and interesting
to me watching him slowly developed more
and more nefarious Tendencies more power
and more influence as the story trudged
on forward was enriching and it all came
to a head in this section through an
Illuminating flashback that helps to put
us as an audience into the right from a
mind to view him finally and that's not
even to make mention of
[Applause]
[Music]
this this was a really cool idea to play
around with on behalf of Kishimoto
Resurrection when it was initially
brought up was something I genuinely
thought was interesting it was a chance
to explore a lot of what if scenarios
that we otherwise wouldn't get to
explore I did get a little bogg down
last week when the story focused harshly
on one aspect of the Resurrection angle
which got very very old quickly
thankfully however this is something
entirely knew and it involved another
one of the main characters instead of
seeing two people duke it out we now
have Sasuke having been granted the
chance to actually talk to his brother
again to potentially alleviate some of
the emotional baggage he's carrying I
mean like him or hate him Sasuke is
still just a kid that's been through
hell and back I'm surprised he even
knows which way is up the moment in time
that Sasuke's eyes meet the movement of
Itachi zooming through the forest on his
way to Kabuto facilitated some of my
favorite illustrative and paneling work
from Kishimoto there tremendous
commitment to allow this moment and
indeed us as an audience the space and
time necessary to soak this snapshot in
time in there's also no explosions or
anything dangerous it's simply a younger
brother thinking he's seeing a ghost
when his older brother zooms on by with
Kishimoto switching from current time to
flashback panels back to present day it
helps to perfectly capture exactly what
Sasuke is thinking as he begins to give
Chase it's brilliant and brings to light
the potential regret confusion and
amazement Sasuke has for how things are
left between them this is a really
intense scene both from a dialogue and
action perspective as I wasn't entirely
convinced I knew where SAS would land in
terms of aligning himself and while that
made for some intense moments it also
helped me relax and enjoy the wholesome
tag team these two brothers eventually
became and in terms of callbacks Kabuto
can now tap into snake Dragon Sage Mode
I'm really glad that Naruto and Jah
weren't the only ones to tap into this
reservoir of power and now that we know
how this technique or form Works
Kishimoto can focus on the choreography
and drama of the situation it doesn't
need to be explained to us and it's
really refreshing to watch someone else
utilize this technique after so long
with a different Spirit it goes a long
way in helping this world feel all the
more believable it's great world
building so okay enough being around the
bush let's talk about Kabuto's flashback
he was a kid that started from quite
literally nothing he had no memories or
anything and is now one of the most
dangerous people in the known world he
was saved from the ruins of battle and
loved immediately danzo and Orochimaru
manipulated the situation taking his
mother away on a mission for the
foundation and Kabuto into Shinobi
training 5 years in he kills his adopted
mother inadvertently and she didn't even
recognize him due to the really screwed
up brainwashing practices that honestly
make way more sense that I'm comfortable
with admitting last week I know I was
the there is way too many flashbacks guy
but I sincerely thought that this
flashback in and of itself was very
effective and made me care a lot more
about Kabuto as a character he's been a
recurring one for quite some time now
and finally having context for his
actions and the philosophy behind his
connection to Orochimaru was refreshing
the flashback itself is quite long with
a fully fleshed out beginning middle and
end it's very much its own
self-contained short story in fact and
by virtue of all of that set itself
apart in my eyes from almost all of the
other short and throwaway flashbacks in
the prior preliminary matchups during my
last video Kabuto wants to feel the void
in his life that he's felt since
childhood he wants to be someone and
through that he's found a profound
jealousy with those that can identify as
IIA someone that can possess a moniker
with which they can ident identify
themselves as someone rather than what
he believes he might be no one it's
creepy and also very sad it's really
interesting and then we get to the
isanami technique Mamu I'm coming to
bargain and okay okay okay before anyone
types it I know Kishimoto did this first
but I couldn't help but laugh when I saw
that scene the similarities were too
similar that said I wasn't laughing in a
mocking way but just in that I was
having fun with the moment it's a really
cool idea the technique itself offering
up a sacrifice and specifically praying
upon the very aspect of Kabuto's
personality that has caused him to be so
dangerous it's a really cool Visual and
one that screwed my head up on first
reading but volume 62 hits like a train
It wraps up the conclusion to Itachi and
Sasuke's story quite beautifully while
also providing a justification for
Itachi's horrible actions that
ultimately became the motivating factors
behind Sasuke's entire Journey this is a
world altering moment in his young life
and the way it's presented in the manga
is stunning to see unfold there are a
lot of real really quiet moments in this
volume following the collapse of
Kabuto's edot tensei one that especially
caught me off guard was Dan's impr
prompt to reuniting with Tsunade in the
middle of battle to protect her in these
situations I found that less is more you
can present the most climactic battles
I've ever seen and demonstrate
characters performing death defying
Feats of unimaginable skill and finesse
but all of that will never match the
feeling of a single page spread of a
brother reaffirming his love and pride
in his younger sibling or The Haunting
white background when two lost souls
finally find each other once again and
okay I need to take a few minutes and
talk about what happens from chapter 595
onwards concerning the battle between
the union of Kakashi G and Naruto versus
Toby it is amazing and I try not to use
that word lightly but it was a moment
that had a clear and well orchestrated
buildup which was delivered in a
phenomenally engaging exciting and
mysterious fashion okay so this might
seem like it's coming from Left Field a
bit but this reveal reminds me of all
the reasons why I loved early Sherlock
on the BBC and why I really grew
disinterested in it with the later
Seasons when you're writing a mystery
story Above All Else the most important
component to its narrative creation is
providing the reader or viewers the
chance to successfully piece the story
together for themselves without a reveal
latter seasons of Sherlock seem to focus
Less on the mystery and more so on the
individual characters opting for a story
driven specifically by drama and less so
about the mystery itself which I mean is
fine if you like that sort of thing I
didn't but that's just my taste the
reason why the first episode of Sherlock
the study in pink worked so well for me
was due to the specific narrative
decision made to Anchor it around the
answer to a given mystery during the
90-minute runtime of that very episode
we as viewers are presented a series of
murders with the circumstances they all
took place within furthermore Sherlock
at one point even asks himself some
pointed questions quote who do we trust
even though we don't know them who
passed es unnoticed wherever they go who
hunts in the middle of a crowd the
questions are said aloud to us to hear
intentionally and they beg us to try and
solve it for ourselves and so the point
of all of these inclusions is to place
Us in the mind of the individual who's
solving the mystery and when it's
eventually revealed or the person us who
pieces it together eventually does so
there's a tremendous feeling of
catharsis as a result both for the
character and indeed us reading or
watching we feel this way we feel the
aha moment if you will because we have
ourselves to blame for solving this
mystery it's an achievement this
naturally builds investment into the
story you're interacting with and
furthermore builds respect between you
and the character who uncovered the
truths and this is exactly what happened
here with Kakashi and Obito uchia
Kakashi throughout this Series has been
one of the most observant and patient
Shinobi we've come across despite
Naruto's massive surge of power in
recent times Kakashi still manages to
believably provide utility to the
emerging conflicts in ways only he can
particularly in this instance as the
team tried to scratch Toby even once in
an effort to figure out who he really is
and ultimately to formulate a plan of
effective attack in doing so Kakashi's
blade scratches the mask of Toby and in
that instance the ball drops and Kakashi
understands everything about how Toby's
Jutsu works and moreover who this
individual actually is and the mechanism
with which this story unveils that is
utterly masterful to say the least and
might I say extremely elegant and simple
Kashi was the only one who could have
made this connection successfully
because he's the only other person who
has that same ocular power what a reveal
and as he rationalizes this Theory
Landing successful attacks might do
Kishimoto himself panels the eyes of
Kakashi and Toby side by side visually
communicating exactly who this person
actually is before it's revealed giving
us the chance to figure it out for
ourselves and there's tons of stuff that
happened earlier in the story to allude
to this very conclusion too and then we
get the flashback jeez okay for a story
that leans fire too heavily on
flashbacks this still hit like a train
which speaks to the level of execution
this reveal is operating with we've
already seen how Kakashi received his
eyes and so this flashback instead
focuses on conveying to us the humanity
the childishness the hopes the dreams
the insecurities and the early life of
Obito himself drawing specific
similarities to Naruto 2 and kimono does
this entirely without any dialogue it's
beautifully handled with the reveal of
who is indeed Beneath The Mask cut to
the core of Kakashi as seen in his
expression despite this being spoiled
for me the magnitude of my enjoyment
horror and excitement I had while
reading this was remarkably high and
remember when I said that volume 62 was
really good well volume 63 is even
better and might even be the best in the
series to say I flew through this volume
is an understatement of the century the
volume is filled with either massive
reveals or extended and viciously
interesting flashbacks the likes of
which determine the course of action of
the remainder of the story it's
extremely pivotal and by the way when I
saw uchia Madara as some old guy in the
origin of bita's story I was like wait
what so I guess not all the surprises of
this section were lost on me after all I
think more than anything else what this
volume managed to convey to me is just
how much work Kishimoto has put into The
Narrative of this story for this
conclusion to involve so many different
characters from so many different
backgrounds and generations each with
their own Rich histories philosophies
and motivations all thoroughly fleshed
out by the way for all of that to come
together and then make sense is one of
the most difficult and cathartic magic
tricks a writer can pull off and for me
someone who was spoiled on one of the
foundational reveals contained within
this section to actually enjoy it this
immensely should stand as a testament to
the writing Acumen of Masashi Kishimoto
in this instance it's totally incredible
the way everything ties back together in
this scene is a feast for the eyes and
mind watching as Kakashi's hero turns
out to be the villain of the Cent and
then Naruto throws his words back at
Kakashi only to regain his resolve it
makes me remember that there are three
generations in this fight for if you
count the KAG and oh jeez okay I didn't
even mention the entrance MAA made
despite the resurrection Jitsu being
released he managed to remain and not
just that in the middle of this scene
between Naruto and orito he shows up
before the scene switches to the blooded
Heap he left the five KAG in there's
been so much time dedicated to these
villains that I honestly am just so damn
excited to see how this thing progresses
I'm all in though totally invested these
are the best collection of chapters in
the entire series easily you might have
to Wade through a lot of mid shown in
the second act of this story but holy
is it worth it the battle that
rages on between these two parties is
utterly nuts to the nth degree far
beyond anything I've seen in this series
visually incredible and narratively
captivating watching Naruto Kurama and
Kakashi manag to find a way to survive
amidst all of this chaos is crazy to see
unfold and then Kurama runs out of juice
he needs time to regain his chakra and
what's more is the situation worsens the
t-tailed beu is released and is
ludicrously powerful it's now starting
to look like Naruto and everyone is done
for
[Applause]
when it had been so long since we
touched base with these guys I honestly
totally forgot about them again
brilliant pacing by Kishimoto here and
what's more is their presence here Works
double duty with them not only serving a
utility and buying Naruto more time to
charge but to also signify the world
that Naruto and indeed all of them are
fighting for thematically one of unity
and peace they are as their name
suggests Allied Forces flying in the
face of Obito and indeed MAA it's
honestly difficult for me to articulate
and to even accurately capture the
excitement I had while reading this week
to help put it into perspective normally
I read some here and there as I go about
my week while writing as I go this with
this one this week I read through six
volumes in a single day and I also wrote
a lot of this and it's felt like nothing
there's just so many interesting and fun
Dynamics at play and they all center
around one ongoing force of evil MAA and
Obito's mission to brainwash and enslave
the world and there are sacrifices too
in this that brought a tear to my eye
Nei wasn't a character I shared a lot of
time with in this story unfortunately
but his sacrifice stood in line with his
One Shining Moment in the series I did
enjoy throwing a quote back to narator
that he really needed to hear from a
time which made me realize just how far
this journey has taken me and then we
came to shikaku he had has been a
character that's contributed one of the
most emotional sequences in the story
and one that was helped immeasurably by
the anime way back when he's never been
in the spotlight for long and he's
almost always been a supporting
character and I think it's for that very
reason that this particular moment here
his sacrifice hit me so powerfully he's
a terrifically written father type
character unafraid to do what he needs
to in order to give his son his family
and the Next Generation a future he
believes in this really got me and in
triumphant fashion it's this final
parting Gambit that leads to one of the
most incredible unifications of power
facilitated by some of the most unlikely
of sources that gives them this chance
it's it's
stunning I just realized something uh I
totally forgot to mention something
super important so remember Kabuto right
well through him Sasuke brought
Orochimaru back but why to what end you
might be asking well Sasuke wants to
know the truth and has some questions
for Orochimaru specifically and so long
story short oo chimaru might not have
the answers but he has taken Sasuke to
kenoa in the middle of a war to help him
answer some of these questions these
questions being what is a village and
what are Shinobi and when I saw what
Orochimaru did to answer these questions
I was super excited the dude resurrects
all four Fallen Hokage of the past
everyone from matato all the way to the
very first Hokage hashirama and getting
to see all of these characters interact
with each other for the very first time
was h hilarious exciting and super
interesting I felt myself hanging on
each and every word exchanged however
after a while the fun and games needed
to come to a close and a much more
serious story and response from
hashirama followed the ignition for this
conversation to actually take place
wasn't necessarily Sasuke's request as
pointed out in the story by Orochimaru
himself despite the second Lord being
the creator of the ensei technique
hashirama is the only one capable of
terminating it and thus the decision was
his to make this is the very first first
time we've gotten to actually see how
characters interact with hashirama
specifically we've heard gr tell of his
strength and presence through his former
adversaries but never straight from the
horse's mouth and I love how candid and
approachable this person is again his
temperament strikes me oddly similar to
that of even Naruto and fittingly the
very reason he's chosen to have this
conversation over helping his community
and the world is due to one observation
he's made if he leaves he believes
Sasuke will become the next Modera which
makes the introduction of his flashback
all the more epic not for its action but
because this could be a Prelude to the
conflict that rests on the horizon
between Naruto standing in for hashirama
and Sasuke standing in for mad as
hashirama remarks to himself numerous
times in this volume always conflict no
matter what the era the flashback in
question that takes place is by far the
most detailed and longest in the series
taking up more than 60% of volume 65 it
is a fascinating read comprehensively
telling the story of both mad and
hashi's Origins where their respective
points of view stem from and what led
them to defect from one another and it's
that slow progression to embrace in the
darkness that this story does a
phenomenal job of conveying and making
sense of beginning as naive and
optimistic children with plans for a
peaceful future eventually becomes a war
of ideology a war where a vision of a
pessimistic reality stands in opposition
to honest optimism for the future one
where the teachings and ultimately the
hatred from both sides pass on down the
poison that ultimately leads to the
downfall of madra and on a long enough
timeline Canoa and the rest of the world
it's such a compelling story where two
children turned Brothers turn sworn
enemies have to contend with the reality
that they are faced with that in life
there are no clear-cut Solutions no
matter how honest or well-intentioned
you might think you're being I think
alongside the flashback with Obito and
MAA this flashback is the best the
series has demonstrated and within which
I found myself oddly attached to the
character of hashirama and even very
sympathetic towards ma someone I never
thought I would feel any sympathy for
but in in the end that's exactly what
the story has made me feel that fighting
for a world where children no longer
have to deal with the looming nightmare
of war is worth fighting for it strips
them of their lives their innocence and
in moa's case their light leaving only
Darkness behind time and again with each
subsequent Hokage signaling their own
unique shortcomings to one another one
inable thought comes to the mind of
hashirama yet again and at the same time
Sasuke is left to decide the fate of his
group and indeed his village ultimately
he decides to head towards the
battlefield for alongside each and every
one of these Fame Shinobi of the past
each flood on their own rights hashirama
once again reaffirms something in his
mind that there may always be conflict
no matter the era but this time it will
be the end of
Wars Kakashi is just cool okay
there I said it he's also got the best
design I just love seeing how Kishimoto
draws the dude but anyways Kakashi noo
end up fighting and arguing ironically
in a different reality they say that
most great drama comes from people
speaking in rooms without story these
scenarios have no meaning and therefore
lack the qualities that compel people to
listen one stripped of all the bells and
whistles but when you can put two
wellestablished characters in a room
together with conflicting ideologies
then there are few things more
compelling than that the conversation
between Kakashi and Alito is just that a
compelling conflict of ideology and it
makes me feel all the more sympathetic
for the lost obido and so much more
supportive of the Resolute Kakashi
there's a portion of this conversation
that succinctly breaks breaks down the
exact argument here for Kakashi he says
and I quote the hole in one's heart gets
filled by others around you but people
won't flock to someone who abandons the
memory of his friends and gives up on
the world that won't help fill the hole
in your heart and people don't help
those who run and do nothing so long as
you don't give up there will be
salvation this is a superbly worded
quote that strikes at the heart of this
conversation the main character of
Naruto himself self and indeed most of
the major conflicts throughout this
entire series and fittingly as if
symbolic of this resolve Kashi is
vouching for Naruto's and the rest of
the Shinobi Allied Forces resolve is
finally
rewarded this is the part of the video
where I devolve into making nothing but
childish sounds because all of this is
just so damn cool like just when you
think things couldn't get even more
awesome they do with within seconds of
each other mind
you
I swear when Sasuke showed up
and the first thing he said was that he
was going to become hakaj right next to
Naruto maybe because of the buildup or
the tension I was feeling at the time
but I just burst out laughing I was so
excited to see cell7 reunited for the
very first time in what feels like
hundreds of chapters fighting alongside
each other for their Village's wellbeing
so much of what transpires from this
point on is wall to- wall or should I
say page to page action It's A Feast for
the eyes and even made me someone that's
only recently picked up Naruto feel an
incredible amount of nostalgia and
everything just comes together in the
best of ways during this section
Shikamaru takes over from his dad in
formulating a strategy heck Sakura makes
it known that she knows how to fight
fight using the diamond on her forehead
like Tsunade which I wasn't expecting
but again totally loved there are so
many interesting little dynamics that
play exploding around the environment
it's here that Naruto as a story truly
basks in the time it's taken throughout
the series in building up its characters
everything from something innocuous like
kba looking for attention in becoming
hak to something dastardly like maa's
shifting demeanor when Kashi Rama shows
up this is the result and man is it
spectacular we even get a recreation of
one of the early illustrations by
Kishimoto with cell 7 standing front and
center showing the full scope of how far
everyone has come in such a long time
span I just know there's going to be so
much more conflict between these three
particularly Naruto and Sasuke so much
so that I'm just going to enjoy this
brief interlude in the violence and
fighting because things are about to get
really really bad for
[Music]
everyone
volume 67 to say that I was hyped to
return to this story would be an
understatement while the arc itself was
extremely long and boring in parts
around the middle by the time the final
pieces started falling into place around
65 to 70% of the way through the arc
everything sort of clicked I found
myself feverishly ingesting volume after
volume until I had to stop for fear of
writing a video that was way too long
Naruto has been a terrific story however
not one without moments I felt it slip
in terms of holding my interest this is
normal however now that I'm on what
feels like the home stretch I can't
imagine this manga ends in any other way
than satisfying in my mind Kishimoto has
already done the hard part he's after
creating a broad and complicated World
filled with Nuance characters each with
their own justifications cultures that
back those ideologies and stories the
leg work and Exposition necessary to
believably create the these interactions
has already been done and he's even
managed to bring all of these characters
together for a conclusion I am immensely
happy with in other words so far I'm
loving it the cover of this volume sees
Naruto teaming up with his father this
section deals with a lot of interesting
strategies I had a great time with for
instance last week we went from bad to
worse as goito became something entirely
different channeling the strength of the
t-tailed Beast and due to this we have
virtually no idea what this individual
is capable of and so when the strongest
and most experienced on the battlefield
the for Hokage chose to use themselves
as resurrect capable Pawns in order to
analyze the strengths and movements of
this target obido I'll admit that I kind
of gigged out a bit it was a great idea
and this volume is filled with moments
to geek out or get excited over Sasuke
getting to team up with Naruto is one
that I found fantastically enjoyable
with Kishimoto demonstrating this fact
as the fight progressed through
interesting layouts and Page spreads and
okay at this point with Sasuke I'm still
getting the feeling that this isn't so
much a reconciliation but more so a
temporary Alliance given the nature of
the occasion but hey I got to take what
I can get Kishimoto utilizes a lot of
natural tension building techniques here
also to help escalate the scope of the
battle and the consequences associated
with it my favorite being his decision
to Grant obido the power to effectively
nullify the ensei which translates to
that sequence we got to enjoy with the
former Hokage now cannot be performed
without consequence rip Naruto's dad's
arm I guess and speaking of matato I
think my favorite part about this volume
and what it tries to do can be seen
through kishimoto's decision in how he
depicts manato internal monologue as it
happens failure is a word matato uses a
lot in this Arc and indeed this volume
throughout the story from the beginning
through to this moment matato has been a
character spoken of extremely highly
he's touted as being virtuous Noble
powerful heroic a savior much like
hashirama despite only being recently
deceased the deification of his
character by The Village he worked for
is abundantly clear and yet Kishimoto
feels it important in this moment to let
us know that even someone like he can
feel like a failure and the same is true
for hashirama the way these characters
have been built up as Gods over the
entire series for this Arc to humanized
them has been incredibly effective for
its themes and messaging we as an
audience are made to feel the full
spectrum of negative emotions both Hashi
raama and matato feel for what they have
failed to do and prevent during their
tenure as Hokage feeling responsible for
all of this happening and by association
the destruction of the area and its
people and I like this because as we are
placed into the shoes of the onetime
Godlike figure through his eyes we get
to see the Magnificent answer to all of
these worries and questions in his son
Naruto oh also the fact that Naruto and
Kurama were able to make use of the
other half of the fox inside manato made
sense surprised me and made for some
awesome moments and shots I mean overall
this volume was great there's a
tremendous amount to love in it and it
continues the great climax I pray so
much last week in natural ways and
what's more is the next volume is even
better volume 68 during this section I
couldn't help but draw my own mental
parallels between Naruto and hashirama
and indeed Sasuke and mad forcing me to
contemplate questions like will history
repeat itself is Sasuke going to become
madra in this generation well not if
Naruto has anything to say about it this
Arc is enjoying quite a lot of payoff
for sure however what ties this complex
web of conflict cause and effect
together is Naruto and the Infectious
spirit inspires his team with there's
this scene with Shikamaru and I swear it
gave me chills to see this dude go from
someone I hardly noticed early on due to
his inactivity and lack of desire to get
involved transforming because of Naruto
into this next level tactician ready to
pick himself up to contribute despite
him virtually having no energy was so
damn uplifting and in this instance it's
all down to
Naruto this quote from Ninetales for me
touches ever so slightly and one of the
most significant pillars of Naruto's
character and one that I think is not
only Central to this battle but indeed
the entire story this is a battle that
sees Sasuke his friends and indeed now
these beu all side with Naruto to Rally
with him in one last final effort to try
and take down Obito to stop his pursuit
in performing the infinite suu yomi to
save the world I'm not sure if this is a
prominent talking point people discuss
in this fandom but I have heard some
folks talk about Naruto having an unfair
Advantage compared to others in the
story that the fact that he has had this
beu inside of him has offered him a
unique privilege perhaps an unfair one
thus detracting from how some people
might feel about Naruto and while I can
see where they're coming from with the
fox providing him a near Unlimited
Supply of chakra and healing Factor thus
leading to a lot of his success in the
story I think if you came away from this
tale with that Outlook it feels at least
to me reading at this point in the story
that you might have missed the entire
point of this section and indeed a core
part of Naruto's character development
as this Series has progressed there's no
secret that this story particularly in
this moment is trying to glorify the
attributes and virtues Naruto is
brandishing however something that's
important to remember is that a central
through line of this Arc and story has
been that very easily Naruto could have
turned out exactly like Obito too which
is why Obito is seen trying to reach or
corrupt Naruto at every turn in this Arc
but more broadly understanding this I
think is intrinsic to understanding and
indeed appreciating Naruto as a
character it's why he shows empathy
towards practically everyone and wants
to reach them if he thinks that they can
be reasoned with gar is the first great
example of this that I can think of
someone that was so close to becoming a
psychotic monster thanks to who Naruto
is not his beu but because of the
decisions Naruto made gar was able to be
saved and the same has been true
countless times in this story it's
demonstrated time and again that the fox
Spirit could very easily have led to
Naruto's downfall both in a literal and
philosophical sense numerous times the
deciding factor wasn't the gift or curse
he was bestowed or burdened with by his
father but the perspective he looked at
the world through in other words Naruto
is where he is because of who he is not
what he has as many have pointed out
both in this battle and in the past
Naruto as a person is someone people
want to trust in to chase after and an
individual that brings out the very best
in
[Music]
everything
the conversation between Obito and
Naruto speaks to this reality this
philosophy that being altruistic honest
and everything else Naruto is is what
ultimately makes him successful in what
he sets out to do in this moment obido
acknowledges that he has the same will
and body as the sage of Six Paths his
gariki was the most powerful all of this
is true but in the same way all of
Naruto's Powers don't make him who he is
the power and potential isn't what's
important in this instance it's who you
are that ultimately determines what you
are speaking on a sort of mechanical
sense given that obido was a sympathetic
villain and a Fallen Hero I thought this
was a great way to cap off his
contribution to the story as an
antagonist the paneling by Kishimoto
employing a lot of white space was
fantastic in illustrating the difference
between Naruto and obido specifically
with Naruto surrounded by people his
comrades his friends people he's
inspired and uplifted to stand by him
and Obito standing on his own and
furthermore this whole sequence was an
apt chance to shift Focus from him to
uchia M further amplifying his fall from
where he was all that time ago volume 69
okay so the hype level is at 10 obido
has been reached but he's been abused
and used by MOA to bring him back to
life we're in the end game here we go
one thing I'll give Kishimoto credit for
in this Arc is that this absolutely
feels like the final battle of a series
it feels massive with each choice made
either having massive ramifications or
creating snapshots in time that I'll
definitely remember like all the tail
beast joining forces to take down MOA
for instance that said I need to draw
attention to something small but also
that's kind of irritated me for a while
MRA looks like he's in bad shape after
that attack and rightfully so he just
got a building dropped on him
effectively he lost his Iron Man All
That Jazz and then this dude shows up
gives him a hand literally and then MAA
pops an eyeball into his skull like it
was nothing now I have said anything
about this in the series before but why
is it that everyone in Naruto seems to
be able to pop in eyeballs into their
skulls like Lego I mean there's a host
of things that need to surgically
connect and happen back there I'm
willing to accept that ninja magic is
real in this world but I draw the line
there apparently but I digress stuff
does happen in this volume a whole lot
of stuff a little while ago in this Arc
I complained that certain characters
weren't used more throughout this story
like G for instance was an example of a
character in Prior videos that I made
however I'm thrilled that he's getting
to play quite a central role in this
story with this moment here bringing his
character full circle and to ahead
Kishimoto does utilize the last minute
flashback tricky loves to pull out but
it hasn't been used for a hot second and
this was really really good getting to
see the Oneil Beast thoughts on G and
his history with humans was interesting
and gain to see G do everything in his
power to try and protect someone he sees
as an equal was wonderful and ultimately
heartbreaking when they all eventually
fall to MAA including Kurama ripped from
Naruto for the first time in this story
Naruto doesn't have the fox Tales spirit
inside of him anymore something that he
would have wished and begged for at the
beginning of the story is now something
that is both tragic and a major blow to
both him and everyone around him now
that's character
development following the tense
Cliffhanger of a chapter that touted
both Sasuke and Naruto taken completely
out of commission and on the verge of
death I have to say that I was in near
disbelief with what Kishimoto managed to
do with the story after this now I say
disbelief not because it didn't make
sense but because it did I'm always so
interested and impressed when a story
that's so long and winding manages to
take all the broad story components that
make it so and tie everything together
neatly at the end and this scene dealing
with this drama does this in Spades it
left me with chills hype and above all
else emotionally devastated in ways I
never thought this story could leave me
the story of Kakashi and Obito has been
one that has lurked in the background of
this manga for quite some time slowly
we've seen the respective Back stories
how Kakashi received the eye how aito
lost his way and through struggle we're
now seeing him come back into becoming
himself it's honestly difficult to
concisely disclose my feelings on this
section so I'll just bounce off this
quote those who lead others never step
over their comrades corpses even if
their own ends up being stepped on I
adore literally everything about this
quote from the dire circumstances
leading up to it to the one deler
delivering the line to who they're
delivering the line to and what that
means in the broader context of the
story this is Obito's Best Line in the
entire series and another shining
example of how brilliantly thought out
and well conceived of and crafted by
Kishimoto this climactic battle was
there are callbacks to the unification
of Kakashi and Obito which draws us back
to quotes that alud to their power being
greater together than separated it
really makes for a fantastic coming full
circle for the character of Obito
himself in ways that make him more
interesting than most I've come across
in this story one that takes a naive but
virtuous character throws him down a
disillusionment path and through
Runnings with the main protagonist of
the story learns to find his way back to
the light that he once abandoned which
speaks to this quote he shares with
Naruto as he's trying to help him later
he says I've never been able to walk a
straight line but I've finally gotten to
where I needed to go the entire story
felt so fulfilling cathartic and
worthwhile I mean it when I say that
this part of the story was hitting me
exactly as Kishimoto wanted me to
experience it and broadly the same
happens with Sasuke albeit not due to
his direct input but instead his
brothers leading to Kabuto fulfilling
the place of Vito in Naruto's situation
the entire scenario is just so well
conceived of and performed that I'm
honestly thrilled with how everything is
going so much so the next part took me
entirely and completely off guard volume
70 Guy versus MOA I know I'm the guy
online that repeatedly says things are
the best or that such and such thing is
my favorite of all time Etc I'm a pretty
energetic person and when something
excites me in a story I honestly get
overcome with enthusiasm and energy
because of this when I'm reviewing a
story I need to express my enjoyment of
a particular choice I tend to use
hyperbolic statements when I can't
conceive of an effective way to convey
just how wonderfully a particular scene
or character has made me as a reader
feel however in hindsight I think what
started as an innocent exclamation of
agulation has become a crutch for me to
burden with the load of translating my
enthusiasm to you all as listeners Guy
versus MAA is a scene that does not
deserve such treatment it does not
deserve a shortcut it deserves my best
because this fight scene right here
moved and connected to me in ways that
no other part of the story has managed
to achieve and due to that I want to
take my time to explain why I am 30
years old and being 30 is weird you're
not really old yet but you're also not
really young either and coming to terms
with that second part has really
with me ever since turning 30 it sounds
redundant to say this but you spend your
whole life being young and a kid until
one day you're not and there was a
moment where I thought to myself how do
I not be a kid chasing a dream or goal
should I change should I stay the same a
lot of popular media details Coming of
Age stories where the na hero grows to
become a well-rounded adult in the
context of the story but once they
become the adult normally the story ends
so does my story end here is everything
after this boring what's next well I
think how Naruto answers this very
question is not only profound but
resonated with me in such a resounding
fashion I simply need to share my
experience I've spoken at length in
Prior videos concerning my appreciation
for kishimoto's tackling of the themes
of fostering the Next Generation through
characters like Naruto and Shikamaru
recognizing they need to adopt more
responsibility as they transition into
the new part of their lives but it's
gu's message that hits me like a ton of
bricks and that message is to find
meaning not in yourself but in what you
can leave behind for others Naruto's
greatest message for me Isn't when it
Embraces traditionally shown in stories
about overcoming your limits or
achieving your dreams with your friends
but ironically when it flirts with what
lies beyond your typical shown and
coming of age Tales when I turned 30 I
had had a crisis for my entire life I
was always in a phase where I was
working towards something for me to grow
up into something that could contribute
something meaningful but once I got
there I didn't know what else to do
other than coast and stare vacantly into
the void that was the rest of my life
apparently okay okay that's a little
dramatic but it's real and that's why
guy's Journey has been so impactful for
me I've never been the best at anything
in my life and to this day I still hold
that fact to be true I'm not the best
writer the best speaker debater reader
reviewer boss YouTuber brother son or
even husband but I want to be I love to
work hard and I try never to dwell on
the scrutiny of other people when they
review my content react to it or even
misrepresent it everyone and I mean
everyone is entitled to feel however
which way they want about me and my job
is to focus on what it is that I can
control and when I read pretty much the
exact same philosophy come out through
guys flashback my hands started to shake
and I paid closer attention I'm serious
as I watched this man after a life of
people belittling both him his father
and his pupil for their differences in
approach and ability to see him not only
motivate himself but find profound
meaning and resolve in the fostering of
the Next Generation and doing quite
literally everything in his power to
ensure that they have their chance to do
the same in the future for their future
Generations is a watershed moment for me
with this series guy by virtue of him
being the most human character has
delivered the most impact in this series
for me gorgeously depicted by Kishimoto
in these moments as he opens the eighth
and final gate for what he knows will be
his last time guy charges forward
unflinching and not looking back knowing
that he'll never return again because
what he achieves in his life is not
measured by himself but by the successes
of those who have been impacted and
loved by him broadly speaking Naruto and
Sasuke are the result of this world's
Heroes Warriors like Kakashi guy Asuma
shikaku Uka and countless others have
attempted to Foster the best attitude
possible out of them and in this same
breath we learned that Obito and the
Darkness he wrought onto the world was a
direct result of Mo's manipulations and
the opposite philosophy MAA in this
instance highlights what happens when
one can't find meaning in the lives of
others and the Next Generation striving
instead to do everything he can for
himself by himself and towards his own
goals with everything else including his
family friends and future Generations
acting as necessary damages for him to
reach his desired outcome I have no idea
what sort of entities Naruto and Sasuke
have become uh but what I do love about
it is the manner with which we're
basking in this Monumental yet daunting
moment Kakashi reflecting on the seeds
he's held to set long ago not taking
credit but honoring to be there
alongside them nevertheless whenever
they need him team seven is readying for
battle to save the world Kakashi
reminding them of their very first
lesson the importance of teamwork and
just it's so good okay so as things were
ramping up and the story felt as though
it was heading into the endgame I
decided to just binge the remaining
manga so here are my reactions to that
the infinite suomi once MOA activates it
and entrances everyone on Earth more
than lives up to its premise I thought
the visuals accompanying this are
striking and horrifying watching as
people are mummified while hanging like
cocoons from the branches of this
satanic tree was nothing short of
brilliant to watch how however shortly
after something happens something I know
a lot of you have been waiting for me to
talk about kaguya you know talking about
this I've realized is going to be a lose
lose if I like it people will hate me
for it and if I dislike it people will
also hate me for it but why do I say
this I've spent the last number of years
catching up on a number of series I've
neglected to start in the past some of
the most popular in the world like one
piece JoJo's Bizarre Adventure and
Hunter Hunter but out of all of these
Naruto seems to be the story that has
conversations surrounding it filled with
more love and hatred than anything I've
covered prior Naruto's original run took
place around the same time the majority
of people around the world started
routinely using the internet and in
addition to that was also released
around the same time as other popular
series like bleach and one piece
together the three properties became
known as The Big Three despite not being
present in these fandoms during this
time I can only imagine the level of
competitiveness that was fostered
between the various communities which
for a small number of people perhaps
fostered or encouraged some to attach a
portion of their own identity to their
given favorite one piece bleach or
Naruto and while I did get an impression
of this mindset during my review of one
piece I still found that to be largely
positive but when it came to Naruto not
just with my videos but in unrelated
conversations beneath tweets I would
make I couldn't believe how some of you
guys would treat each other like for
instance I was spoiled in intentionally
for my genuine honest attempt to share a
good faith impression of the scene and
creative choice and the only reason I
mention any of this is because Naruto is
one of the most enjoyable and positive
series I've read over the last few years
I've enjoyed it more than Hunter Hunter
and even JoJo's Bizarre Adventure with
one piece being the only one I found to
be more engaging consistently and that's
no small feed if you know how much I
loved one piece Naruto has this profound
ability to tug on my heartstrings while
also boasting one of the most endearing
main characters across the various
properties I've just mentioned it's a
story about cooperation caring for
people and fostering relationships but
look I don't want to belabor this point
too much so let's move on to my overall
thoughts on this scene what did I think
of kaguya despite what I understand
Kishimoto to have done with kaguya as a
concept and final main villain with her
for all intents and purposes
philosophically and literally embodying
the root of all suffering in the main
plot so to speak and despite the
terrific metaphor with M literally being
consumed by the darkness he's embraced
and brought to the world despite those
upsides I didn't find kaguya to be an
engaging final villain up until the
revealer for in the story kimono had
quite masterfully I thought managed to
tie every relevant piece of information
and respective character together to
form catharsis bombs that honestly made
this very long final fight so much
snappier than it otherwise would have
been without and an important component
within that for me was familiarity with
these characters for me Naruto was very
much a character-driven story Kakashi
nobo worked as a conflict in this
section because of their history
together and the various fights I
complained about earlier in the arc
didn't work for me because I didn't know
them as characters prior I wasn't
familiar with them I had no investment
emotionally and thus had to rely on one
side of conflict to try and carry my
interest yielding a less than Stellar
second act in the Shinobi War Arc in my
mind for me this is what happened with
the climax to this big fight while I was
thrilled with the cooperation and
camaraderie demonstrated with the likes
of Kakashi Sasuke Naruto and Sakura all
coming together for the final struggle
all I could think about was how much
better and more satisfying this would
have been had the target of these
attacks and co-opt efforts been someone
I cared about at all like MOA out of
virtually nowhere it felt as though Mara
someone that had been built up across
the entire story was abruptly benched in
favor of swapping out someone I
comparatively didn't care for at all and
honestly after that it felt as though
the story sort of forgot him but does
this mean I didn't like the ending does
this mean I didn't love the story of
this manga does this mean that I will
look back on my time with Naruto as a
tainted experience with which I can't
look past the
negativity hell no while this particular
choice is something I didn't personally
like or connect to very much it in no
way takes from my enjoyment of
everything that came after or before it
I hope something that I've made clear
during this review series Series has
been just how much fun I've been having
with this story and what I've Loved
about it unless the entire Narrative of
a given property is built around a
singular moment in time then I find it
difficult to relate to those that say
this moment ruined the story for them in
the same way a good ending doesn't
retroactively make a Bad series good a
lackluster conclusion to a fight doesn't
retroactively make a good series Bad
speaking of someone that loved how
Dragon Ball super anime came to an end
I'll also say it doesn't by virtue of
its existence make those boring or
uninspired moments in the middle any
more palatable for me and that's not to
say that this final Conflict didn't have
some killer emotional gut punches either
by the way watching Sakura Sasuke and
Naruto delivered the final blow to kagio
was a terrific moment and Obito's gift
and paring conversation with Kakashi was
spectacular way back when I started the
story I would have never imagined that
Kakashi would end up being one of the
most important and Central characters to
this story and that's sort of what I'm
driving at here this wasn't just a
singular isolated moment or collection
of moments it was a long journey there
are 72 volumes in this series which
detail a story of a lonely child with a
dream of one day making something of
himself despite his detractors and upon
that mission statement this story more
than delivers on that front and speaking
of which this fight's ending despite it
not being something I resonated with it
also wasn't the ending of this story and
funnily enough everything after this
fight offered yet more stuff I did enjoy
Sasuke versus Naruto
it's difficult to disconnect my feelings
on this final Conflict from my feelings
on this entire story again like most
aspects of this finale section of the
story it's handled brilliantly filled
with callbacks to words that have been
exchanged between the two self- admitted
best friends with two diametrically
opposed outlooks on life in more ways
than one this felt like what happens
when an Unstoppable Force meets an
immovable object which to be honest is
fitting given the characters we have in
question here with the anime's rendition
of what was presented in the manga
pulling out all the stops leaving my jaw
firmly on the floor the animation was
spectacular to say however that I didn't
expect this to be the way the series
would round things out would be a lie
however I felt a long time ago that this
would be the best way to end things and
it was it felt a little corny or
simplistic at times particularly after
the complex web of converging plot lines
in the last battle but that could very
easily be to its benefit depending on
your point of view I felt extremely
conflicted during this battle and to be
honest in a good way while I felt like a
knew what the outcome would be I wasn't
ready to put money on it either the
ending to this fight felt satisfying
albeit a bit extreme given the
motivations involved but then again they
are essentially gods in the bodies of
children so it did make sense in the end
true to his character Naruto once again
proves that he can win over even the
most stubborn of Minds all the while
making good on his longtime promise to
Sakura I would have liked if Sasuke
stayed with the village for a little
longer than he did but I can understand
his mindset for leaving too I guess he's
a complicated guy overall the final
class between Naruto and Sasuke was epic
not in scope but in Impact here we have
the longest rivalry in the story come to
its natural conclusion with an
appropriate level of emotion and
narrative callbacks employed to help tie
it all together which finally after all
this time brings me to the Final Chapter
this is the perfect ending for Naruto in
my mind it's simple it's a mirror image
of the very first chapter and I loved it
the entire story of Naruto itself has
been that of a young man's to achieving
his desired goal of becoming Hokage and
so for it to end with his coronation
while showing off where everyone else is
at was hugely enjoyable getting to see
Shikamaru Hinata choji Eno Sakura and
all of the other Central supporting
characters find their places in the
village felt fitting for sure but it's
also only part of what I loved about
this final chapter and indeed this
series at large I've touched on this
numerous times in this video and across
this series I've written while this is a
story of one character's Journey it's
also a story of how that one character
connects to and grows alongside others
in his life what they become where they
each Find meaning in their lives and
what they ultimately leave behind and
while this Arc did a fantastic job of
showing Naruto's struggle towards his
ultimate goal its ending also emphasizes
another Central Point to the story that
life goes on and that there's more than
just the goals immediately in front of
you alongside the coming of age heroes
we've witnessed the lives of across this
story were also introduced to the next
generation the Next Generation that can
only exist when one fights for and finds
meaning in a tomorrow they might never
see to Foster The Young and to be
remembered long after you've drawn your
final breath and that's such a wonderful
sentiment to end this incredible journey
with at the beginning of every one of
these 72 volumes that comprise this
story Kishimoto writes a short paragraph
discussing everything from it struggles
to his gratitude to his milestones and
on this final volume we wrote this this
is my final volume thank you so much for
your support these past 15 years I'd be
honored if in the future you
occasionally recall that there was once
a character named Naruto well then
please enjoy the conclusion to Naruto in
my very first videos covering Naruto I
discussed the story behind Masashi
kishimoto's road to eventually achieving
his dream of becoming a mangaa a story
of a young man struggling to attain his
goal in an incredibly competitive
industry a story of a young person who
struggled to get noticed to not be
forgotten together Kishimoto and the
character of Naruto helped each other
achieve their respective dreams a
character that was once incredibly
lonely found lasting friendships and
support and the struggling artist found
worldwide a claim and success through
his own inspirational story I can
confidently say that for as long as I
live I will neither forget the story of
Naruto or indeed the legend of mashi
[Music]
Kishimoto cultivate hunger before you
idealize motivate your hunger to make
them more realiz CL in the mountain
never coming down Breck into the content
Never Falling
[Music]
Down